THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND TODAY'S
HEARING IS FOCUSED ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO READ SOME INSTRUCTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING THE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM I WILL SKIP THAT PART
SEEING NO PUBLIC HERE AT THE
MOMENT I WILL THEN DESCRIBE FOR
THE PANELISTS THAT ALL
PANELISTS WHO ARE ON THE AGENDA
ARE APPEARING REMOTELY USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL
BE NO VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND ALSO SHOULD BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. ALL PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
TAKEN ON ISSUES IN THE AGENDA
INCLUDING THE NON PRESENTATION
ISSUES ISSUES SIX THROUGH
TWENTY AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. UPON CONCLUSION OF
PANEL FIVE. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN TODAY WITH SOME.
PRELIMINARY COMMENTS IF I
COULD. BECAUSE I CANNOT
UNDERESTIMATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. I FIRST WANT
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS. MENTAL HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRETORS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE L.
A. O. N. D. U. O. F. FOR
HELPING. US TO PUT ON TODAY'S
HEARING BUT I ONLY GOT FIVE
HEARINGS IN A YEAR AND WE'VE
DEDICATED AN ENTIRE HEARING
TODAY TO THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CRISIS. MANY OF US HAVE TALKED
ABOUT HOW COOPER IN NINETEEN IS
AN EARTHQUAKE THAT HAS HAPPENED
OFF OUR SHORES. AND THAT SOON
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A TSUNAMI
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISES
HITTING OUR SHORES. WHAT WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE FROM THE KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION IS THAT PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS WERE EXPERIENCING
ANXIETY OR DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS.
BUT SINCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN WE
ARE NOW AT FOUR OUT OF TEN
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS OF
ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION. WE ARE
SEEING INCREASING NUMBERS AS
WELL DISPROPORTIONATELY IN OUR
YOUNG ADULTS. THOSE WHO ARE
FACING ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS WERE
THOSE WHO COME FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. WE ARE SEEING
INCREASED SYMPTOMS AS WELL IN
OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND IT
IS BECAUSE OF THIS THAT IT
TAKES US TO HAVE AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK MENTALITY HERE TODAY.
WE WILL INVESTIGATE WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO REDUCE THE DISPARITIES
AND TO ADDRESS WHAT MANY SAY IS
REACHING A YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN THE UNITED STATES. I
DO WANT TO APPRECIATE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE KEVIN MCCARTY WILL BE
JOINING US LATER. AS WE WILL
NEED DEVELOPMENT OF CROSS
SYSTEM PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP
BREAK DOWN THE SILOS AND STIGMA
THAT OCCUR BETWEEN EDUCATION
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
I AM EXCITED TO LEARN ABOUT THE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. FOR
INCREASED ACCESS TO STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES SO
WE CAN FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION. WE WILL
ALSO GET TODAY AN UPDATE ON THE
YOUTH DROP IN CENTRES EARLY
PSYCHOSIS AS WELL AS THE ALL
CHILDREN THRIVE PILOTS BUT WE
CANNOT FORGET THE DEATHS OF
DESPAIR OR THE GOOD WORK BEING
DONE BY CAUGHT MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS. OR THE
MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THEY'RE STRIVING FOR ZERO A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AND WE WILL WANTS
TO HEAR ABOUT CAL HOPE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE CDC
GRANTS THE DPH HAS RECEIVED. OR
WE WILL AS WELL AS HEARING
ABOUT THE NEED TO DEMONSTRATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
STREAMLINING RESPONSIBILITY
WITH THE COMMUNITY CARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT FOR
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL IN THE
PHONY I S. T. POPULATION AND
WHILE WE DEAL WITH MANY OF
THESE COMPLEX ISSUES WE MUST
ALSO PREPARE FOR THE NEED FOR A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES. TO ADDRESS THE SHORT
TERM CRISIS STABILIZATION ACUTE
NEEDS PEER RESPITE AND OTHER
LONG TERM TREATMENT AND
REHABILITATION OPPORTUNITIES
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION OF HOW SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME OVER
THREE YEARS GETS DISTRIBUTED
EQUITABLY. AND WHILE OUR SUB
COMMITTEE IS JOINTLY SPONSORING
TWO INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON
CALAMP ON MARCH NINTH AS WELL
AS MARCH SIXTEENTH WITH A SAID
ASSEMBLY HEALTH. THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH KELLY IN PROPOSALS ARE
ALSO MENTIONED HERE MORE
GENERALLY INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF A NEW ENHANCED CARE
BENEFIT AND IN LIEU OF
SERVICES. IT IS ENCOURAGING TO
WORK WITH AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS COLLABORATIVE THAT IS
INNOVATIVE AND FORWARD THINKING
IN THIS AREA AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S HEARING AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING. WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO LET'S BEGIN. IF WE
CAN HAVE OUR FIRST PANELISTS
BEGAN. FOR THE PANELISTS PLEASE
PRESENT IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
NAME APPEARS IN THE AGENDA. WE
HAVE EIGHT PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL INCLUDING WILL LIGHT BORN
J. C. COOPER STEPHANIE
CLENDENIN. ARTEN YES YA RAMIREZ
MEDINA I WILL STILL TOBY EWING
VERONICA KELLY AND MICHELLE
CABRERA WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED
LET'S BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR LIKE
BORN. GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON. JEROBOAM OF TOO MANY
NUMBERS ON TIME IS LATE I WILL
BE BRIEF AND MY INTRODUCTION
CALL BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA HOME WITH
KAISER HEALTH ON A STUDY POINTS
TO THOSE SHARP INCREASE IN AND-
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING. EXTREME. STRESS
THOSE- ADULTS HOME DECOR SAYS.
ON AFRICAN LATINOS OF ITS YOUNG
PEOPLE SO- MOTHERS CARING FOR
CHILDREN AT HOME. ONE SO JUST
TO MAKE THE OBVIOUS. ABOUT
THESE NEEDS AND PRESSURES-
LANDING ON TOP OF WILL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
INADEQUATE- B. AS YOU MENTIONED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- PROPOSES
A NUMBER OF ALL RECORDING
STRAPS THE MUSIC WILL HELP
GROCERIES BOTH THE SCHOOLS
INITIATIVE WITH FEDERAL HEALTH
PLAN FOR STRUCTURE. AND OF
COURSE THE TELLING. BUT SINCE
TIME IS SHORT LET ME ALL TURN
TO CHIEF DEPUTY AND STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR J. C. COOPER
TOUR OF REFLECT MORE DETAIL ON
THE CONDEMNING. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE J. C. COOPER I THANK
AT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO DO YOU SEE S.
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IMMEDIATELY RESPONDED
WITH SIXTY TO SEVENTY
POSSIBILITIES- ARE MET WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO EXPAND BENEFITS
ELIGIBILITY PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION FINANCING- EVEN
LAUNCHING A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
ADVERSE- NURSE ADVICE LINE. IS
THE BEHAVIORAL HOLD THOUGH- TO
FOCUS ON THE PURPOSE OF THE
HEARING TODAY WE RECEIVED A
NUMBER OF FLEXIBILITIES FROM
CMS THE DEA SAM SET AND AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER- TO ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBILITY DINNER DIY PROGRAM
AND OUR LICENSING AREAS. FOR
FINANCING WE INCREASED INTERIM
RATES DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY TO MITIGATE THE
DECREASING UTILIZATION REVENUES
OF THE COUNTIES MAY BE SEEING-
IT WILL BE SUBJECT TO FINAL
COST RECONCILIATION BUT IT WAS
SOMETHING WE DID EARLY AND THE
PANDEMIC TO ENSURE THERE WAS A
REGULAR CASH FLOW. MOVING TO
THE COUNTY PARTNERS WE ALSO
INCREASED ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
REIMBURSEMENT LIMITS FROM 15%
230% DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN TO ENSURE THAT-
COSTS LIKE PP AND TELEHEALTH
EQUIPMENT FOR PROVIDERS AND
STAFF WERE ALLOWED COSTS FOR
DELIVERING SERVICES AT FOUR
COUNTY PROVIDERS. DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. ON THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM SIDE WE CLIP
QUICK IMPLEMENTED. OF ACROSS
THE ENTIRE DELIVERY SYSTEM BUT
SPECIFICALLY ALSO WITHIN THE
MENTAL HEALTH IN S. U. D.
SYSTEM PRIOR TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WE HAD SEEN
SOME TELEHEALTH BUT WE THOUGHT
GREATLY EXPANDED- AS YOU COULD
SEE FROM SOME OF THE SLIDES. IN
THE AGENDA AS WELL. WE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED VARIOUS
POSSIBILITIES. REGARDING OUR
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE TYPES OF
SERVICES ALTERNATIVE SITES
STAFFING FLEXIBILITY AND
LICENSE FUNDS ABILITIES DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU SAW FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SOCIAL SERVICES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO MODIFY
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS
INCLUDING AUDITING SCHEDULES TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD. YOU TO
REPORTING AND OTHER VARIOUS
BURDENS DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. ME
IMPLEMENTED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT POSSIBILITIES LAST
YEAR AND PROPOSED IN THIS
BUDGET. WE IMPLEMENTED CAL HOPE
WHICH WE WILL SPEAK TO LATER IN
THIS HEARING. WE ALSO DURING
TIMES OF SURGE IMMEDIATELY
STEPPED UP TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS- IN
HAVE REGULAR COMMUNICATION WITH
HOSPITALS COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FACILITIES AND WORK WITH
THEM TO IDENTIFY ISSUES. PUT UP
ADDITIONAL REQUESTED CMS WE
HAVE SOME PENDING NOW FOR
EXAMPLE FOR CRISIS
STABILIZATION FLEXIBILITIES FOR
OUR- COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AS WELL AS WORKS
CLOSELY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ENSURE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF
RECEIVED PRODUCT OF
VACCINATIONS. AND THAT IS THE-
CONCLUSION OF OUR UPDATE WILL
TURN TO THE NEXT- INDIVIDUALS
ON THE PANEL. YEAH STEP CLINTON
DIRECT FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS AND I'M
PRESENTING ON THE STATE
HOSPITALS PANDEMIC RESPONSE THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
PRESENTED UNIQUE CHALLENGES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS SYSTEM. OUR HOSPITALS
ARE LARGE CONGREGATE CARE
ENVIRONMENT SERVING INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
MANY WITH COMPLEX MEDICAL
CONDITIONS WE QUICKLY RECOGNIZE
THE THREAT THAT KEVIN NINETEEN
PRESENTED FOR OUR SYSTEM OF
CHECKS OF STANGEL MEASURES TO
MITIGATE REST. OUR RESPONSE CAN
REALLY BE CHARACTERIZING FOUR
STAGES THE FIRST AS OUR INITIAL
RESPONSE RIGHT WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE FIRST SIXTY DAYS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND REALLY RECOGNIZE
IS REALLY AROUND RECOGNIZING
THE THREAT AND TAKING IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO MITIGATE THE RISK OF
COVER NINETEEN. ACTIVATED ARE
DIMMER ARE MERGING ZERO
OPERATIONS CENTER AND REALLY
BEGAN TO WORK ON IMPLEMENTING
IMPLEMENTING INFECTION CONTROL
MEASURES TO ADDRESS EACH OF THE
FACTORS. OF CO IN NINETEEN AND
HER SYSTEM LOOKING AT- HOW IT
COULD COME IN ON OUR STAFF. OUR
VISITORS TO OUR HOSPITALS AND
OUR PATIENTS. ARE WE SUSPENDED
PATIENT ADMISSIONS DURING THIS
TIME AND PATIENT VISITING.
IMPLEMENTED DAILY STAFF
SCREENING. DEVELOPED QUARANTINE
AND ISOLATION PROTOCOLS AND HOW
TO PREPARE SPACES WITHIN OUR
HOSPITALS TO SERVICE ISOLATIONS
IN QUARANTINE SPACES FOR
PERSONS ABOUT AT. UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR. CALL THE
NINETEENTH WE HAVE PROCURE PP
AND IMPLEMENT PROTOCOLS AROUND
PP. WE HAD TO DEVELOP TREATMENT
PROTOCOLS AND CONTACT AND
TESTING PROTOCOLS. AND
CONTRACTED LABORATORIES FOR. WE
BUY FOR ENHANCED AT CLEANING
AND SANITATION ON THE ON. I WE
HAD TO DEVELOP EMISSIONS
PATIENT ADMISSION PROTOCOLS
AND- CREATE A MISSION
OBSERVATION UNIT SO THAT WE CAN
SAFELY ADMIT PATIENTS INTO OUR
ENTIRE HOSPITALS YOU MAY HAVE A
CO THAT NINETEEN WE WORK WITH
OUR TO OUR PARTNERS AT CDC ARE
IN THE SHERIFF'S TO DEVELOP
TRANSFER COVER. ALL BETWEEN OUR
SYSTEMS AND ROUTE THIS INITIAL
PHASE WE WERE ALSO CONSULTING
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
COLLEAGUES OVER A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH CARE FIRED
INFECTIONS TEAM AND UTILIZING
THE EXPERTISE OF THE HEALTHCARE
ACQUIRED INFECTIONS TEAM IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MANY OF OUR
PRODUCTS. ALL TO OF OUR
RESPONSE REALLY WAS AROUND RE
OPENING- THIS WAS A YOU KNOW
REOPENING TO ADMISSIONS- THIS
IS AT THE TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA
WAS RE OPENING AS WELL AND WE
STARTED TO SEE AN AT YOUR
SURGEON CASES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE AS A
HOSPITAL SYSTEM HAS STARTED TO
EXPERIENCE OUR FIRST OPERATES
AND THIS WAS REALLY OUR FIRST
TEST OF OUR PROTOCOLS. AND
DURING THE SUMMER WE WORK TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE OUTBREAKS
THAT DID OCCUR IN OUR
HOSPITALS. AND REALLY REFINING
AND MAIL MONITORING TRENDS
REFINING OUR STRATEGIES. AND IS
INVOLVED FURTHER CONSULTATIONS
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ACTUALLY VISITS FROM
THEIR INFECTION PREVENTION AS I
HAVE TO REALLY THINK HER
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
ALL THE SUPPORT THEY PROVIDED
US THROUGH THIS WEEKEND AND I.
AM THIRD STAGE MILLIONS AROUND
THE SURGE- WE- EXPERIENCE
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA DADDY SURGE
DURING THE MONTHS I'VE HAD
DECEMBER IN JANUARY. WE SAW
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN CASES
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. INITIALLY
STARTED TO SEE THIS RIGHT AFTER
THE THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY- SAW
SIGNIFICANT RAMP UP IN OUR
STOCK- CASES AND THEN WHICH
TRANSLATED INTO POSITIVE CASES
AND WE BEGAN WORKING WITH THE
ODD TESTING TASKFORCE TO
DISCUSS ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES
THAT WE CAN DO. TO HELP
MITIGATE AND THIS INCREASE IN
AND IN CHASEZ AND ULTIMATELY WE
DID IMPLEMENT ANTIGEN TESTING-
IN OUR HOSPITALS ON A DAILY
BASIS TO HELP US. KIND OF BEEN
THAT CURVES- IF YOU WELL OVER
THE COURSE THE PANDEMIC NINE
THROUGH THE END OF JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WE HAVE HAD
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN PATIENTS STATEWIDE
WHO HAVE BEEN POSITIVE FOR
COVER NINETEEN. 68% OF THOSE
OCCURRED DURING THIS DECEMBER
AND JANUARY SEARCH. SHE DID TO
THE INCREASE CASES DURING THE
SURGE WE SAW AS A STAFFING
CHALLENGES AS WELL WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SHOULD CHANGE BIRDS AT
SEA NURSING STAFFING TO HELP
ENSURE THAT WE COULD. MAINTAIN
OUR OUR NURSING RATIOS AND
REQUIRED STAFFING. AND WE ALSO
ASSIGN IMPACT TO ADMISSIONS
AGAIN DURING THIS TIME I DO TOO
THE NUMBER OF UNITS THAT WE HAD
ON QUARANTINE AS WELL AS
IMPACTS AND INCOME THE POSITIVE
ACTIVITY IN IN OUR ADMISSION
OBSERVATION UNITS. STAGE FOUR
HAS REALLY BEEN A VERY EXCITING
STAGE FOR US THIS IS BANNED-
THE VACCINATION AND POSTERS- OP
OPERATIONS STAGE. OF WITH
RESPECT TO VACCINATIONS WE
BEGAN RECEIVING VACCINATIONS-
OF- SHIPMENTS IN THE LAST WEEK
OF DECEMBER AND INITIAL ONLY-
ALONG WITH PHASE ONE A
PRIORITIZATION- TIES BACK. OUR
HEALTH WORKFORCE AS AND AB BE
FOCUSED ON THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE IN OUR HOSPITALS THAT
HAVE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
INITIALLY WHAT WE HAD WHEN WE
HAD I'M SMALL SHIPMENTS
INITIALLY. AT OVERTIME- THROUGH
JANUARY WE RECIEVED- ADDITIONAL
SHIPMENTS OF THE VACCINE WERE
ABLE TO OFFER TO ALL OF OUR
STAFF AS WELL AS TO OUR
PATIENTS- SO ALL OF OUR STAFF
AND ALL OF OUR PATIENTS HAVE
BEEN OFFERED THE VACCINE AND TO
DATE WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY 65%
OF OUR STAFF. AND 80% OF OUR
PATIENTS WHO RECEIVED AT LEAST
THEIR FIRST AS MANY NOW HAVE
RECEIVED THEIR SECOND DOSE.
WITH THE COMBINATION OF OUR
INFECTION CONTROL EFFORTS ARE
DALY ANTIGEN TESTING AND OUR
HIGH VACCINATION RATES WE'VE
SEEN A SUBSTANTIAL AND RAPID
DECLINE IN THE NEW POSITIVE
CASES IN THE RECENT WEEKS. IN
FACT IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE'VE HAD
ZERO POSITIVE PATIENT CASES-
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ONE AND
THAT WAS A NEW ADMISSION WHO
CAME IN FROM- CDC ARE. POSITIVE
AND- DURING THE HIGH AND JUST
ACROSS THAT THE- HEIGHT OF THE-
WE WERE SEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NEW PATIENTS-
POSITIVE CASES DURING THE WEEK.
THE AGENDA ACCESS TO DISCUSS
AND TO PROPOSALS I RELATED TO-
CODE NINETEEN THE FIRST WAS OUR
PORTION OFTHE STATE RIGHT CO
THE NINETEEN EXPENDITURE BE
SEEKING. A WE'RE REQUESTING
FIFTY TWO MILLION AND BUDGET
YEAR TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
CONTINUED RESPONSE- THROUGH
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. THIS INCLUDES A FUNDING
FOR ALL OF THE PERSONAL
SERVICES THAT WE ANY AND
TESTING AND THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE RESPONSE.
JACOBI NINETEEN THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY INFECTION PREVENTION
S. B. C. P. WE'RE REQUESTING
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
AND TWO POSITIONS FOR INFECTION
PREVENTION NEST. ARE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES OPERATED AT
DMCH METROPOLITAN INDIA STATES
NOT BUT AS REQUIRED. BY AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR. AND YES
AGE NOT- SIX SKINNER FACILITY
IN THE US METRIC YES IT METRO
HOW A HIGH AND TWO EVENTS. IN
MAY OF TWO SEEN. ISSUED OFFICE
ON THESE LETTERS THAT RICK
SKILLS FACILITIES TO HAVE
DEDICATED INFECTION PREVENTION
NEST AND TO MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT WE NEED WE HAD TO
RE DIRECTOR POSITION AT METRO
AND NAPA. AND AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR MAKES THIS
REQUIREMENT PERMANENT SO WE
ARE. REQUESTING THE ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR THOSE POSITIONS.
AS WE WERE I WAS ASKED TO ALSO
SHARE LESSONS LEARNED ABOUT OUR
STATE HOSPITALS BEING PREPARED
TO RESPOND TO A PANDEMIC IT'S-
OUR- HOSPITAL'S URGENT
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS AND- WE
HAVE PANDEMIC RESPONSE PLANS
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT OF OUR
HOSPITALS. I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
THOUGH THAT THEY WERE BUILT ON
THEORY AND NOT REALLY BUILT ON
ANY REAL EXPERTISE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO BE- I TO RESPOND TO A
PANDEMIC SUCH AS- WE ARE
CURRENTLY RESPONDING TO. AND SO
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LESSONS
LEARNED- DEFINITELY NEED THE-
STATE HOSPITALS OF THE FUTURE
ARE GOING TO LEARN FROM THE
ACTUAL PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE
THAT WE'VE WE- RECEIVED. AND
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT ONE
OF THE BIG LESSONS LEARNED THAT
WE DID- EXPERIENCE PARTICULARLY
OVER THE SUMMER WAS AROUND I'M
SEARCH CAPACITY AND PLANNING
FOR SURGE CAPACITY THAT WAS ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAD
I'M FROM OUR PANDEMIC I'M IN
OUR PANDEMIC RESPONSE PLANS.
AND WE YOU KNOW DID I DEVELOP
ISOLATION UNITS INITIALLY I
HAVE FOR THAT RESPONDING TO-
POSITIVE CASES ARE HOSPITALS
BUT ULTIMATELY VERY QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT IT IN A SURGE
THAT WOULD NOT BE SUFFICIENT
AND SO WE HAD TO. AT OVER THE
SUMMER WORK TO PREPARE FOR THE
POTENTIAL SURGE IN THE IN THE
WINTER AND IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
HAD A SURGE CAPACITY FOR OUR
HOSPITALS AND BOTH WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES AND ALSO I HAD TO
CONTRACT- WITH CDC ARE TO
UTILIZE- THAT A SOUTHERN USE
RECEPTION CENTER IN NORWALK TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SPACE FOR US TO DECOMPRESS THE
HOSPITALS IF NEEDED. I AND WE
DID ALTERNATELY HAVE TO UTILIZE
THAT FACILITY- IN IN THE-
DURING THE SEARCH. SH AND THE
ALSO WAS TO TALK ABOUT AND DUST
MITE I'M GONNA ASK MY OUR
MEDICAL. DR KEEP WERE BURTON
TO- HOP ON- AFTER FINISH UP THE
LAST QUESTION TO- PROVIDE- THE
DEPTH YEAH FOR AROUND- ARE
DEATHS. BUT THE LAST QUESTION
ON AGENDA BE SHE- HOPS ON IS TO
WAS AROUND I'M PROVIDING
RESPONSE TO ALLEGATIONS MADE BY
OUR COALINGA STATE HOSPITAL
PATIENTS. AND PER SE WOULD LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THE PERSPECTIVES
AND EXPERIENCE OF ALL OF OUR
STATE HOSPITAL PATIENTS DURING
THIS PAST YEAR IT'S BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME TO LIVE IN ANY
CONGREGATE YOUR ENVIRONMENT
INCLUDING OUR STATE HOSPITALS.
THE PATIENTS MANY OF WHOM HAVE
SIGNIFICANT OKAY NINETEEN
MEDICAL RISK FACTORS ARE
CONCERNED FOR THE HEALTH AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. ADDITIONALLY
THEIR LIVES HAVE BEEN DISRUPTED
BY THE CHANGES THAT WE'VEHAD
TO MAKE IT OUR SYSTEM IN ORDER
TO MITIGATE THE WRAP DRESS. AND
I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE PATIENTS.
FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS AS WELL
TEN TRACTION CONTROL AS THEIR
EFFORTS TO FOLLOW FOR THE
NINETEEN PROTOCOLS WASHING
THEIR HANDS SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND WEARING MASKS ALSO ASSIST
WITH INFECTION CONTROL THEIR
HOSPITALS. WITH RESPECTIVE
ALLEGATIONS THEMSELVES ALL OF
OUR HOSPITALS INCLUDING
COALINGA STATE HOSPITAL HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY DEDICATED AND
COMMITTED TO MITIGATING THE
RISK OF COVERAGE NINETEEN. EACH
OF OUR HOSPITALS FROM THE
LEADERSHIP ON DOWN THROUGH THE
ENTIRE TEAM HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY OVER THE PAST YEAR.
TO IMPLEMENT MEASURES HERE TO
INFECTION CONTROL PROTOCOLS AND
REDUCE THE REST. OF THE
NINETEEN AND TO CONTAIN ANY
OUTBREAKS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT AS LICENSE HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES EACH OF OUR
HOSPITALS IS RECEIVING
INFECTION CONTROL FOCUSED
REVIEWS BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. HEALTH
EVERY SIX WEEKS. RE SIX WEEKS
WE HAVE ON AN OUT REYES- BY
THEIR- BY THEIR SERVE. FINALLY
JUST ONE TO NOTE THAT COALINGA
STATE IS ONE OF THREE OF OUR
HOSPITALS THAT WERE LOCATED IN
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT WERE
MOST IMPACTED BY HOVIK NINETEEN
AND ALL THREE OF OUR HOSPITALS
IT WAS NOT JUST UNIQUE TO
COALINGA STATE HOSPITAL ALL
THREE OF OUR HOSPITALS IN THOSE
AREAS AND REGIONS OF THE STATE.
ARE BEING FRESNO COUNTY SANTA
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALL EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES DURING A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES DURING THE SEARCH.
SO WITHOUT A DOUBT DR WARBURTON
TO. RESPOND TO THIS QUESTION
REGARDING- PROVIDING A DAY
AVAILABLE DATA RELATED TO OUR
DEATHS. THANK YOU KATE
WARBURTON MEDICAL DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
THESE DATA ARE SPECIFIC TO TEST
WHILE OUR PATIENTS WERE
INFECTED WITH THE KOBE NINETEEN
VIRUS SO THIS REPRESENTS
EVERYONE WHO PASSED AWAY. AFTER
CODE NINETEEN A POSITIVE TEST
IT ALSO INCLUDES PATIENTS WHO
CONTRACTED THE VIRUS AND
SUCCUMBS TO IT WHILE AT
EXTERNAL MEDICAL FACILITIES
SUCH AS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. HOSPITALIZATIONS
97% HAD AT LEAST ONE OF THE CDC
DEFINED RISK FACTORS WITH AGE
BEING 83% OBESITY 42%
HYPERTENSION 1% TAKE MEETINGS
TWENTY TWO PERCENT. 69% HAD TWO
OR MORE RISK FACTORS 37% HAD
THREE OR FOUR RISK FACTORS. OF
NOTE 54% HAD A SCHIZOPHRENIA
SPECTRUM DIAGNOSIS WHICH IS AN
EMERGING DIAGNOSIS HASN'T
INDEPENDENT RISK FACTOR FOR
TOUGH FROM COVE IN NINETEEN.
12% OF THE PATIENTS THAT PASSED
AWAY WORK INTERNAL SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY PATIENTS AND
8% FOR EXTERNAL SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OUR- PATIENTS THE
AVERAGE CHANGE WAS SIXTY SEVEN.
YEARS OLD M. 79% OF THE
PATIENTS USED TO COME TO COVER
NINETEEN WERE MADE. BAIL THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE HEARING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OUR NEXT JADA MADE AS-
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU-
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT IS A SIXTY
MILLION COLLABORATIVE PROJECT-BETWEEN CITY PAGE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY. AND THIRTY FIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF ACCESS TO IN
RETENTION IN MENTAL HEALTH CARE
FOR FIVE HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THESE
INCLUDE AFTER FOR CAN MERICAN
ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER LATIN ACT
LGBTQ. FAN OF AMERICAN ME
COMMUNITIES. IN TOTAL FIFTY
COULD HAVE AWARDED AND EXECUTED
FORTY TWO CONTRACTS AND GRANTS
TO IMPLEMENT THE CRT CRT P.
PHASE TWO FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THESE CONTRACTS AND GRANTS ARE
COMPOSED OF THE FOLLOWING.
THERE'S A STATEWIDE EVALUATION
COMPONENT FIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER CONTRACTS
THIRTY FIVE IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECTS WHICH ARE
REFERRED TO AS IP PEACE
THROUGHOUT THIS PRESENTATION.
AND THE EDUCATION OUTREACH AND
AWARENESS CONSULTING CONTRACT
IN ADDITION AUXILIARY CONTRACTS
WERE AWARDED TO SUPPORT. LAUNCH
AND IMPLEMENT. THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY P. FACE TO INCLUDING FOR
KERMIT THE- SOLICITATION. I
DON'T COPY PLANNING FOR.
CULTURAL SERVICES AND I FEEL U.
P. PROJECT WEBSITE. THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY. APPROPRIATE
MOMENT THANK MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY FOR MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM. FIVE MILLION HAS BEEN
ALLOWED TO CDPH OF WHICH FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION WILL BE USED
TO PROVIDE UP TO THIRTY FIVE
PILOT PROJECTS. WITH GRANT
FUNDS TO EXPAND OR ENHANCE
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THREE MILLION HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES MEDICAL
MEDICARE OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIVISION THROUGH AN INTER
AGENCY AGREEMENT EXECUTED IN
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY.
TOGETHER CDPH AND IT FEELS
FORMER COOPERATIVE CALLED THE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY
PROJECT. A PROJECT DESIGNED TO
REDUCE THE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES THAT AFFECT AND
EXACERBATE CALIFORNIA'S MORE
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES CDPH AND
UCS HAVE IDENTIFIED THE FOB THE
FOLLOWING PRIMARY GOALS. M. S.
OF THE THIRTY FIVE POP PROJECTS
PROVIDING CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTICALLY RESPONSIVE CARE
ALLOWING THEM TO EXPAND OR
ENHANCE EXISTING MENTAL
SERVICES BUILD BRIDGES BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND PILOT PROJECTS TO
SHARE STRATEGIES. SORRY
PROVIDING CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RESPONSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SUPPORT
COMMUNITY EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO
THE COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THROUGH INTEGRATING TARGET
EFFORT INTO INTO PROJECT
DELIVERABLES. PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TRAINING TO
COUNTIES ON CULTURAL COMPETENCE
PLANS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
DATA COLLECTION THROUGH USING
AN EQUITY LAND. FORTY PAGE ONE
OFF OF HEALTH EQUITY OUR
PRIMARY FOCUS IS TO FUND UP TO
THIRTY FIVE PILOT PROJECTS AND
ENHANCE AND EXPAND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AWARDED SOME
ORGANIZATIONS AS MUCH AS TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THE DURATION OF THE PROJECT
WHICH ENDS JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FOR THEIR
PART DETAILS WILL BE CONTACTING
HEALTH EQUITY EXPERT TO DESIGN
TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SMALL PORTABLE
COMMUNITY KEPT. COUNTIES
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EFFORTS WILL TARGET
AND FOCUS ON GROWING COUNTY
KNOWLEDGE THROUGH MENTAL HEALTH
EQUITY. DATA AND RESEARCH AND
LINKING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WOOD COUNTY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LASTING
PARTNERSHIPS. IN REGARD TO THIS
YEAR THIRTY P. FUNDING TIMELINE
THE PROJECT IS SCHEDULED TO
SUNSET AND SPRING TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND FUNNY WILL BE NEEDED TO
SUSTAIN AND POTENTIALLY EXPAND
THOSE PRACTICES IDENTIFIED AS
VALUABLE DURING THE THIRTY P.
PILOT PROJECTS. THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY AND IT'S A
BUYER'S EXPIRY COMMITTEE HAVE
BEGUN ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THE FUTURE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THERAPY. IN
ADDITION SIX REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS WILL BE
SCHEDULED FOR LATE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO HIGHLIGHT KEY
FINDINGS FROM THE THIRTY P.
STATEWIDE EVALUATION AND THE
FINAL CONVENIENCE AWFUL.
PLANNED FOR OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THESE AND CONVENING
WILL PROVIDE FOR THE OP. TO
HIGHLIGHT AND SHOW THE
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES UTILIZED BY THE C. R.
D. P. SERVICE PROVIDERS. TO
ASSIST COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS ALONG
WITH THE VALUATIONS WHICH I'LL
DISCUSS NEXT THIS INFORMATION
WILL HELP IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES. THAT SHOULD BE
CONTINUED. THE THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY BASED ORGANIZATION ALSO
KNOWN AS I. P. P.'S LEVINE
IMPLEMENT AND EVALUATE THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY TO FIND.
EVIDENCE PRACTICE SERVICE OR
PROGRAM SOME OF THE PROJECT
HAVE PRELIMINARY FINDINGS AT
THIS TIME BUT OTHERS ARE STILL
FOCUSED ON GATHERING THEIR
PROCESS AND OUTCOME DATA THIS
IS PARTLY DUE TO UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES WE HAVE THE FIRES
OF ALL OF THAT STUFF AND THEN
MAKE. THAT FURTHER DELAY IN THE
DATA COLLECTION. HOWEVER THERE
IS AN EXTENSION OF NINE MONTHS
IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS CAN.
PROCESS AND COLLECT DATA WHICH
BOTH THE TO JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AT THE TIME I CAN GIVE YOU
A FEW EXAMPLES OF PILOT PROJECT
REPORTED PRELIMINARY FINDINGS
REPORTED SO FAR THERE'S A SAFE
PASSAGES AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION FIVE PP HAS PROVIDED
OVER SEVENTY SIX HUNDRED HOURS.
PERFORMING CENTER 4% OF
PARTICIPANTS REPORT AN INCREASE
IN MENTAL HEALTH OF PRODUCTIVE
PROTECTIVE FACTORS SUCH AS
CONNECTION TO CULTURE REDUCE
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION. AND
MARGINALIZATION SAN JOAQUIN
PRIDE CENTER HAS PROVIDED LGBTQ
COMPETENT COUNSELING TO TWO
HUNDRED LGBTQ YOUTH AND YOUTH
AND ADULTS. ON TOP OF REPORTED
OUTCOMES IS REDUCED. INDERJIT
FAURIA EXCITING AN INCREASE OF
SUBSTANCE BY FAMILY. THE LONG
CULTURE SAN OF THE COUNTY
PROVIDES. FROM LONG ELDERS AGE
FOR PLUS. 80% OF THE- HAVE A
THAT THE SERVICES THEY HAVE
RECEIVED HAVE HELPED THEM TALK
ABOUT AND DEAL WITH THEIR PAST
TRAUMA. LEADING TO A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE. MOUNTAIN DOT
THERAPY AND EDUCATION SERVICES
PART OF THE LOT NEXT HUB HAS
PROVIDED SERVICES TO OVER.
THREE HUNDRED LOW INCOME. RIGHT
NEXT TO ME MEMBERS CINEMA.
THERE COMPETENCIA PROVIDED A
OPENNESS PAID FOR TO ANY MEMBER
DRESS TRAUMA FEARS AND PROVIDE
TOOLS SUPPORT SO DRESSED
FEELING 90% PROTEST WERE THEY
FEEL COMPLETE SAFE FILL WELCOME
TO THEIR FOR FILL OF CAN THANK
YOU. A KEY PROTECT THE FACTOR
FROM THE WELLNESS WHILE THIS BY
MEANS OF THE LIST EXHAUSTIVELY
HOPEFULLY IT HIGHLIGHTS AND
POOR OF THESE. TO COMMUNITIES
AND PROVIDE MENTAL PREVENTION
AND EARLY AND FOR. THE
STATEWIDE ABOUT ASSESSES
OVERALL OF THE AND I DO NOT AND
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE MY HEALTH
BY THE PER POPULAR. IT ALSO
VIOLATES NEXT AFFECTING A THAT
YOU NEED FIND OF PRO. AS A
MENTAL HEALTH AND EARLY AND
STRATEGY FOR PER. ESTO THE
MENTOR HEALTH OF THE FIVE
PRIORITY PA. AS WELL TO A CASE
TO HELP AND. OF THAT SYSTEM. A
REP FROM THE SENATE WERE. TO
THE MAIN PRIMARY. DATA SOURCES
FOR THE STATE LIKE WIDE OF A-
INCLUDE A PRE POST PROGRAM.
SURVEY ADMINISTER BY SECURE
BASED OR. HOPEFULLY BASED
PROTECT US. AND HIM ANNUAL
REPORT OR- AND A PRO CORD DATE
EVERY BY NICK BASED ORGANIZED A.
THE THIRTY PCEVALUATE REPORT
WILL BE SIMILAR FOR THE FOR THE
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH HELLO.
FOR MARINO WILL NOT BE JOINING
US TODAY UNFORTUNATELY SHE WAS
UNABLE TO ATTEND GREAT WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO BE
EWING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
TODAY IN THIS IN CALL. AS
OUTLINED IN YOUR HEARING AGENDA
YOU'RE AWARE OF MANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS THAT HAVE
ARISEN BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
I DO I DO WANT TO JUST YOU KNOW
RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND OTHERS HAVE DONE.
TO REALLY STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO MENTAL
HEALTH WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH THEM. ON THE CAL
HOPE PROJECT AND SOME OF THEIR
OTHER INITIATIVES AND SO WE'VE
SEEN A TREMENDOUS RESPONSE FROM
OUR STATE PARTNERS AS WELL AS
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS. DESPITE
THAT AS YOU'RE AWARE BASED ON
THE ANALYSIS AND SOME OF THE
DATA THAT ARE IN THERE WE'RE
SEEING TREMENDOUS INCREASE NEED.
YOU MENTIONED THE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION'S WORK. WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOSS OF
TRADITIONAL SUPPORTS
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN.
ATTENDING SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN
LIKE ATTENDING WORK FOR ADULTS.
GIVES US SOME OF THE RESILIENCY
FACTORS THAT CAN HELP US DEAL
WITH STRESS AND TRAUMA. AND
MANY MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICULAR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES HAVE LOST THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE RATES OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT THAT ARE I NOTICED AT
THE MOMENT BECAUSE YOU CYNICAL
ACTIVE SO OFTEN REPORTED BY OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONS AND OUR
TEACHERS- THE WORK CONCERNED
ABOUT THE EDUCATIONAL SETBACKS
THAT CHILDREN HAVE FACED
BECAUSE THAT THE PANDEMIC. AND
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN REQUIRED
TO MOVE AWAY FROM SCHOOL INTO
PROVIDING ECONOMIC SUPPORT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES PARTICULARLY IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IF NOT
EXPLICITLY. AND AS YOU
MENTIONED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
FACING. OFTEN DEVASTATING
IMPACTS. IN TERMS OF THE STRESS
THAT THEY'RE UNDER THE ECONOMIC
STRESS HEALTHCARE STRESS. AND
LIMITED ACCESS TO CARE.
CERTAINLY ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WERE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN TERMS OF S.
U. D. NEED SUBSTANCE USE NEEDS-
GOING UNREPORTED OR ME OR
THEY'RE BEING ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING S. UT
SERVICES. THE SHIP THE VIRTUAL
CARE WHICH WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
HOW QUICKLY ARE COUNTY PARTNERS
AND THE STATE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
FACILITATE THAT SHIFT THE
RITUAL CARE. BUT IT'S AN
UNCERTAIN IMPACT IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES SOME OF OUR
COMMERCIAL PROVIDERS ARE
TELLING US THAT AS MANY AS 80%
OF THE CARE THAT THEY'RE
DELIVERING FOR MENTAL HEALTH IS
THROUGH VIRTUAL PLATFORMS- BUT
WE'RE ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT
CHILDREN IN PARTICULAR CAN FACE
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES. IN
ACCESSING CONFIDENTIALMENTAL
HEALTH CARE YOU VIRTUAL MEANS
BECAUSE THEY MAY NOT HAVE A
PRIVATE SPACE FOR WHICH TO
ENGAGE WITH THE THERAPISTS TALK
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THEY'RE
FACING THE CHECK LET THOSE
CHALLENGES ARE RELATED TO THEIR
FAMILY. AND OF COURSE IS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA WERE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT SUICIDE
RISKS AND SUICIDE RATES. M. I
WILL SHARE THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS A PROJECT ON MENTAL HEALTH
IN THE WORKPLACE. AND EVERY
EMPLOYER THAT WE HAVE TALKED TO
INCLUDING STATE AGENCIES IS
CONCERNED ABOUT ACCESS TO CARE
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES AND SO
WHILE MANY OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE TALK ABOUT. OUR OUR-
WE'RE SEEING THROUGH PUBLIC
PROGRAMS THROUGH MEDICARE
SYSTEMS WE'RE ALSO SEEING THESE
CHALLENGES FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
INSURANCE AND HAVE CONTINUED TO
RECEIVE. AN INCOME TO THEIR
JOBS I'M EVERY EMPLOYER WE
TALKED TO HAS SAID THAT THEY
ARE FACING TREMENDOUS MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. AND DIP AND
FACING DIFFICULTY IN SUPPORTING
THEIR EMPLOYEES. THE PANDEMIC
IT'S REALLY RUBIO HOW FRAGILE
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AS AND
IT THAT IT ALSO HAS REVEALED
THE OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE SYSTEMS. IN A
JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OKAY THAT'LL COME UP
IN MY TESTIMONY TODAY AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AROUND SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH. AROUND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE- WE ARE STILL
VERY MUCH IN A CRISIS MODE.
YEAH AND WE'RE WE'RE QUICKLY
GETTING THROUGH THIS CRISIS AS
THE STATE MAKES PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF VACCINE RATES AND
RECOVERY RATES AND TREATMENT.
FOR KOBE BUT THAT IT'S UNCLEAR
THAT WERE ACTUALLY READY FOR
THE POST. PANDEMIC MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS THAT OUR STATE
WILL HAVE. RESEARCH ON OTHER
CRISIS SHOWS THAT WE SEE. A
LACK THREE TO OFTEN THREE TO
FIND YOUR LACK. OF MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS COMING OUT OF
INVOLVEMENT IN A CRISIS I'M
THAT WITH SMALLER SCALE THAN
THIS PANDEMIC AND SO. IT IT'S
NOT CLEAR HOW WE WILL RESPOND
TO THE POST PANDEMIC MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS THROUGH OUR
SCHOOLS OR WORKPLACES AND SO-
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT IN TERMS OF SOME OF OUR
WORK. I'M I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
I THINK THAT WE HAVE. REALLY
SEEN THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC THE
WAY IN WHICH GOVERNMENT CAN
RESPOND IN UNDERSTANDING CODE
RATES. IN UNDERSTANDING
VACCINATION RATES IN REALLY
PUTTING TOGETHER THE RAPID
RESPONSE STRATEGIES IN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CAPACITY TO
DO THAT IS MUCH LESS MATURE.
BUT IT'S NEEDED NONETHELESS SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING WITH
YOU ABOUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AS A GENERAL STORE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI DR VERONICA KELLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR RUNNING
TO KELLY I AM THAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR FOR ST
BERNARDINO COUNTY EACH AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD JUST LIKE
TO START BY SAYING OFTENTIMES
WE SAYING CRISIS OR DISASTER
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ARE
SOME OF THE FIRST FOLKS IN AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE AT THE
LAST FOLKS OUT. WE ARE OFTEN
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
AND SERVICES FOR OVER A YEAR OR
LONGER AFTER THE END OF A
COMMUNITY DEVASTATING EVENT
JUST CONSIDER THE IMPACTS OF A
REGULAR DISASTER LIKE OUR FIRES
THE CREEK FIRE THE PARADISE
FIRE AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS KNOWS ALL TOO WELL OUR
DECEMBER SECOND TERRORIST
ATTACK HERE IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY IN WHICH MY STAFF WORKED
FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO FOLKS WHO
ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THAT.
AND NATIONALLY THERE ARE FEW
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAMS THAT
ARE FOCUSED SOLELY ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUPPORTS AND
HERE IN THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE LUCKY THAT WE
HAVE A SYSTEM OF COUNTY BASED
HIP HOP DEPARTMENTS. THAT HAVE
FOR A LONG TIME OPERATED TO
PROVIDE MUTUAL AID TO ONE
ANOTHER ON A PRETTY MUCH
VOLUNTARY SELF FINANCED AND
SELF COORDINATED BASIS. WHEN
COUNTIES IMPACTED FOR EXAMPLE
WITH AN EARTHQUAKE OR FIRE
COUNTIES PROVIDE MUTUAL AID TO
ONE ANOTHER TO SUPPORT
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL AND THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITY. TAKE THE
RIDGECREST TRONA EARTHQUAKE A
FEW YEARS AGO WE WORKED WITH
INYO COUNTY KERN COUNTY AND
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY TO
PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUPPORT TO THE ENTIRE REGION
HELPING ONE ANOTHER. BUT WHEN
THIS DISASTER CAME FOR COBIT.
AT OUR OWN SUPPORT OF ONE
ANOTHER IT WAS CERTAINLY NOT
ENOUGH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
STARTED PROVIDING MUTUAL AID TO
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE HAD TO FOCUS ON
RELIEVING PRESSURE FROM THE
HOSPITAL EDIE'S AND IN SOME
COUNTIES LIKE MINE WE STOOD UP
A SKILLED NURSING TASK FORCE.
SO THAT WE COULD ASSIST BASED
ON THE RIVER SIDE MODEL
ENSURING THAT STAFF REMAINED AT
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
CARING FOR OUR ELDERS RATHER
THAN LEAVE THEM TO DIE. AND
WHILE STATEWIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DISASTER PLANS NOTE THAT
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
THERE TO SUPPORT OTHERS IN A
DISASTER THERE'S NO MENTION OF
WHO WILL SUPPORT US. AND ASKED
TOBY JUST STATED CO BUT IS
REALLY SHONE A LIGHT ON AREAS
OF EXTREME CHALLENGE FOR COUNTY
ABOUT HOW. WE WOULD ARGUE AT
THE SAME TIME THAT IN ORDER FOR
THE STATE TO TRULY RECOVER FROM
THE COLLECTIVE TRAUMA THIS
EVENT THAT WE MUST MOVE FORWARD
AND REALLY FOCUSING ON BEHAVIOR
HEALTH. AND SPECIFICALLY IN
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SAFETY NEED.
THE STATE DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC IN
WORKING WITH C. B. H. J. IN OUR
MEMBERS TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
CRITICAL STRESS POINTS WHERE
POSSIBLE FOR EXAMPLE DUE TO THE
FACT THAT OUR SERVICES ARE COST
BASED. THEIR FEE FOR SERVICE
ONE OF PROVIDER LIKE A
RESIDENTIAL SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. PROVIDER EXPERIENCED
AN OUTBREAK OF COBIT. AND THEY
NEEDED TO ISOLATE OR QUARANTINE
STAFF AND PATIENTS. BILLABLE
SERVICES SLOW AND THAT ADDED
UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL STRESS TO
THE PROVIDERS WHO WERE WORRIED
THEY WOULD RUN OUT OF FUNDING
AND HAVE TO CLOSE BUT BY
IDENTIFYING THESE ISSUES CREEK
QUICKLY WE WERE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE H. TWO GAS TO SEEK OUT
SPECIFIC REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITIES TO ALLOW US TO
INCREASE SINCE WITHOUT PAYMENTS
TO PROVIDERS BEYOND WHAT OUR
TYPICAL PROTOCOLS ALLOWED IN JC
COOPER- TO THAT AND HER
PRESENTATION. HOWEVER IN OTHER
AREAS WE STRUGGLED WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE
NURSING HOMES AND HOSPITALS
REMAIN AT THE FOREFRONT AND
BECAUSE BOTH SETS OF FACILITIES
ARE LICENSED UNDER CDPH THEY
RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT
RESOURCES INCLUDING
PRIORITIZATION OF PP AND
DESIGNATED ALTERNATIVE CARE
SITES HOWEVER MANY OF OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE PROVIDERS ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH CLIENTS WITH
SIGNIFICANT PHYSICAL HEALTH
COMMITTEES AND THEY'RE LIVING
IN CONGREGATE CARE AND
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. YEAH WE A
WHOLE PROVIDERS WERE AND
CONTINUE TO BE LESS KNOWN AND
UNDERSTOOD AND DECIDING
PRIORITIZATION OF GP WORKFORCE
INFECTION CONTROL. GUIDANCE AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAS
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
SUPPORT WE REQUESTED THIS VERY
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC TO HELP
FUND TECHNOLOGY MOVE US TO A
PURELY TELEHEALTH MODEL- AND-
OUR- REPEATED REQUESTS WERE
DENIED. THE STATE AND OUR
BEHEST REQUESTED CMS WAVE THE
IMD EXCLUSION INSTITUTE FOR
MENTAL DISEASE EXCLUSION WHICH
PROHIBITS MEDICAL PAYMENTS MUST
BE EVER HEALTH TREATMENT
PROVIDERS THAT HELP MORE THAN
SIXTEEN BEDS. THIS REQUEST WAS
TWO ALLOWS ON A TEMPORARY BASIS
TO A DRAW DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS
THESE REQUESTS WERE ALSO DENIED
EACH TIME I SEE A MASS. AND
REFERRING TO THE PRESENTATION
AT DH CS PROVIDED AMAZING DATA
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE DATA PROVIDED ABOUT WHO IS
SERVED BY BOTH MANAGED CARE AND
OUR MENTAL HEALTH PLANS BUT A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY
DO. DOES NOT INCLUDE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES AND
REALLY ONLY FOCUSES ON BILLABLE
SERVICES. AT THE SAME TIME AS
WE KNOW DURING KOBE WE HAD A
LOT OF OTHER IMPACTS OUR STATE
HOSPITALS CLOSED AS WE HEARD
ABOUT TODAY- AS FAR AS
ADMISSIONS WHICH FURTHER
LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO ACCESS
HIGHER LEVELS OF CARE FOR OUR
PATIENTS. AND WHILE PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES DO DIP A LITTLE BIT
AND A CRISIS WE FEAR THAT AT
SOME POINT THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS ESPECIALLY
AMONG OUR CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
OUR NATIONAL AND STATE DATA. WE
SEEN FENTANYL RELATED OVERDOSES
INCREASE AND STAFFING AND THE
PHYSICAL PLANT OF WHERE OUR
SERVICE IS DELIVERED. ALSO
CAUSED A DIFFICULTY IN SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE WAY WE ARE WE
ARE STRUCTURED TO DELIVER
SERVICES. AND PROVIDERS ARE
REALLY CAUGHT IN A BIND
STRUGGLING TO RETAIN THEIR
STAFF I'VE HAD THREE OF MY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF DIE OF
KOBE IN THE PAST MONTH. WE HAVE
HAD COUNTLESS STAFF WHO LOST
THEIR SIGNIFICANT OTHER THEIR
PARENT THEIR CHILDREN TO THIS
VIRUS AND YET. MANY STILL COME
TO WORK. IN FACT IN ONE AREA OF
OUR COUNTY IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND VICTORVILLE IN
BARSTOW AREA THAT SERVE ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND OPEN CASES
EVERYONE OF OUR PSYCHIATRIC
NURSES HAD KOBE AND THEY WERE
ALL OUT AT THE SAME TIME. THESE
ARE NURSES WHO GIVE. LONG
ACTING ANTI PSYCHOTIC
INJECTIONS AND MEDICATED
ASSISTED TREATMENT TO OUR
CLIENTS THERE WAS NO ONE TO
PROVIDE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR RELATIONSHIPS
THAT ARE LOCAL PHARMACIES AND
OUR PHARMACISTS DID THAT WORK
FOR US FOR THE TWO WEEKS THAT
WE HAD NURSES OUT FOR KOBE. WE
HAD NO NURSES IN ANY OTHER PART
OF OUR COUNTY TO MOVE UP THE
HILL. AND WHERE IS THIS THE
STATE'S MOHAWKS THE MEDICAL
HEALTH OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATOR. OUT REALLY WAS
STRUCTURE TO SUPPLY HIGHLY
SKILLED HEALTH CARE PERSONNEL
DURING SUCH CRISES. THEY DON'T
HAVE PSYCHIATRIC. AND SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT OUR
PSYCHIATRIC NURSES AND OTHER
STAFF WHO ARE NEEDED FOR A
CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS ARE
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES.
ARE NOT ABLE TO- OF BE
LEVERAGED IN SACRAMENTO FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE- PSYCHIATRIC
HEALTH FACILITY A FIFTEEN BED
FACILITY AND FIRST THEY HAD TO
CLOSE BECAUSE ALL OF THEIR
STAFF GOT KOBE. SHORTLY
THEREAFTER THEY RE OPENED ONLY
TO HAVE AN OUTBREAK WITH ALL OF
THEIR PATIENTS. ONLY NOW ARE
THEY OUT OF QUARANTINE. BUT IT
HAS NOW RESULTED IN LONG
LASTING EFFECTS ON THE WORK
FORCE AND THEIR CO FOURTEEN
FOUR PEOPLE AT A TIME TO COME
IN IMAGINE DOING THAT AND ANY
OTHER ROUND OF HEALTH CARE.
THAT YOU WOULD ONLY TAKE FOR
WOMEN IN MATERNITY CARE BACK TO
THE BIRTHING CENTER WHEN YOU
HAVE FOUR RIGHT ONE COMES AND
THEY'RE IN LABOR YOU HAVE TO
WAIT WE'RE GONNA WAIT WE HAVE
TOUGH FOR PEOPLE TO GO BACK.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DEALING. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT OUR STATE
PARTNERS HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
TO MAKE UP. THE STRUCTURAL GAPS
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND WHAT. WE
HAVE RECEIVED AN REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITIES AND GUIDANCE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT THEIR DEDICATION AND
PERSISTENCE IN OVERCOMING THESE
BARRIERS. BUT THE FACT IS AT
THE END OF THE DAY COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAD TO FIGHT.
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS. ARE
WORK FORCES AND OUR SERVICES
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. MOST OF
OUR CONGREGATE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES ARE LICENSED BY DCS
AND CDS THAT'S NOT. A
CALIFORNIA PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. LIKE A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OR HOSPITAL. AND SO IT
WAS ALMOST A YEAR INTO THE
PANDEMIC BEFORE THE STATE WAS
ABLE TO GATHER ALL OF THOSE
THREE ENTITIES TOGETHER SO WE
CAN BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT. HEALTH
IMPACTS. AND THESE GAPS
PERSIST. WELL INDIVIDUALS AS
WAS NOTED EARLIER BY DR
WARBURTON. AND HAVE. WITH US
SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM DISORDER
HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST RISK OF
MORTALITY TO COOK IN NINETEEN
ONLY BEHIND H. THE UP. STATE
BAXEEN PRIORITIZATION CRITERIA
DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. AND THAT WILL MEAN
THAT WE WILL NEED TO FIGHT ONCE
AGAIN TO ENSURE OUR HIGH RISK
CLIENTS CAN GET IN THE QUEUE
FOR VACCINES. WE HAD TO LIFT UP
OUR OWN VACCINE CLINICS FOR
STAFF IN OUR BUREAU HEALTH
NURSES WHO ARE EXPERTS ARE
OFTEN USED ELSEWHERE ALL OF MY
NURSES KNOW HOW TO GIVE A
VACCINE. BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE WORK HARD TO
DIVERT BEHAVIOR HEALTH CRISES
FROM OUR PARTNERS IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS. FEDERAL LAW DOES MANDATE
THAT HOSPITALS. ARE TO ADDRESS
ALL FORMS OF EMERGENCY THE
ENTER THEIR FACILITY INCLUDING
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY. BUT THE
COMBINATION OF COBIT OUTBREAKS
AT THE HIGHER LEVEL LOWER
LEVELS OF CARE. ALONG WITH
SPACING AND DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND LACK OF PP AND
INCREASED DEMAND WITH NO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- AND
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ACCEPTING COLEMAN POSITIVE
PATIENTS HAS RESULTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT BOTTLENECK SO THAT
WE HAVE PATIENTS WHO ARE NEED
TO QUARANTINE. AND PSYCHIATRIC
CRISIS AND THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WITHOUT
RECEIVING PSYCHIATRIC CARE
FURTHER IMPACTING THEIR
PSYCHIATRIC. SYMPTOMS IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE TYPICAL LENGTH
OF STAY IN A PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITY IS UNDER TWO WEEKS
SEVEN CODE POSITIVE INDIVIDUAL
CASTING A QUARANTINE TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THEY GET ADMITTED ENTIRE
LENGTH OF STAY IS SPENT IN
QUARANTINE. AT A HOSPITAL
AWAITING ADMISSION NOT MEETING
MEDICAL NECESSITY NOT BEING
ABLE TO BE BUILT. IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE STAFFING ISSUES
AND THE LACK OF EXTERNAL
RESOURCES CAN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HAS RELIED ON LOCUM TENENS TO
HELP US STAFF AND LOCUM TENENS
ARE BEYOND EXPENSIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR KELLY NEXT WE HAVE
MICHELLE GERBER. GOOD AFTERNOON
ED SHEERAN MEMBERS MACHEL
CAPITA ALSO WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND IWOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ORGANIZING
TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSED ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- IT WITH THAT
EARLIER THAT ARE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SAFETY NET IS GRADUAL
AND I THINK WHAT DR KELLY LAID
OUT REALLY- DEMONSTRATE JUST
HOW STRONG THE SAFETY NET HAS
BEEN AND RESILIENT- IT'S IN
IT'S UNDER REPRESENTATION
AROUND COORDINATED RESPONSE
EFFORT. I WILL SPEAK TO THE
LESSONS WE'VE LEARNED TO DATE
AND PROVIDES SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE STATE
TO CONSIDER- AS LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SO FAR- ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE IS THE
BI DIRECTIONAL ASSOCIATION
WHICH RESEARCHERS ARE FINDING
EMERGING BETWEEN COPE AT
NINETEEN AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS IT APPEARS THAT COOK
AT NINETEEN- MAY BOTH TRIGGER
THANK YOUNG TECH ILLNESS. AND
ALSO INDIVIDUALS WITH- MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO COPE IN NINETEEN
INTERACTION AND MORTALITY WE
THINK THAT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING TO KEEP AN EYE ON AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND THINK ABOUT
PRIORITIZATION RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO COOK AT
NINETEEN- THERE IS ALSO AS WE
WILL HEAR ABOUT IN THE HEARING
OF THE WINNING. EPIDEMIC OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS RELATED
TO THE PANDEMIC BOTH OPIOIDS AS
WELL AS DRUGS OTHER DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL AND- ALL OF THESE
CONDITIONS WILL HAVE A LASTING
IMPACT ON OUR STATE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME- SO MUCH OF
THE BROADER EFFORT TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS HAS REALLY
BEEN ABOUT ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
WE HAVE A LIMITED CAPACITY OF
HOSPITAL TO ADDRESS THE
PHYSICAL HEALTH NEEDS OF PEOPLE
WITH A COOK AT NINETEEN- BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS AREAS WHERE
WE BELIEVE WE FALLING SHORT.
IT'S BEEN ADEQUATELY
UNDESTANDING THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THAT PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES AND ILLNESS AND
THOSE THEIR VERY THING
HOSPITALS AND SO- WE BELIEVE
THAT LIVING. WE NEED TO REALLY.
PSYCHIATRIC IN TECH AND- THANK
YOU THIRD PLANNING RELATED TO
COST AND- WE SAW WITH THE PANDA-
THAT THERE. THAT THAT ARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AT
ALL LEVELS OF HIGHER LEVEL AS
WELL AS LOWER LEVELS OF ACUTE
LEVEL WERE IMPACTED BY COBIT
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS AND SO.
THERE NEEDS TO BE- SOME
PLANNING DONE AROUND THAT THE
SERVICES ARE BOTH MEDICAL AS
WELL AS NON MEDIC HELD DUE TO
THE I AND D. EXCLUSION WHICH DR
KELLY REFERENCED. AND SO- OUR
OUR COMMUNITY OF PROVIDERS HAVE
REALLY ADJUSTED AS THEY CAN BUT
WITH VERY LITTLE SUPPORT AND NO
EXTRA RESOURCING TO DO SO- THE
PHYSICAL PLANT OF THE
FACILITIES IS. ALREADY SMALL
AGAIN BECAUSE OF HOW WE ARE
HE'D AND THE FEDERAL RULES FOR
PAYMENT AND SO- ANY ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY WOULD REQUIRE AN
INTENTIONAL AND DEDICATED
RESOURCE- TO ADDRESS OUR UNIQUE
SYSTEM- WHEN IT COMES TO OF FOR
EXAMPLE ALTERNATIVE CARE SITES.
OR A HOUSING WHICH WAS PROVIDED
BY THE STATE THERE WERE
DISCRIMINATORY BARRIERS PUT IN
PLACE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS
WELL AS LOCALLY WHICH- LOOTED
OUR CLIENTS FROM ACCESSING
THOSE RESOURCES ON PAR WITH
OTHER INDIVIDUALS. WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
MOVING FORWARD- AND WITH
RESPECT TO FUNDING AGAIN THERE
NEEDS TO BE DEDICATED RESOURCE
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FACILITIES AND PROVIDERS AND
SYSTEMS BECAUSE OF THE
CATEGORICAL NATURE OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FUNDING.
WHICH LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO-
MOVE FUNDING AROUND OR DRAW
FROM DIFFERENT AS FUNDING
STREAMS IN AN EMERGENCY SUCH AS
THIS ONE- MOVING FORWARD IT
WILL BE ESSENTIAL FOR MORE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EXPERTISE TO
BE BROUGHT IN STATE. DISASTER
AND PUBLIC HOW TO. AT A MUCH
MORE MEANINGFUL- IS IT IMPORT
WITHIN CITY PH AND- YES AS THEY
ARE THE HEART OF THE STATE'S
DISASTER COMMANDING CONTROL.
BUT WE BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE STATE TO ALSO CONSIDER
RECRUITING AND EMBEDDING MORE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINICAL
EXPERTISE ACROSS ALL THE KEY
DEPARTMENTS WHICH TOUCH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCLUDING.
THE STD PH YES S. AND OF COURSE
EMERGENCY SERVICES. REGARDLESS
OF THE INTERNAL EXPERTISE THERE
NEEDS TO BE BETTER COORDINATION
AND COMMUNICATION ACROSS THE
STATE. AS DR KELLY MENTIONED
THE- ALL BE HERE HALL FACILITY
IT'S CALLED WHICH WERE LIFTED
UP WITH LEADERSHIP FROM- DTS
AGENCY I AM PROUD IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- SOCIAL SERVICES
PARTNERS. WAS IN A VERY OVERDUE
AND WELCOME- TOUCHPOINT FOR
HOURS FIELD. AND WE DO NEED TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT CONSISTENTLY
NAMING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
STAFF THE FACILITIES AND
CLIENTS SPECIFICALLY IN OUR
COBIT RELATED STATE GUIDANCE.
THAT TARGET RESOURCE ALLOCATION
WHETHER IT'S HOUSING BAXEEN.
KEEPS I GREG BE UPDATED FOR GUY
ON PURE BACK PRIOR TO.
TECHNICALLY WE WERE ARGUE IN
INCLUDE OF HEALTH CLIENTS BUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT NAME LIKE
US HEALTH. ARE LIKE IN THE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
IT WILL MAKE IT THAT MUCH
HARDER FOR US TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT EIGHTEEN-
THERE DO PRIORITIZATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THESE ARE THINGS
THAT CAN BE EASILY REMEDIED BY
HELPING US NAME THEM
SPECIFICALLY- MOVING FORWARD
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR WORK FIRST
COORDINATION AND RESOURCES FROM
ALL WALKS. YOU NEED TO BE
REVISED TO INCORPORATE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE AS
AN OPTION IN A CRISIS. AND WE
NEED TO WORK TO DEVELOP A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE HERE HOPE
WORKFORCE STRATEGY COMING OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC TO TRULY IN
NEED. OF THE ON COMING TO NAMI
WHICH YOU MENTIONED CHAIR
ARAMBULA- OUR WORK TO CONTINUE
TELEHEALTH AND IMPLEMENT PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST THE MEDIC
HOW WILL NOT BE ENOUGH WE WILL
DESPERATELY NEED ADDITIONAL
CLINICIANS AS WELL THROUGHOUT
THE CONTINUUM INCLUDING
PSYCHIATRISTS FOR ADULTS AND
CHILDREN. NURSES AND OTHER
LICENSED AND CERTIFIED STAFF-
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE MOVING FORWARD
REGARDLESS AT TELEHEALTH WELL
IT CAN HAVE ITS LIMITATIONS
PARTICULARLY THE VERY A Q.
POPULATION- WILL NEED TO BE
ACCORDED WITH AN ACTUAL-
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT VERY LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY. PRIVATELY
OR INTERNET ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE IN
TELEHEALTH SO THAT IS SOMETHING
WE WOULD. ASK FOR A
POLICYMAKERS TO CONSIDER MOVING%
FORWARD AND THEN WE WILL NEED
TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH INSURERS
BOTH MEDICAL AND NON MEDICAL
ARGUING AGGRESSIVE. OUTREACH TO
THEIR BENEFICIARY CHANGE- THE
STATE ARE BENEFICIARY NO AND-
NOT. FROM SERVICE- AND OFTEN.
OF THE FOUR CONTENT REALLY DOES
NEED TO STEP FORWARD IN THIS
MOMENT- AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
TARGETING INVESTMENT IN- CAL
GAME R. AS WELL AS IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET. TO REALLY
HELP BOLSTER THE FULL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON
AS PART OF THE PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDING THE IMD WAIVER
PROPOSAL WHICH WE THINK WILL
ALL BE HELPFUL IN SHORING UP
OUR SYSTEM COMING OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EVERYONE WHO IS ON THE PANEL I
WILL NOW BRING IT UP TO THE
DíAS FOR MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUNS
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- IF I COULD MISTER
CHAIR IF I COULD SPEAK TO ISSUE
THREE- I HAVE A SCHEDULED
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THAT. AND THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTERS ON THIS
ISSUE ONE I'M SHOWING THE
IMPORTANCE OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE COMPONENTS OF THOSE AT THE
FRONT LINES AT THE LOCAL LEVELS
CONTINUING TO WORK. ON THOSE
AREAS. MISTER CHAIR AND THOSE
THAT WOULD PRESENT A NON ISSUE-
THREE ON THE RISK OF SUICIDE
AND SELF HARM. IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE ACROSS OUR STATE AND IS
ESPECIALLY HIGH AMONG
ADOLESCENTS OLDER ADULTS
VETERANS AND LGBT Q. USE AN
ADULT'S KOVEN NINETEEN HAS
RESULTED IN AN INCREASE CALLS
TO CRISIS HOTLINES AROUND THE
COUNTRY. AND IN CALIFORNIA IT
IS MY BELIEF THAT THAT AN
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION IS
MUCH NEEDED AND IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA I INTRODUCED A
BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE LAST
YEAR THEY GOT SIGNED INTO LAW.
THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED OF ALL
THESE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY AND SPECIFICALLY-
WAS SUICIDE PREVENTION. BUT
ALSO SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS AN
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL
COMPONENT- FOLLOWING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. EVEN
BEFORE THE CURRENT PANDEMIC
SUICIDE RATES AMONG ALL GROUPS
HAVE BEEN INCREASING NOW THIS
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IS GROWING
UNDER THE WEIGHT OF ISOLATION
AND UNCERTAINTY. WELL RESOURCES
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED TO ADDRESS
SUICIDE RATES COORDINATION OF
STATE RESOURCES HAS REMAINED A
CHALLENGE FUNDING THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION WILL BE
DISCUSSED. AND WILL BE A VITAL
STEP FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THIS
CRISIS FOR YEARS TO COME. IT IS
WITH THIS IN MIND THAT THIS
YEAR ARE I WILL BE REQUESTING
AN ANNUAL ALLOCATION OF TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THIS
OFFICE AND ENSURE IN THE YEARS
TO COME WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS
AND THIS CRISIS. AND CONTINUE
TO HIGHLIGHT AND ADVOCATE
AROUND THESE ISSUES THAT ARE
MUCH NEEDED- WAY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CAME AND NOW- DURING
THE PANDEMIC. IN AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC. WHY WITH THIS THE OF
SUICIDE. CAN ORGANIZE A
STATEWIDE RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS. ENSURING WE ARE TAKING
DATA DRIVEN APPROACHES TO
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION IN ALL
COMMUNITIES. AND ASSIST WITH A
VITAL ON THE GROUND WORK BEING
DONE BY PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STRAIT. EACH YEAR WE DO NOT
TAKE THIS STEP IS A YEAR WILL
HAVE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES TO
DEVELOP AND HARD IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NEEDED
FOR MANY OF THOSE THAT ARE OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW. WITH
CHALLENGES CHALLENGES IN THEIR
LIVES FEELING ISOLATED
CHALLENGES WITH THEIR IN THEIR
LIVES WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. THAT MIGHT BE
CONTEMPLATING THE ISSUES OF
SUICIDE AND DRUG OVERDOSE IN
THE AREAS THAT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY DURING
THESE PRESENTATIONS. I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THIS YEAR WE CAN
TAKE A STEP FORWARD- THAT IT
DEMANDS THE TIME TO BE ABLE TO
COME FORWARD. AND FUN BY THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION.
THE FUTURE HOLDS THINGS ARE
UNCERTAIN. BUT ONE THING THAT
IS CERTAIN IS THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THE SUICIDE.
AND THE OVER DRUG OVERDOSES
THAT ARE HAPPENING THROUGHOUT
OUR COMMUNITY. WE KNOW FOR
CERTAIN THAT THOSE WILL
CONTINUE TO ESCALATE DURING
THESE TIMES AND DURING THESE
PANDEMICS IT IS WITH THIS IN
MIND THAT I FULL HEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THE PRIVATE PRISON
CHANGES MOVING FORWARD. AND
WILL BE REQUESTING THAT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO
FUND THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRISONERS THAT ARE- COMING
FORWARD TO HIGHLIGHT THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS WITH THAT
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR SO THAT AMASSED TWO
QUESTIONS. FIRST QUESTION IS
GOING TO BE FOR OUR NEXT YEAR
OUT I MADE AS THE- ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. ASKING ABOUT THE CD R.
P. THE **** C. R. D. P. THE
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
PER THE FIRST STAFF
RECOMMENDATION I WANTED TO GET
A SENSE IF THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
VALUE AND THEREFORE WARRANTS.
AN EXTENDED FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IN. THE
PROGRAM DOES HAVE VALUE ALL-
AND WE'VE SEEN IT HAS BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE- AND IF YOU COULD
JUST REPEAT THE LAST PART SORRY
MR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THEREFORE WARRANTS AN EXTENDED
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT. AT THIS
POINT I PROBABLY CAN'T I'M
GOING TO DETAIL ABOUT THAT IF
IT WEREN'T I WOULD I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT IT DOES- IT HAS
VALUE- WE WILL SEE MORE AT I
PROGRESSIVE. MY HOPE WOULD BE
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENTS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WOULD BE A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT
FOR BRIDGE FUNDING. SO THAT WE
CAN THEN DO THE APPROPRIATE
ANALYSES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DONE WITHIN PHASE TWO. AND SO
HOPE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH.
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO
CONTINUE WHAT I AM WOULD AGREE
IS A VALUED PROGRAM AND ONE
THAT. DOES NEED CONTINUED
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT AND SO-
WITH THAT I HOPE WE HAVE THAT
CHANCE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. I DO WANNA ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION I THOUGHT A
POWERFUL FROM C. B. H. T. A. TO
MENTION THE BI DIRECTIONAL
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN COVERED
NINETEEN AND- MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND WAS HOPING TO
GET- RESPONSE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON WHY MENTAL
HEALTH WERE SPECIFICALLY
SCHIZOPHRENIA IS NOT EXPLICITLY
CALLED OUT IN TERMS OF VACCINE
PRIORITIZATION. WE WOULD NEEDED
THE PART TO OUR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. OVERSEAS
ACTING PRIORITIZATION. SO WITH
THAT WE MADE TABLE THAT
QUESTION FOR NOW AND COME BACK
TO IT I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING VERY MUCH PANEL ONE
NOW WE WILL MOVE ON THE PANEL
TO ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND PROPOSALS SPECIFIC
TO YOU AGAIN- FOR MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL
AFTER ALL THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED WE HAVE EIGHT
PRESENTERS AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR LIKE PORN. PLEASE
BEGIN- AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON ALL
INSURABLE- J. C. IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY START WORST PART OF
OUR PRESENTATION HERE AND I'LL
FOLLOW UP TO OUR SUMMER MARC
SHE TAKES. HER BACK. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
INVEST FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
TOTAL FUND TWO HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND. OVER THREE YEARS
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS RECEIVING PREVENTIVE
AND EARLY INTERVENTION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
OFFERED BY SCHOOL AFFILIATED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING THE
NON SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND THIS
PROPOSAL INCENTIVIZES PLANS TO
COME TO THE TABLE COLLABORATE
WITH SCHOOLS IN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO SERVICES IN
SCHOOLS. HISTORICALLY THERE'S
BEEN LIMITED OF CORONATION
BETWEEN MANAGED CARE PLANS
COUNTIES IN SCHOOLS AROUND
PROVIDING SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES. EACH ENTITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR VERY SPECIFIC
SETS OF SERVICES PROVIDED
THROUGH VARIOUS DELIVERY
SYSTEMS THE PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
BREAK DOWN SOME OF THOSE
HISTORICAL BARRIERS BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THESE
ENTITIES. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO SCHOOL
CHILDREN. I THINK ONE EXAMPLE
THAT. WE ARE ALL VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IS FOR EXAMPLE 58% OF OUR
ELEAZAR IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
ELLIE A BILLING OPTION PROGRAM
SERVICES- THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS
ELEAZAR TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
CERTAIN HEALTH SERVICES. IN A
SCHOOL SETTING- HOWEVER ELLY
ELLS ELLY AIDS CAN ONLY BE
REIMBURSED FOR SERVICES TO A
CHILD WITH THE CARE PLAN. DH CS
IS INTERESTED IN ULTIMATELY
INCREASING ACCESS TO ALL
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL SERVICES IN
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW IN LIGHT OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
RESPONSE- AROUND NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES WE
ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL BUT HOPE
IT REACHES BROADER THAN THAT IN
THE FUTURE. ANOTHER PIECE WE
WOULD JUST MENTION. IS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD OF FOR VERY LONG
TIME THE NUMBER OF. YEARS OF
THAT MAY BE IN PLACE AND WE'RE
HOPING TO KIND OF REMOVE SOME
OF THOSE WITH THESE INCENTIVE
HE SAYS AND THAT'S- WHY THEY
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
INTERVENTIONS THAT FOCUS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE. PARTNERSHIP TO
PASS THE BUILDING AND REMOVING
SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS WOULD BE
USED FOR THINGS LIKE. PLANNING
CONSULTANTS TO COME IN AND WORK
WITH THE MANAGED CARE PLANS THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
PROVIDERS IN THE SCHOOLS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PATH
FORWARD SHOULD BE IT WOULD
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND DATA SYSTEMS IT COULD ALSO
PROVIDE THINGS LIKE TELEHEALTH
PORTALS. OR MODELS OF CARE FOR
APPROPRIATE SCHOOL SETTINGS. DO
YOU IS ALSO VERY FOCUSED ON
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CARE MANY
OF THE PROPOSED INCENTIVES
FOCUS ON REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND INEQUITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE HIGHER INCENTIVES MAY
BE OFFERED FOR CLOSING HEALTH
EQUITY GAPS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND LGBTQ
STUDENTS WITHIN THE PROPOSAL.
INCENTIVES WILL NOT- INCLUDE
PAYMENTS FOR TREATMENT SERVICES
WOULD YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S CLEAR TO PEOPLE THAT CAN
BE REIMBURSED TODAY- AND WOULD
BE SEPARATE FROM THESE
INCENTIVE DOLLARS. THE MODEL
WOULD BE FLEXIBLE TO ALLOW FOR
SCHOOL AFFILIATED PROVIDERS I'M
INCLUDING PROVIDERS IN SCHOOLS
COUNTY- PROVIDERS SCHOOL
AFFILIATED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS WITHIN THE
SYSTEM WE KNOW THAT ALL OF THE
SYSTEM'S EXISTING CALIFORNIA I
MEAN WHAT THE PROPOSAL TO BE
FLEXIBLE. TO ALLOW FOR ALL OF
THOSE MODELS ADDS PLANS SCHOOLS
AND COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WORK TOGETHER TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE IN THE SPACE.
ADDITIONALLY SINCE THE RELEASE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DH CS
HAS MET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
AS WELL AS THE PHD A TO DISCUSS
HOW WE CAN ALIGN AND LEVERAGE.
THEIR VARIOUS EXPERTISE IN THIS
AREA TWO BOARDS TOGETHER TO
COORDINATE ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS FOR ALL
CHILDREN TO HAVE THE- LARGEST
NUMBER OF SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
THEM IN THEIR SCHOOLS. YES THEY
ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THESE DISCUSSIONS
OVER THE SUMMER TO HELP INFORM
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE PER HOST
INCENTIVES AS WELL AS THE
DISTRIBUTION. AND ALLOCATION OF
THOSE INCENTIVE DOLLARS. EACH
DEPARTMENT HAS BOTH EXPERTISE
AND RELATIONSHIPS. AND THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO LEVERAGING AND
PROMOTING. THOSE IN ORDER TO
INCREASE AS STUDENT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY
DH CS DID REQUEST LIMITED
RESOURCE SERVICES OF TWELVE
POSITIONS EQUAL TO ELEVEN
MILLION TOTAL FUN TO ADDRESS
AND IMPLEMENT THIS WORK. I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO WILL NOW DO YOU.
HAVE SOME I REMAINING COMMENTS.
WELL YOU'RE ON YOUR. YES WE
RELY ON J. C. TO KEEP TELLING
ME THAT I NEEDED- WE'RE VERY
COMMITTED TO BEING SHORED UP
ALL CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
NEED THEM WITHOUT DELAY-
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE MOTIVE OF
THE SCHOOLS PROPOSAL IS NOT.
MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE ALREADY
BEING PAID. WHAT A CAPITATED
RATE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE DON'T
SUCCEED IN MAKING THOSE
CONNECTIONS HAPPEN THEN THAT'S
NOT LEAVING MONEY ON THE TABLE.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE GO ABOUT.
DURING THAT WE GET A HIGH
QUALITY CALL BOTH FROM OUR
EXISTING. THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AS WELL AS- SCHOOLS-
THE CONCEPT IS WE GO THROUGH
OUR SORT OF DATA ANALYTICS YOUR
EXTERNAL QUALITY REVIEW
ORGANIZATION- BUT ALSO THROUGH
THE PROCESS BUT WE'RE NOT-
GAUGED IN WITHIN THE PARK-
CREATING A SORT OF A OFFICE OF
CHIEF QUALITY OFFICER. GOAL
WHICH IS TO BE SURE THAT WE ARE
REALLY GETTING THE OUTCOMES OF.
OUR CLIENTS. NEED WE ARE
PLANNING FOR- AND- WE ARE ALSO
ISSUES OF EQUITY ALL WITHIN THE
SORT OF THE BROADER FOCUS ON
GETTING SERVICES TO CHILDREN
BEYOND ALL SCHOOLS SHOULD HAVE.
IT WITHIN THE CATALAN PROPOSAL
ON MODIFYING THE MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA. IT BARRIER
FOR MANY YEARS. WARMER DAYS
UNTIL SERVE SOMETHING STRUGGLED
RIGHT OUT GET ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND CARE THE CHILD
NEEDS WITHOUT HAVING TO WAIT
FOR THE DIAGNOSIS OF UNIVERSAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. IN
TURN OF- YOU CAN CARE WHICH IS
TO FOCUS OF COURSE BARBER'S ARM
WAS PART OF CAL AIM WE- BROUGHT
TOGETHER A- OF FOSTER CARE
WORKGROUP THAT IS WORK WITH.
ALL OF THE STATE. BOTH
DEPARTMENTS- YES SO. AND SOME
OF THE JOB MOST PROFESSIONALS
IN THE FIELD TO REALLY LOOK AT
HOW DO WE GET TO A SYSTEM THAT
IS TRULY COORDINATED
INTEGRATED. HIGHLY ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR ENSURING THAT ALL ALL
HEALTH NEEDS OF CHILDREN ARE
BEING WELL GRASSED. CHILDREN
AUSTIN CARE. AND THOSE
TREATMENTS WILL BE ON THE WERE
IN OUR WITH D. O. YES THESE ARE
FIVE WORKGROUP CONTINUES THAT
WAS WITH WHAT'S CALLED WE
EXPECT FIND REPORT ALL THE IN
OCTOBER. TWENTY TWENTY ONE- TWO
OTHER THINGS ARE QUICKLY BENCH.
OF THE AGENTS OR THE AB TWENTY
THREE WORK. WHEN TOGETHER. ALL
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS BOARD OF EDUCATION TO REALLY
WORK AT BOTH STATEWIDE LEVEL
CALLS FROM LOCAL LEVELS HOW TO
INTEGRATE OPERATIONS SO BUT WE
NEVER AGAIN HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE. CHILDREN ARE SOME GOING.
ALMOST SERVED OR UNDER SERVED
BECAUSE THE MORE RELEVANT
DEPARTMENTS. LOCAL YOUR STATE
LEVEL ALL OF OUR. PROBABLY
SAYING. ONE WILL BE JUST
MENTIONED BECAUSE OF FIGHTING
AND ALL- WORKING WITH THE BOARD
OF SOCIAL. AND THE- FIRST BROKE
FINALLY ORDER THE SPA TO
PROVIDE CARE AND FORMER BOSS
YOUTH IN THEIR CARE. WITH THE
MEDIA TRUMP INFORMED SUPPORT
WHEN THEY NEED IT TO SORT OF A
TWENTY FOUR SO. THIS WHEN.
CRISIS A AND TEN O'CLOCK ON THE
NIGHT. ALL MY THE CARE GIVERS
WILL AND- CHILDREN THEIR CARING
FOR CAN. ALL PROGRESS. HELP
THEM ON THIS THEM THROUGH THE-
SO THOSE ARE JUST OF YOUR-
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE WORK WEEK OR
IS DOING APRIL HELPED WITH
CHILDREN RIGHT NOW. LET ME STOP
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE DEPUTY
DIRECT MONICA MORALES. HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS MONICA
MCALLISTER THE DIRECTOR OVER
THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
BE PROVIDING SOME BACKGROUND IN
ALL CHILDREN THRIVE INITIATIVE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS JUST A LITTLE
REMINDER ON THE ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE CAMPAIGN IS REALLY THE
PURPOSE OF IT IS FOR CITIES TO
PREVENT AND MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. A PILOT FUNDING OF
TEN MILLION OVER THE YEARS WAS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT WHEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO FIND
OUR PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE. HE
PAID CONTRACT IT WOULD PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND THE UCLA
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO LEAD
THE PROJECT ALL CHILDREN THRIVE
MAINTAINS IN EQUITY WORKGROUP
RIGHT NOW IT'S REALLY GUIDING
THE FOLLOWING KEY STRATEGIES OF
THE INITIATIVE STARTED WITH
CREATING PROTECTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS PROMOTING HEALTHY
TELL DEVELOPMENT ACCESS TO SAFE
AND STABLE HOUSING STRENGTHENED
ECONOMIC COURT YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS. PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES REPORTS THAT THERE
ARE TWENTY ONE CITIES
PARTICIPATING IN THEIR
INITIATIVE I TO DATE SOME OF
THE KEY ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE
COMPLETION OF A TOOL KIT
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN ONLINE
COMMUNITY PLATFORM AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CITY. BY CITY
COACHING CLIENTS. IN ADDITION
YOU KNOW THE P. H. HAS REALLY
BEEN WORKING WITH THE TEAM TO
REALLY DO A LOT OF THE- CONTACT
ADMINISTRATION ACTIVITIES. THE
SCHOOL COMPONENTS OF THE WAR
WE'VE PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE PROJECT
AROUND YOU KNOW JUST EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES SOME OF THE KEY
DATA THE DEPARTMENT ALSO-
MANAGES AND WE'VE CONVENE
SEVERAL TIMES- STAKEHOLDERS
UCLA AND SO FORTH TO DISCUSS
HAVE THE DISCUSSIONS ON. THE
PROGRESS AND HOW WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO KIND OF MOVE SOME OF
THE ACTIVITIES FORWARD. I'M IN
ADDITION WE REALLY WORK WITH
THEM TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
PROPER REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT THEIR SUBMITTED ON A
TIMELY BASIS TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MISSION NUMBER
LEGISLATOR. I'M AT THIS POINT
THE PROJECT IS SCHEDULED TO END
BY THE END OF DECEMBER OF THIS
YEAR- AT THAT POINT WE DO
EXPECT A FINAL VALUATION REPORT
TO BE PROVIDED. THAT WOULD
REALLY A DISCUSS SOME OF THE
KEY FINDINGS OF THIS PILOT
PROJECT FUTURE RECOMMENDATIONS-
ALL OF THAT WILL BE PACKAGED
AND WILL BE OUR SHARED WITH THE
MADOC OVERSIGHT. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGETS AS WELL. I'M YOU KNOW
WE DID GET A QUESTION ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF COAL BID ON THE WORK-
YOU KNOW I THINK LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE WE HAVE SEEN THAT WE'VE
HAD TO PIVOT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO PICK FROM IN PERSON.
INITIATIVE TO REALLY MORE OF AN
ONLINE- INSTEAD THAT HAS
ACTUALLY TAKEN PLACE VERY
QUICKLY FOLKS RETOOLED THEY
THOUGHT ABOUT WAYS THAT THEY
COULD REALLY OPEN UP THE ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO PROMOTE
ENGAGEMENT. TO REALLY ENSURE
THAT THEY WERE WORKING WITH THE
KEY CITIES AND COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES AND LEADERS TO MOVE
THEIR- THEIR EFFORTS FORWARD
THAT BEING SAID- YOU KNOW WE
STILL DIDN'T SEE ANY IMPACT IN
TERMS OF THE KEY. FOLKS AND
COMMUNITIES THEY CALL THERE IS
THAT WERE RICH. PART OF THE AND
THAT MORPHED SOME OF- YOU KNOW
REALIZE THAT WE EVERYTHING ON
WITH COLD WITH THE TO PAY IT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. WE DID
SEE NEW OP. NEW STATE. THAT
REALLY WANT TO AND- SOME OF THE
KEY COMPONENTS OF- YOU KNOW THE
INITIATIVE CAME ON BOARD AND SO
WE'VE SEEN KIND OF BASICALLY A
TRADE OFF OVERALL. SO WE'LL
JUST CONTINUE TO UPDATE YOU
KNOW THE COMMITTEE AS REFINING
OUT NEW INFORMATION AND REALLY
KEEP YOU GUYS ABREAST OF SOME
OF THE KEY COMPONENTS THAT.
HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
MORE INFORMATION ON AS WELL AS
EFFORTS RAMP UP. SO WITH THAT.
I'LL PASS IT ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER THANK YOU. TERBIUM
EUROPE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THAT PRECEDE THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M GOING TO COVER
THREE ISSUES OUR SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS. ABOUT HOW
PARTNERSHIPS SECOND ARE YOU
DROP IN CENTERS AND I WORK ON
THE SIDE BECAUSE THIS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND I
JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
STAFF WORK THAT WENT INTO CAN
ALICE'S. I AM I THINK DISTRICTS
LOAN PART IN HERE THE
COMMISSION A FEW YEARS AGO
RECOGNIZE THAT IN SOME WAYS WE
HAVE CREATED FISCAL AND OTHER
INCENTIVES THAT MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO PARTNER WE HAVE
SEEN SOME PARTNERSHIPS HAPPEN
NATURALLY THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF JUST SOME
INCREDIBLE EDUCATORS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. DIRECTORS
BUT GENERALLY THESE
PARTNERSHIPS TEND TO BE THE
EXCEPTION RATHER THAN THE ROLE
SO THE COMMISSION WORKED TO
INCENTIVIZE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES
AND HOW WE ALLOCATED SOME OF
OUR S. B. EIGHTY TWO OR TRIAGE
FUNDS. AND THE RESPONSE FROM
COUNTIES AND THEIR SCHOOL
PARTNERS WAS INCREDIBLE. AND
THAT THAT LED TO THAT PASSAGE
AND SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE MAIN HOSPITAL SERVICES
ACTED WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDS. INTO SUPPORTING THESE
KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS. THE
COMMISSION THAT THIS WORD
BECAUSE OF A COUPLE A HANDFUL
OF FUNDAMENTAL RATIONALES.
FIRST IS THAT CHILDREN ARE IN
SCHOOL AND SO SCHOOLS CREATE
THESE READY OPPORTUNITIES TO.
UNDERSTAND AND MEET THEIR NEEDS
SCHOOLS ARE GENERALLY ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND SO
THEY BECOME VERY EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENGAGE. IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING
THEM. AND THE LEVEL OF TRUST
THAT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
OFTEN HAVE IN TERMS OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IT IT'S
OFTEN HIGHEST WITH SCHOOLS AND
SO THAT HIGH LEVEL OF TRUST THE
ACCESS THAT SCHOOLS. CREATE FOR
CHILDREN THEN YOU REALLY
CREATES A NATURAL OPPORTUNITY
TO STRENGTHEN THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE DELIVER MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO YOU AND IT ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
OUR MENTAL HEALTH GOALS. IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE CREATE
THE RIGHT KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
COUNTIES. AS OUTLINED IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS THE COMMISSION
ISSUED GRANTS TO FOR COUNTIES
THAT HAD PROPOSED TO JOIN WITH
THEIR SCHOOLS WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVED IN AUSTIN SERVICES ACT
FUNDS IT WAS A FORTY MILLION
ONE TIME AT TEN MILLION NOT
GOING. OVER MULTIPLE YEARS WE
TURN THAT INTO A SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
OPPORTUNITY WITH A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS AND WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND EIGHTEEN. COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS. NEED TO BCK
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE THERE WAS
UNMET NEEDS ADD TO THE LEVEL OF
ABOUT EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO FIND TWENTY ADDITIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WERE PROPOSED
THE BCP REQUESTS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. ASSUMING THAT
THE LANGUAGE WOULD ALLOW US TO
FIND THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT WERE
ALREADY PROPOSED WE SEE THIS AS
SHOVEL READY PARTNERSHIPS THE
COMMISSION WOULD BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE DOLLARS TO OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS PRIOR TO THE
START OF SCHOOL IN. OVER THE
SUMMER IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THAT OUR LOCAL PARTIES WOULD BE
ABLE TO LAUNCH NEW PROGRAMS
BEFORE STUDENTS RETURN BUT IT
DOES MEAN THAT WE CAN GET GOING
VERY QUICKLY. WITH A LEVEL OF
FUNDING THAT'S IN THE IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO FIND TO ADDITIONAL
SMALL COUNTIES AT TWO AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS EACH TO
ADDITIONAL MEDIUM SIZE COUNTIES
A FOUR MILLION DOLLARS EACH AND
TWO ADDITIONAL LARGE COUNTIES.
AT SIX BILLION DOLLARS EACH.
FOR A TOTAL OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. I DO WANT TO
RECORD. THAT FULLY FUNDING
WOULD TAKE A LITTLE OVER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. BUT I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT EVEN
FULLY FUNDED THAT WOULD MEAN
TWENTY COUNTIES WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM. AND EVEN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT ARE PARTICIPATING
THE SIZE OR SCALE OF THESE
GRANTS. FALLS SHORT OF WHAT
ACTUALLY IS NEEDED IF WE WANT
TO DELIVER CARE OR BUILD OUT
STRONGER COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
SCHOOLS. THESE FUNDS HOWEVER
ARE A DOWN PAYMENT OR STARTING
POINT. IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
INCENTIVES JUST TO STRENGTHEN
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
COUNTIES IN OUR SCHOOLS WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THEIR SUCCESS BY
LOOKING AT MODELS FOR
GOVERNANCE FOR SUSTAINABLE
FINANCING FOR THE KINDS OF
PROGRAMMING THAT WILL BE
EFFECTIVE ACROSS SUCH A DIVERSE
STATE AND A DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATIONS. AND DIVERSE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WE NEED TO BUILD
OUR CAPACITY TO UNDERSTAND
WHICH OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING AND TO LEARN FROM THE
PROGRESS THAT HAPPENS OVER TIME
AND WE NEED TO REVISIT SOME OF
OUR POLICIES AND PRACTICES AT
THE STATE LEVEL THAT MAY HINDER
OR WE HOPE ACTUALLY SUPPORT AND
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THIS FROM THE
COMMISSION'S PERSPECTIVE THE
STATE REALLY NEEDS TO EMBRACE
THESE PARTNERSHIPS IN WAYS
WHERE WE CAN ALL SHARE RISK AND
RECOGNIZE WE SHARE REWARDS WHEN
WE GET SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
DOWN RIGHT FIRST FOR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. MISSPOKE IS
ON CAPACITY BUILDING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE QUITE OFTEN
WE HEARD THIS LAST WEEK IN A
LISTENING SESSION IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE.
WELL WE DO FEEL THAT MANY OF
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS MAY FOR A
LOT COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS AND SCHOOLS HVE
FIGURED OUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AND ARE FAR ALONG. MANY
OTHERS HAVE YET TO BENEFIT FROM
THE GUIDANCE AND EXPERIENCE OF
THEIR- SISTER AGENCIES THAT
HAVE LEARNED SOME OF THESE
LESSONS. THERE'S A FEW OTHER
COMPONENTS THAT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. ELEVATING HIS
VOICE THE COMMISSION WENT
THROUGH ABOUT AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
PROCESS OF ENGAGING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO TALK WITH THEM ABOUT
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES. OR MENTAL HEALTH
AND THEY HIGHLIGHTED
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE SCHOOL. TO
THEIR SCHOOLS AND THE IDEAS
THEY HAVE ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
OFTEN DIVERGE FROM WHAT SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS WE'RE SEEING
COMING OUT OF SOME OF THE
COUNTY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS AND
SO ELEVATING YOUTH VOICE IS AN
AREA WHERE THE COMMISSION FEELS
VERY STRONGLY. MUST BE A
COMPONENT OF OUR BROADER
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH- WE WANT TO
CREATE ON DEMAND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR LOCAL PARTNERS
SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
GET THESE PROGRAMS RIGHT. WE
WANT TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
LEVERAGE IMAGES STATE
INNOVATION FUNDS WERE AVAILABLE
AND APPROPRIATE. AND SEE HOW WE
CAN SHARE RISK BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE COUNTIES AND OUR
SCHOOLS TO REALLY- DESIGN
PROGRAMS THAT WILL NEED TO
EVOLVE OVER TIME AS WE LEARN.
AND AS WE INTEGRATE THE
STRATEGIES. I'M GONNA SHIP
DURING DROPPED WORK. HE THE
COMMISSION WAS FINE AS OUTLAW.
IN THE ANALYSIS TO LAUNCH A
SERIES OF YEARS DROPPING MODELS
BASED ON A MODEL OUT OF
AUSTRALIA CALLED HEADSPACE. AND
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE BUILDING
THAT OUT IN A PARTNERSHIP WITH
A NUMBER OF COUNTIES. AND
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS UNDER THE
BRAND ALL CODES. THE MODEL THAT
HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO BE
EFFECTIVE AROUND THE WORLD
REALLY BEGINS WITH THE PREMISE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE NEED TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DESIGN AND
DELIVERY OF SERVICES INCLUDING
THE WAY IN WHICH- THE NAME THAT
IS USED. IN REFERRING TO THESE
SERVICES AND THE WAY IN WHICH
WE TALK ABOUT AND COMMUNICATE
THE SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. THIS PROJECT STARTED
WITH A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INNOVATION PROPOSAL FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. WE HAVE NOW FIVE.
DIGITS HAVE. FOUR ADDITIONAL
LOCAL PARTNERS ACT WAS FIVE TO
AN LA ONE AND SAN MATTEO ONE IN
ORANGE AND ONE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. WE'RE
BUILDING A LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE WITH SUPPORT AND
PARTNERSHIP FROM EXPERTS AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. RIGHT NOW
WE ARE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
THE DAHLE GOALS OF FIDELITY TO
THE MODEL. WHILE ALSO REMOVING
ANY BARRIERS TO ACCESS SO THAT
WE CAN- AT. SCALE THIS MODEL UP
NOT JUST ACROSS THE STATE BUT
WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING INCREASE
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY FROM
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
INTERESTED. IN ADAPTING THE
ALCOVE MODELS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THE BALLOT THE
QUESTION HERE IS HOW CAN WE
BALANCE SUPPORTING FIDELITY
THIS WELL ESTABLISHED MODEL IN
THIS CAPACITY TO SCALE
OVERTIME. OR WORKING THROUGH
LEGAL PROGRAMMATIC FINANCIAL
pISSUES- BUT WE'RE WORKING WITH
IN A PARTNERSHIP WITH STANFORD.
WITH OUR COUNTY AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS
WHO ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
SEEING THIS MODEL LEFT RATE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE REALLY ARE
HOWEVER JUST GETTING STARTED
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE TASK- IT'S WHAT FOR A MODEL
THAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
ELSEWHERE AND. AND THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADAPT YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA. THE THIRD ISSUE
THAT I WANT TO MENTION. AS
OUTLINED IN THE NON IS EARLY
PSYCHOSIS AND AGAIN WE- THE
WRITER. THIS IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE WE'RE REALLY WORKING TO
CREATE. JOE PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION LANDS. WE
TRIED FOR THE PAST. I SHOULD
SAY RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
THERE'S ABOUT AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
DELAY IN ACCESSING CARE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
EARLY PSYCHOSIS EPISODE. IN
CONTRAST WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
TOM INSULT THE FORMER DIRECTOR
OF NIMH TO SEARCH FOR A MOMENT
HERE AS THERE ARE MENTAL HEALTH
CZAR TO THE GOVERNOR. IS THAT
THAT THAT DELAY IN THE UNITED
IN THE UNITED KINGDOM IS ABOUT
TWO WEEKS SO THERE'S AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH DELAY IN
ACCESSING HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ITS TWO WEEK DELAY
IN THE UNITED KINGDOM. SO THE
QUESTION THAT THE COMMISSION
ACTUALLY TRYING TO TACKLE IS
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS. TO
SPRING SEKULA SAYS IN THE
FASTEST TIME POSSIBLE. TO DO
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF COUNTY PARTNERS WITH
UC DAVIS AS A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT WE'RE CONNECTING WITH
OTHER STATES THAT ARE WORKING
TO BUILD OUT THEIR RELEASE
ACOSTA STRATEGIES. AND THE
TARGET HERE IS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE ACCESS TO
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER. IT
REDUCES THE OFTEN MOST
DIFFICULT MOST EXPENSIVE AND
MOST IMPACTFUL. MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES OFTEN RELATING TO
HOMELESSNESS INCARCERATION I'M
MULTIPLE HOSPITALIZATIONS
INCLUDING IDENTIFICATION AS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AT
STATE HOSPITALS. WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW CAN WE BUILD
CAPACITY TO SCALE UP EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACHES TO THESE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTIONS THAT
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO REALLY
LOWER COSTS AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES AND DO SO IN A WAY
THAT WE'RE PARTNERING. WITH NOT
JUST WITH MEDIC CAL IN OTHER IN
OTHER N OTHER PROVIDERS OR
LOOKING AT ALL THESE OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES BUT ALSO WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR WE HAVE A
VERY CREATIVE PARTNERSHIP WITH
KAISER NOR CAL. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN BEGIN
TO UTILIZE THIS TREATMENT MODEL
CONCORD AT THE SPECIALTY CARE
WHICH IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
UNDER MEDICARE I'LL BUT IT'S
TYPICALLY NOT FUNDED UNDER
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE WE'RE ALSO
TALKING WITH. PURCHASERS OF
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE INCLUDING
PURCHASERS LIKE CALPERS AND
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN LEVERAGE
THE PURCHASING POWER OF A LARGE
PURCHASER LIKE ARE PENSION
FUNDS TO REALLY SHAPE THE
COMMERCIAL HEALTH CARE MARKET
PLACE. SO THAT WE CAN EXPAND
ACCESS. TO CARE FOR THOSE
BEHAVIORS. RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALSO
WORKING TO LINK DATA TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS THAT
PARTICIPATION IN THESE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS HAVE ON THE
OUTCOMES THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR INCLUDING REDUCING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
INCLUDING REDUCING
PARTICIPATION AND FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH IS A LITTLE
BIT LATER ON THE AGENDA- WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT DISPARITIES
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THESE
SYSTEMS. OTHER STATES ARE A BIT
FARTHER AHEAD OF US. AT WORK
PLACE TO CATCH UP THROUGH THE
KIND OF COLLABORATION THAT WE
HAVE WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS
AND UC DAVIS UCLA AND UC SAN
FRANCISCO AS WORKING THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE. AND
WE'RE TAKING GUIDANCE FROM SOME
OF THE WORK THAT HAS HAPPENED
IN OTHER AREAS OF HEALTHCARE
WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS EFFORTS
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR TO CREATE
GREATER AWARENESS AROUND THE
REST OF STROKES FOR EXAMPLE AND
HOW INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
SHOULD RESPOND WHEN THEY
SUSPECT THAT SOMEONE MIGHT BE
EXPERIENCING A STROKE. WE HAVE
YET TO BEGIN TO DO THAT KIND OF
STIGMA REDUCTION WORK AND
ENGAGEMENT AROUND PSYCHOSIS-
BUT THE IMPACTS OF IGNORING THE
INITIAL. SYMPTOMS OF PSYCHOSIS
THE IMPACTS OF STATEMENT THAT
LEADS TO PEOPLE DELAYING ACCESS
TO CARE OUR PROFOUND. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES BUT
ALSO FOR THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE NEIGHBORING CARE. SO
THAT THIS IS A PRODUCT OF ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT AGAIN WE ARE.
GETTING NEW PROGRAMMING OFF THE
GROUND WE ARE WORKING TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE NEEDS FOR
WORKING TO ADDRESS GREATER
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES HAVE WHEN THEY'RE
BEGINNING TO EXPERIENCE
PSYCHOSIS AND HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS
CARE AND WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
OUT A DATA DRIVEN STRATEGIES
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT THAT WERE HAVING. THAT
WAS A LOT I APOLOGIZE BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WE HAVE DR KELLY. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS. SO WHEN
IT COMES TO BE ABLE HEALTH
CONDITIONS WE ALL KNOW CHILDREN
AND YOUTH ARE NOT SIMPLY LITTLE
ADULTS SERIOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE. PREVENTION
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
APPROACHES MUST BE AGE
APPROPRIATE. AND IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO BE EFFECTIVE BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE TO BE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE WE
KNOW THAT RATES OF CO OCCURRING
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CONDITIONS. ARE ALSO
MUCH HIGHER AMONG CHILDREN AND
YOUTH THAN IN ADULTS WITH ONE
STUDY FINDING THAT 60% OF USED
HER RECEIVING COMMUNITY
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT. ALSO MET DIAGNOSTIC
CRITERIA FOR MENTAL ILLNESS
FURTHERMORE BECAUSE CHILDREN
DON'T SPEND AS MUCH TIME IN
PRIMARY CARE. AFTER THE AGE OF
THREE OR FOUR WITH THEIR
PEDIATRICIANS WHEN
IMMUNIZATIONS AND WELL CHILD
VISITS TAPER OFF. COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAS
RECOGNIZED THE NEED TO OUR
REGION ENGAGE CHILDREN INTO
SERVICES OUTSIDE OF THE
STANDARD HEALTH SYSTEM. WE HAVE
BUILT OUT OUR SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
AS A DOCTOR YOU IN REFER TO.
I'M TO MEET CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WHERE THEY ARE TODAY ARE SCHOOL
BASED PARTNERSHIPS ARE KEY
COMMUNITY ACCESS POINTS
PROVIDING A BROAD RANGE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES NOT
JUST THE CHILDREN BUT ALSO TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE. OUR
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES SUPPORT
HOMELESS AND CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVED MEDIC CAL CHILDREN AS
WELL AS ALL CHILDREN IN OUR
SCHOOLS. CBH DA HAS FOCUSED. ON
LEVERAGING OUR HISTORY. I AND
OUR KNOW HOW IN- WE DO NOW. AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
HAS ALSO ALLOWED US TO FULLY
DEVELOP OUR CHILDREN'S SYSTEM
OF CARE WE HAVE DATA WE HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS. AND THAT HAS LED
TO FOR MY COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY THE PAST DECADE A
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL SOUTH US
TO GET THIS RIGHT. A WE HAVE
YOU LEVERAGED I MEAN JUST A
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
SYSTEMS PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL AGE
TREATMENT SERVICES AGAIN FOR
ALL CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM. LEVERAGING THAT AM I
JUST A DOLLAR WE'VE CREATED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR COUNTY
AND CITY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS LEVERAGING EDUCATIONAL
DOLLARS WHICH IS DIFFICULT AS A
MATCH. AND THAT EXTENDS OUR
REACH INTO ALL CHILDREN NOT
JUST THOSE WHO ARE IDENTIFIED
AS HAVING MEDIC HOW. A RECENT
SURVEY OF OUR MEMBERSHIP THIS
LAST MONTH HAD FOUND THAT AMONG
THE COUNTY SURVEYED. 97%
REPORTING 85% HAVE EXISTING
SCHOOL BASED PARTNERSHIPS THE
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY COVER
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND 1100% OF THE
SCHOOLS. AT CAMPUSES IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND A MAJORITY
PROVIDE S. U. D. E. SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES IN
ADDITION TO MENTAL HEALTH
ONSITE. ALSO ANOTHER GOOD POINT
THAT DIED DIRECTOR EWING MADE
WAS THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH
RIGHT BEFORE CALLED IT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WORKED WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THREE OF OUR
DIRECTORS. MYSELF FROM SOMEBODY
DO YOU KNOW FRESNO AND MONTEREY
PRESENTED TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION HOW WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO ENHANCE-
OUR REACH. BUT DESPITE THIS
GROUNDWORK CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SUFFERING MORE
AND MORE A CUTE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CRISES SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. WELL OVERALL ADULT
RATES OF DEATH BY SUICIDE
TYPICALLY DIP A LITTLE BIT. IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CRISIS ALL OF
THE REPORTING WE'VE SEEN HAS
SHOWN THAT RATES ARE UP FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE ACCESSING A
CRISIS AND REQUIRING LONGER
HOSPITALIZATIONS RATES ARE UP
TO FOLD AND IN SOME COUNTIES.
THREE FALL THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC
COUNTY SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE USE OF TELEHEALTH SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THERE
IS A GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE THAT ARE PROVIDED FOR US TO
HAVE WEB BASED TRAINING AND
WAYS TO ADAPT CLINICAL
PRACTICE. PRACTICE. TO HEALTH
TELEHEALTH MODALITIES. FOR
OLDER CHILDREN. AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY PRIVACY IS HUGE AND
ENSURING CONFIDENTIALITY
PARTICULARLY ON COM COM
CONFLICTS ME INVOLVED FAMILY
MEMBERS YOU MIGHT BE LIVING IN
THE SAME PLACE. FOR OUR CLIENTS
WHO DO NOT HAVE TECHNOLOGY. OR
INTERNET ACCESS TO ENGAGE IN
TELEHEALTH SOME COUNTIES HAVE
HAD TO SET UP SECURE DEDICATED
SPACE TO PROVIDE. A SAFE PLACE
WHERE FAMILIES CAN WORK AND ARE
YOU CAN WORK WITH AN OFFSITE
CLINICIAN THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT SPEAKING FROM A
COUNTY THAT HAS- A LACK OF
SATELLITE COVERAGE. TELEHEALTH
IS AN ADDENDUM TO IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL IT IS NOT EVER
TO BE USED. INSTEAD OF ACTUAL
DIRECT CLINICAL CARE AS A
CLINICAL DECISION THAT NEEDS TO
BE MADE BY THE PROVIDER AS WELL
AS THE PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE
WORKING WITH IF YOU HAVE A
CHILD WHO'S HAVING DELUSIONS OR
HALLUCINATIONS IT IS OFTEN
DIFFICULT TO HAVE THEM. KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REALITY
AND DELUSION IF YOU'RE USING A
COMPUTER SCREEN. WE ALSO
SUPPORTED CHILDREN BY DOING
MORE TO SUPPORT CARE GIVERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY WE HAVE HAD AN INCREASE
DURING PANDEMIC OF 16%
PROVIDING SUPPORT SERVICES TO
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WHEN WE'RE TALKING TO
THE CHILD WE CAN SEEN MOM OR
DAD OR FOSTER MOM WALKING IN
THE BACKGROUND. WE CAN EASILY
ACCESS THEM. AT THE SAME TIME.
DUE IN PART TO THE SHIP TO
DISTANCE LEARNING OUR USUAL
MEANS OF IDENTIFYING AND
CONNECTING WITH CHILDREN HAS
BEEN IMPACTED. A SOME OF OUR
SCHOOLS WON'T ALLOW BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS ON CAMPUS FOR
FEAR OF SPREADING THOUGH THE
VIRUS. SO FOR EXAMPLE SCHOOL
BASED REFERRALS MIGHT BE DOWN
IN SOME CASES AS MUCH AS
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. BUT
COUNTIES RESPONDED TO THIS
CHALLENGE IN SEVERAL WAYS WE
HAVE REDIRECTED SCHOOL BASED
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE OTHER
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
WITHOUT REACH TO SELFIES TO
ENSURE WE ARE PARTING WITH OUR
EDUCATION PARTNERS AND- TO
IDENTIFY TARGETS STUDENTS WHO
MAY BE AT HIGHER RISK. WE ARE
INCREASING OUR OUTREACH TO
SCHOOL FAMILIES AND PARTNERING
WITH SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP
CURRICULUM ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WITH THE SCHOOLS ARE
DISSEMINATING AS WELL. AND
WE'VE INCREASED MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE SERVICES SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE OLD HAND OUT
UNFORTUNATELY AS THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY PREFERRED SERVICE.
I'LL BE AT ONE WITH MINIMAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEDIC CALORIE
ENFORCEMENT. KENNY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HAS BEEN. AT THIS A LONG
TIME AND WE ARE EXCITED TO
SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE WITH OUR
PARTNERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR KELLY NEXT MICHELLE CABRERA.
HI MISTER SHARON MEMBERS I WILL
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT NOW TO SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES AND WHAT WE
THINK- WE SHOULD DO ABOUT THEM-
WE WILL BE TALKING LATER ABOUT
HOW AIMED MORE AT LENGTH BUT I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT-
FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AT
CHILDREN'S MEDICAL NECESSITY
CRITERIA FOR ACCESSING
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BUT THE ISSUE THAT
WOULD FLAG FIRE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND AS
OVERDUE FOR REFORM. AND EVEN-
PRETEND THAT MAKE IN ORDER TO
INCREASE- MEDIC HOW BILLABLE
SERVICES- THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING UP CURRENTLY AS YOU
MAY KNOW A CHILD WERE YOU MUST
HAVE A DIAGNOSIS IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE SPECIAL CAN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THIS HAS
EXPOSED COUNTY TO SIGNIFICANT
STATE AND FEDERAL AUDITORS
ALLOWANCES. MADE IT A REAL
CHALLENGE FOR COUNTIES TO FUND
CERTAIN SERVICES TO CHILDREN
UNDER MEDIC HOW SO WITH THE
PROPOSED REFORMS UNDER KELLY
MARC HOPE IS THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE MORE OF THOSE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FONG AND SHOW THE
COLDER POLICY MAKERS THE FULL
PICTURE OF WHAT CHILDREN AND
YOUTH ARE CURRENTLY ACCESSING
TO. COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO USE THOSE
ADDED DOLLARS TO BUILD. OUT THE
CERTIFICATE. UNDER CARRY KELLY
COUNTY AND ALSO I THE STATE
FIFTY. APPROVAL FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
AUTOMATIC CAL. TO SPECIAL
MENTAL SERVICES- WHICH ARE
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE FOR ALL
FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL AS
HOMELESS YOUTH- THIS WOULD HELP
US. TO AMELIORATE OR PREVENT
MEDICAL CONDITION THANK YOU FOR
CONDITIONS ANOTHER AT THE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. AND THEN WE
ARE PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE TO INITIATE AND
FINANCE OUR STATE WIDE NETWORK
OF EARLY PSYCHOSIS- AT CLINICAL
OFFERING WITH AN HSA FUNDS-
WE'VE NOT ONLY GROWN THESE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE LEARNING COLLABORATIVE HAVE
HELPED COUNTY TO COMPARE NOTES.
AND BRING EMERGING BEST
PRACTICE TO THE FOR- ONE OF
THE- INITIATIVE THAT WE'VE
REALLY TAKEN UNDERTAKEN WITH
RESPECT TO EARLY PSYCHOSIS WORK
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WORK
IS ADAPTED TO CALIFORNIA'S.
DIVERSE POPULATION WITH MORE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
ALIGNED SERVICES- WE BELIEVE
THAT HE ROAD AHEAD WILL NOT BE
EASY BUT CHILDREN AND OUR
SYSTEMS ARE RESILIENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RIGHT TO
FOCUS ON BUILDING OUT SCHOOL
BASED PARTNERSHIP AT THEY ARE
CRUCIAL AFTER THAT POINT- BUT
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE UPON THAT
WORK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THOSE EFFORTS ARE SCALED UP TO
INCLUDE NOT JUST MEDIC HOW- BUT
ALSO REGIONAL CENTERS. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
INSURERS ARE DOING THEIR BEST
TO MAKE SURE THEY BEACH
CHILDREN FAMILIES BEFORE THEY-
FALL INTO CRISIS- BECAUSE
SCHOOLS HAVE EXPRESSED THE
DESIRE FOR OUR SCHOOL BASED
PARTNERSHIPS THAT SERVE ALL
CHILDREN. REGARDLESS OF
INSURANCE HI AT B. H. IN BOXING
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR EIGHTY
FIVE BY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA TO BETTER ENGAGE
PRIVATE PLAN IN THE DELIVERY
AND FINANCING OF THESE
PARTNERSHIPS. FOR THE FIFTY PER
CALIFORNIA'S WHO ARE CO BY THE
HEALTH WE HOW TO REMEMBER THAT
COUNTY HEALTH PLANS OFFER A
MUCH FOR. BRING OF BASED
SERVICE. NOT JUST UNDER MY BUT
OF NON HOW MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT SERVICES AS WELL
AS OUR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
BLOCK GRANT FUNDED SERVICES.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD ENSURE
THAT MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
INFORMING MEDIC HELP AND
APPRECIATE THAT THE
AVAILABILITY OF MILD TO
MODERATE BENEFITS FOR CHILDREN
AND INCENTIVIZING THEIR
PROVIDERS TO CONDUCT HE HE HE
WILL HELP BRING HER CHILDREN.
AS SCREENING AND REFERRALS ARE
FOR MANAGED CARE RESPONSIBILITY
UNDER EPS EIGHTEEN AND IMPROVED
ACCESS TO THE MILD TO MODERATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WILL
HELP MITIGATE THE TRENDS THAT
WE'RE SEEING. WE CANNOT ATTEMPT
TO EXPAND ALL OF THESE SERVICES
TO THE DEGREE THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING WITHOUT AS A SERIOUS
LOOK AT THE WORK FORCE- I. TO
SERVE CHILDREN AND YOU WE NEED
MORE PROVIDERS AS WELL AS MORE
TRAINING IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. AND
CALIFORNIA NEEDS MORE ACCESS TO
HIGH ACUITY SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN THE
STATE. IF THE PANDEMIC TRENDS
CONTINUE AT THIS INVESTMENT AS
WELL AS POLICY CHANGES MAY BE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS.
AS CLOSE TO HOME AS POSSBLE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO COMMENT ON THE ISSUE. THANK
NEXT WE HAVE J. HAM WHAT AT.
FOR THE- ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ARAMBULA NOW MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS JEFF
HAMPTON THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PLANS. I HEAR
REPRESENTING FORTY FIVE PUBLIC
NONPROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COLLECTIVELY
DELIVER HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK BUT INCLUDING
THE STREET TOGETHER. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INSIGHT INTO SOME OF
THE WORK THE HEALTH PLANS ARE
DOING IN THAT ACCOUNT IN THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET AROUND ITS
OWN BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES I
INCLUDING FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN- ARE BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
NEEDS AND PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE KNOW HOW. DECADES
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
STATE LEADERS AND POLICY MAKERS
TO GROW THE STATE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. SO THAT
PARTICULARLY IN TIMES OF CRISIS
OUR MEMBERS CAN CONTINUE TO
ACCESS THE CARE THEY NEED. WHEN
THEY NEED IT MOST. IN THE
CONTEXT OF TODAY'S HEARING. I
RECOGNIZE THAT. THE NINETEEN.
IN RESULT. IMPACT GROSSLY
AFFECTED MANY NOT HEALTH AND-
ADDITIONAL. FOR INDIVIDUALS
ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. FURTHERMORE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL WELLBEING. I'VE ALSO
BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS PAYMENT.
INTERESTING THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
FIRST QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO
HOW HEALTH PLANS APPLETON A
CONTROVERSIAL- MARKET ARE
MONITORING ASSESSING SEEKING
GROUP ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR YOU. I
HEALTH PLANS ARE ENGAGED IN AND
COMMITTED TO INSURANCE WOULD
YOU HAVE CRITICAL ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AM
ONLY RAMPED UP THE LEOPARDS
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE CALL
THE NINETEENTH ENDEMIC. I'M
GOING TO TAKE A VARIETY OF
ACTIONS TO AVOID AND ELIMINATE
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL
INTERRUPTIONS IN SERVICES TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. I
PARTICULARLY FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND MOVE QUICKLY I
MEAN EXCUSE ME AND MOVE QUICKLY
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC TO EXPAND. HEALTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ACCESS FOR YOU.
ALSO INTERNET FOR TO INCREASE
BEHAVIOR HOW ACT ANY. HIGH
SCHOOL IF YOU. MANY PLAN TO
PARTNER THE SCHOOL BASED
CLINICAL PROGRAMMING TO BRING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES IN SCHOOLS.
CREATING NEW PROGRAMS TO EXPAND
ONLINE ACCESS TO. TAILORED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. OFTENTIMES
UTILIZING EXISTING DIGITAL
PLATFORMS HERE TO THIS
GENERATION OF THE- I
SPECIFICALLY WE'VE HEARD FROM
ONE MAN WHO ISSEEKING TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO DATA HEALTH
SERVICES FOR YOUTH. VESTED IN
HERE HOT START UP THAT PROVIDES
VIRTUAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS. IT PROVIDES RENTAL
EDUCATION IN AN ENCOURAGING.
THIS HEALTH PLAN WILL BE
PILOTING THE PROGRAM. ALWAYS TO
MEASURE THE EFFICACY OUTCOMES
MAJOR HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDING
IN THIS EXAMPLE THE PRODUCT
WILL BE OFFERED TO MEMBERS AND
MARKET. I JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENS BEEN
DOING SINCE TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO THESE SERVICES THE PANDEMIC-
YOU DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY HAPPENED RIGHT IN
STATES INCREASE THE SERVICES
ARE INCLUDED CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS. SPECIFICALLY
HEALTH PLANS HAVE EXPANDED
ONLINE ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING PROVIDING
FREE DIGITAL RESOURCES MENTAL
HEALTH APPS PHONE AND VIDEO ALL
THERAPY SESSIONS. THE PUBLIC
WHAT ARE TO RAISE AWARENESS.
AROUND IMPLEMENT APRIL HELL.
MANY OF THESE TOOLS RESOURCE
ARE IS FOR TEENAGE AND TARGETED
TO PROVIDE TREATMENT FOR
DEPRESSION ANXIETY INSOMNIA
SUBSTANCE USE STRESS TRAUMA AND
MORE. WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED
CRISIS LINE AVAILABLE TO OLDER
MEMBERS BOTH THE NECK CAL AND
COMMERCIAL MARKET. IN THE
UNITED STATES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
ACCESS FOR CONFIDENTIAL
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT.
PROVIDED MEMBERS WITH TOOL KITS
AND MATERIALS SPECIFICALLY
DEVELOPED TO ADDRESS- NUMBERS
EXPERIENCING ANXIETY AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES LATE
NINETEEN. AYE WE'VE EXTENDED
CARSHARE WAIVER FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TELEMEDICINE VISITS.
ORDERED WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH SPECIFICALLY ONE PLAN
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO AMERICARES TOP
FRONTLINE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE SERVING LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS. I TO
IMPROVE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS KNOWLEDGE AND
RESILIENCY. UNDERSTANDABLE
HEALTH CONCERNS IMPACTING THEIR
PATIENTS. I WE UNDERSTAND WITH
INCREASED ANXIETY OVER CODE
NINETEEN OF THE COMPANIES YOU
CAN DEMOCRATS ARE THE MANY
HEALTH PLANS HAVE EXPANDED THAT
HELP SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS-
TO INCLUDE AGAIN ADDITIONAL
PERSONAL OPTIONS. ON IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS RESOURCES CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS BECAUSE PARTICULARLY ON
MIDDLE HIGH SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
AS I MENTIONED. IN AN OVERALL
CONTRIBUTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING CHANGES TO
OUR MENTAL HEALTH OFFERINGS
ENSURE BOTH ONLINE AND IN
PERSON ACCESS WILL CONTINUE.
EIGHT MILLION FOUR WE BELIEVE
THE HEALTH PLANS CAN CONTINUE
TO BUILD UPON THE ACTIVE ROLE
THERE THANKS FOR SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS RUN THE
STATE. FOR EXAMPLE HELPING CAN
BUILD UPON CURRENT CURRENTLY
EXISTING SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS THAT.
PROVIDE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH THERAPY SERVICES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS- THEY CAN ALSO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE HEALTH ISSUES
THAT HIGH SCHOOLS I RAISING
AWARENESS. REGARDING SERVICES
AN ADVOCATE FOR SUPPORT. IN
PROVIDING YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID TRAINING FOR
EDUCATORS AND HOW TO RECOGNIZE
SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS THAT YOU CAN
MEET SUPPORT AT G. EDUCATORS
FROM CALIFORNIA. EASIEST SOME
OF THE FEW OF THE EXAMPLES THAT
HELPING YOUR CURRENTLY DOING
AND THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BUILDING ON HOW TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND JUST LAST YEAR WON TENSIONS
MOVED THE THINGS THAT THAT
HAPPENS IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET ARE DOING. TO CONTRIBUTE
TO BUILDING THE PAPER HOLDEN
STRUCTURE WILL SERVE YOU
REGARDLESS OF HEALTH INSURANCE
STATUS. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
PERSONAL HELP AND CAN CONTINUE.
TO EXPAND THE ROLE IN
SUPPORTING SCHOOL WRAPAROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN MEET
YOUTH WHERE THEY ARE. PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THIS
COULD INCLUDE A VARIETY OF
THINGS INCLUDING COORDINATION
OF SERVICES PROVIDED ON SCHOOL
SITES NOT SO OFTEN IN THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. I MEAN CAN ALSO
PLAY A ROLE IN CONTINUING
SUPPORT PARTNERSHIP A SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS. ENSURE
THAT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
ARE CONNECTED TO A ROBUST
REFERRAL NETWORK AMONG OTHER
THINGS. AGAIN I'M THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THIS AFTERNOON AND HAPPY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE OF COURSE HOW SHE DEALT
WITH THE- ANALYST'S OFFICE.
JERRY COREY HAS SHE DONE WITH
THE L. A. L. I'LL JUST BE
GIVING SOME BRIEF COMMENTS THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON THE DH CS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM PROPOSAL AND-
JUST WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT WE RECENTLY
PUBLISHED AN ANALYSIS OF THIS
PROPOSAL ON OUR ON OUR WEBSITE.
FIRST WE JUST KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME SUBSTANTIAL DETAILS
RELATED TO THIS PROPOSAL THAT
REMAIN UNDER DEVELOPMENT- THESE
WOULD INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE THE
SPECIFIC ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
THAT WOULD DETERMINE HOW
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO MANAGED CARE
PLANS- IT'S ALSO OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL. ON THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENDS TO RELY ON BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE RATHER THAN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE- TO ESTABLISH THE
GRANT THE- THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS GIVEN THAT BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TYPICALLY LACKS
SPECIFICITY AND DETAIL WHEN
COMPARED TO- TRAILER BILL AND
WE FIND THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
ROLE IN PROVIDING- YOUR INPUT
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
DETAILS OF THIS PROPOSAL MAYBE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONSTRAINED UNDER
BUDGET BILL. AND SO WE'RE
RECOMMEND OR WORDS SUGGESTING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OWN ADOPT
THE- TRAILER BILL APPROACH TO
THIS TO THIS PROPOSAL- NEXT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE INTENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL WHILE WE DON'T
RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
CONCEPT OF INCREASING MANAGED
CARE. PLANS FOOTPRINT IN
SCHOOLS- YOU KNOW AS THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTED MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE ALREADY SORT OF
TASKED WITH PROVIDING A SET OF.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN- WE DO FIND WHETHER
IT'S UNCLEAR WE DO FIND THAT
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE AMOUNT
PROVIDED AN INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
WILL ACTUALLY INDUCE MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO INVEST IN THESE
PARTNERSHIPS- IN THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ONE ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW IT
DETERMINED THAT. THIS FUNDING
ABOUT WOULD SORT OF BE
SUFFICIENT TO ALTER PLAN
BEHAVIOR AND TO SET UP THESE
THESE PARTNERSHIPS. IN ADDITION
WE FIND THAT YOU KNOW A REAL
CHALLENGE WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS
GOING TO BE NAVIGATING SORT OF
THE VERY FRAGMENTED BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY AS IT AS IT RELATES
TO CHILDREN-AS DISCUSSED
EARLIER YOU KNOW STUDENTS CAN
ACCESS. MANY CAL BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES THROUGH SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ENTITIES- BE IT
COUNTY IS MANAGED CARE PLANS
OUR SCHOOLS DIRECTLY- AND WHICH
ENTITY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT-
THROUGH MEDICARE CAN OFTEN SORT
OF BE. DETERMINED INCONSISTENT.
IN ADDITION AS SORT OF THE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES NOTED ON
THIS CALL ON THIS- MEETING
EARLIER THAT- YOU KNOW COUNTY'S
MAIL ALREADY SORT OF PROVIDE
THE SAME. SERVICES IN SCHOOLS
THAT MANAGED CARE PLANS COULD
PROVIDE BUT- THEY THEY MIGHT
JUST SORT OF USE THEIR LOCAL
COUNTY FINDS INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THROUGH
THE MEDIC HOW- ALL OF THIS IS
TO SAY THAT THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY SORT OF HIGHLIGHTS THE
NEED FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CLARIFY EXACTLY WHAT SERVICED.
SERVICE GAPS EXIST CURRENTLY
THAT MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
SORT OF UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO
FILL. AND FOR A REALLY CALM.
STATE EFFORT- EVEN THINKING
MORE GENERALLY OUTSIDE OF THIS
PROPOSAL TO COORDINATE ACROSS
THESE DIFFERENT ENTITIES TO
ENSURE THAT. A ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS ARE
ENTITLED THROUGH THROUGH
MEDICARE HOW ARE BEING PROVIDED
IN. THE THAT SORT OF NO
DUPLICATED SERVICES ARE ARE
BEING PROVIDED- JUST FINALLY
JUST WANT TO SORT OF ADD THAT
ON WHILE WE DON'T RAISE ANY
ISSUES WITH THE- THE OASES OF
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT PROPOSAL THERE IS GANG
RELATED PROPOSAL IN THE
EDUCATION SPACE- TO PROVIDE-
SORT OF LIKE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MATCHING FUNDS FOR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH ACTIVITIES. ON
WHERE WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL AND- YOU KNOW THE MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON OUR
ANALYSIS OF THAT. CAN BE FOUND
ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL- SO THAT
THAT SORT OF BOOKLETS ARE ARE
REMARKS FOR THIS THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I WILL
BRING IT BACK UP TO THE DíAS
FOR QUESTIONS I WILL BEGIN- AND
IF I CAN'T I DO WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT I
HEARD- WE HEARD FROM DIRECTOR.
LIGHT BORN THAT ALL CHILDREN
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS AND WITHOUT
DELAY. WE HEARD FROM- TOBY
HEWING. ABOUT HOW SCHOOLS ARE.
READY TO CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET
CHILDREN'S NEEDS. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HELPING TO
ELEVATE THE USE VOICE ABOUT
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH. WE HEARD
FROM DR KELLY THAT CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING MORE AND MORE DURING
THE SPENDING. PLAN SO IT'S WITH
THAT IN MIND THAT I WANT TO ASK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT URGENCY. TO
THE ADMINISTRATION IF I CAN.
THERE'S A BIG PUS BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP US TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS. AND I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND IF THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING FASTER
ACTION ON A PACKAGE OF SCHOOL
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS. RATHER THAN WAITING
UNTIL JUNE. SO I'LL START AND
OTHERS CAN DEFINITELY- JUMP IN
I THINK THAT- IT'S CLEAR TO US
AS YOU CAN SEE DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN. MORE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED DURING
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN TWENTY
NINETEEN. IT AND THE REASON WHY
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING FOR
PEOPLE TO LOOK AT IS THAT BUT
ALL OTHER UTILIZATION. IN MEDIC
CAL AND THAT'S ALL I CAN SPEAK
FOR- INCLUDING INPATIENT
EMERGENCY ROOM AND REGULAR OUT
PATIENT CARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER AND UTILIZATION IN TWENTY
TWENTY COMPARED TO TWENTY
NINETEEN BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THE ONLY OUT
LIAR- IS CONSISTENTLY-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
UNDERSCORING THE NEED- SO I
THINK YOU KNOW I TAKE YOUR
POINT A VERY. NEARLY AND IT'S
SOMETHING WE DEFINITELY WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK AT I THINK IT'S
WHY YOU SEE THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU THAT THERE IS A GROWING
CONSENSUS THAT WE NEED TO EVEN
WITH A LOT OF THE GREAT-
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS BEEN
PUT IN PLACE PRIOR TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ACTION
AND- THE EXPERIENCE AND LESSONS
LEARNED THAT WE'VE HAD ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES CLEARLY SEES WE NEED
TO DO MORE AND WE NEED TO THINK
MORE UPSTREAM AND PREVENTIVE
AND EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES- AND SO- WELL I CAN'T-
RESPOND TO HER DIRECT REQUEST
IN REGARDS TO AN ADMINISTRATION
SO CLOSE I THINK. WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN REGARDS TO HOW
WE ENSURE CHILDREN ARE GETTING
INCREASED ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES HARPER COURT MEETING
ACROSS SO MANY DELIVERY SYSTEMS
IN FUNDING STREAM- AND. WE ARE
VERY COMMITTED TO THAT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE AND- I'D
LIKE TO NOW TALK ABOUT THE
FRAGMENTED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND- I THOUGHT THE L.
A. O. FRAMED IT QUITE WELL.
WHEN THEY ASKED IF YOU COULD
CLEARLY ARTICULATE. WHAT
SPECIFIC SERVICES MANAGED CARE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
STUDENTS. THAT CANNOT CURRENTLY
PROVIDED BY SCHOOLS DIRECTLY OR
THROUGH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WAS HOPING THAT YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THAT. SHARKS
WE'LL START WITH- THE SCHOOLS
SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE ON THE L.
A. BACH PROGRAM WHO PROVIDES-
SOME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
THROUGH L. A. BACH YOU ONLY
HAVE AROUND A 58% OF OUR LEDS
PERSISTENT PAIN IN THE L. A.
BACH PROGRAM ROBERT IS A HIGHER
PROPORTION OF CHILDREN- SERVICE
HOWEVER WHEN YOU ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES THROUGH THE L. A. BOB
PROGRAM I'M IT IS ONLY FOR A
SELECT. LIST OF SERVICES
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IN THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS RESTRICTIONS
AROUND WHO CAN RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE I'M ONLY
THOSE WHO HAVE. THAT IN THEIR
CARE PLAN OR I H. P. R. I. D.
SORRY BOUT THAT- INCLUDES A
LIMITED NUMBER OF CHILDREN-
WHERE THAT IS BEING SERVED- AND
THEN OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. PARTNERS WELL THEY
HAVE- PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF SERVICES IN THIS
SPACE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SCHOOLS- IT'S DOMINI BEEN
FOCUSED ON SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES WHICH IS VERY
CRITICAL SERVICES- WE DO KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE PROVIDED SUCH A
NON SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITH AN HSA FUNDS.
HOWEVER WE ARE PAYING OUR
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
PROVIDE THE NON SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR ALL
CHILDREN- AND WE DO THINK THAT
OF THAT IS THAT GAP WE ARE
TRYING TO CLOSE THE MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN. ARE NOT GOING TO NEED
A SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES IT'S VERY CRITICAL
THAT YOU DO NEED AND SO WE'RE
VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP THE COUNTIES HAVE
PLAYED. IT WITH THE SCHOOLS IN
THAT SPACE- HOWEVER WE ARE
TRYING TO IN BED IN. THE MORE
PREVENTATIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES THAT ARE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A FOR
CHILDREN- AND SO WE DO FEEL
LIKE. DOING THAT THROUGH THE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS WHERE THERE'S
BEEN. SUCCESS WITH PROVIDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES NOT
ALL SERVICES CAN YOU KNOW
EASILY BE PROVIDED ON A SCHOOL
BASED SETTING- BUT WE DO FEEL
LIKE THERE IS A REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
WITH OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
MANAGED CARE PLANS I WOULD
NOTICE- THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF. YEARS GIVEN TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS AS TO WHY
THIS HAS BEEN CHALLENGING IN
THE FUTURE- AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH OUR-
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF.
EDUCATION AND OUR ACCOUNT-
NURSE WHO HAVE FOR INTO. A THIS
TO LEARN FROM THEM LET THAT.
INTO BUT PROVIDE INTO. ACROSS
THAT WHEN YOU WERE RECEIVING
SERVICES AT THE SCHOOL WHETHER
IT'S TO LA POP THE COUNTY OR
THE MEDICARE PLANS IT'S
INTEGRATED- AND HOPEFULLY
THAT'S THE SYSTEM WE CAN GET
YOU IN THE FUTURE AND THAT'S
WHY WE FOCUSED THE DOLLARS ON
INCENTIVES. TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY TO BUILD THAT
PARTNERSHIP INTO A FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAY BE
NEEDED IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE SPACE. FOR
THE FIRST STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AND FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT YOU
JUST SAID REGARDING THE
FRAGMENTED. SYSTEM I'D LIKE TO
URGE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENGAGE AND REAL COORDINATION
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMNT.
INCLUDING THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY- DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- M. H. O. E. C. AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL AND OTHERS AS
YOU SEE APPROPRIATE TO REALLY
COME UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN AYE I THINK OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE THAT AND REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THAT- SO THAT. THE
NEXT TIME WE SPEAK WE CAN TALK
ABOUT A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM THAT AS MEETING OUR
STUDENTS NEEDS. I WOULD LIKE TO
NOW MOVE ON IF I CAN'T- JEFF
HAMPTON- REGARDING MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND WE SEE THAT BOTH
MEDICAL AND COMMERCIAL OUR-
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THROUGH DTE AND THE L. A-
APPROPRIATELY COMMENTS THAT
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS
PARTICIPATION THUS FAR AND I
WANTED TO SEE IF MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE WILLING AND EAGER TO
BRING RESOURCES TO AND TO MAKE
A COMMITMENT TO OUR SCHOOL
BASED SERVICES AND MORE AND
GENERALLY TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
OUR YOUTH. THANK YOU FOR A
REASON QUESTION YEAH ABSOLUTELY
I THINK I'M YOU KNOW I IN
REGARDS TO THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL I YOU KNOW WE ARE WE
ARE- EVEN. WILLING TO ENGAGE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WITH BERMAN
HEALTHCARE SERVICE AND OTHERS
TO. MORE ABOUT SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL BUT A YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF BUILDING UPON I
INCREASING ACCESS TO SCHOOL
BASED SERVICES. FOR YOU I YOU
KNOW I WOULD. ABSOLUTELY BE
WILLING TO- YOU KNOW ENGAGEMENT
PARTNER WITH YOU KNOW ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THAT PROCESS-
YEAH I KNOW WE HAVE MENTIONED
THAT YOU KNOW I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT YOU WE HAVE
STARTED BUILDING THE
GROUNDWORK. FOR SOME OF THAT
WORK THAT THAT'S BEING DONE
NOW- AND CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING ADAM YOU KNOW HOW
THAT THE BALLOT OUT- YOU KNOW
IN THE SPACE BUT THAT BOTH
MEDICARE AND COMMERCIAL MARKETS
UP. I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION DOCTOR ANYWAY IS
YES I THINK WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
HE GAVE ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS- AND SEEING HOW WE CAN
INCREASE ACCESS AND SERVICES-
YOU KNOW I AT. SCHOOL THEY
STAND IN THE COMMUNITY. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COMP. I
HIGHLIGHTED THE USE YOU- YOU
OFTEN USE EXISTING DIGITAL
PLATFORMS I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE CURRENTLY HAS
BEEN PAID FOR BY MEDICARE ALL
AND IT BENEFITS ALL STUDENTS
AND REALLY WOULD. WANT TO
FRUITFUL CONVERSATIONAND I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP BUT WITH
THAT I WILL THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL TWO ONE WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON THE PANEL THREE ON SUICIDE
AND OVERDOSE PREVENTION. AGAIN
WE WILL NOW HAVE SIX PRESENTERS
AND WILL HOLD ALL MEMBERS
QUESTIONS UNTIL WE HAVE
CONCLUDED WE WILL BEGIN WITH DR
EWING PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
DR ARAMBULA AGAIN TOOK DEALING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION
YOU KNOW I JUST I WANNA AND-
JUST QUICKLY REVIEW THAT THE
BACKGROUND. ON THE DRAFTING OF
STRIVING FOR ZERO THAT THIS IS
A PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS
DEVELOPED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU RECALL SEVERAL
YEARS OF CONVERSATION. OVER THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
STRENGTHENING OF THE STATE'S
SUICIDE PREVENTION RESPONSE M.
AND AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF
CONVERSATION THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED THE COMMISSION IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. TO DEVELOP A
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
COMMISSION- WE UNDERTOOK A
LENGTHY PROCESS OF ENGAGING
WITH COUNTY PARTNERS TALKING TO
PARTNER STATE AGENCIES SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS. IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO ACROSS THE COUNTRY
LOOKING AT MODEL PROGRAMS IN IN
INDIA AND IN THE VERY END OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED STRIVING FOR ZERO
CALIFORNIA'S DID YOU PLAN FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION. THIS THIS
PLAN WAS VERY INTENTIONAL AND
DESIGN THAT IT STARTS OFF WITH
CLEAR ACCESS TO INFORMATION ON
WHAT TO DO. IF YOU ARE THINKING
ABOUT SUICIDE WE WANTED TO MAKE
IT VERY ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO NEEDED ACCESS TO A CRISIS
LINE OR A HOTLINE. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT DHS IS
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT TO
THEIR STUDENTS THERE HAVE CAL
HOPE PROJECT HAS REALLY BEEN
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN ACCESS
TO. ON BASED CARE TO TEXT BASED
AND DIGITAL PLATFORMS TO
RESPOND TO PEOPLE WHO MAY BE IN
CRISIS. SO THE QUESTION REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT-INFORMATION IS ACCESSIBLE AND
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT WHEN THEY NEED IT. THE
REPORT REALLY THEN LOOKS AT IT
PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND ON HOW
TO THINK ABOUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION TRY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT SUICIDAL
BEHAVIOR ABOUT RISK ASSESSMENT
AROUND TRANS. AND WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THOSE PRACTICES THAT HAVE
BEST AVAILABLE EVIDENCE OF
BEING EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
SUICIDE. BASED ON THAT
INFORMATION THIS PLAN REALLY
LAYS OUT A- AN OPERATIONAL
APPROACH ENHANCES MEMBER RAMOS
COMMENTED EARLIER IN THIS
HEARING. THAT THEY'RE STATES
VERY AGGRESSIVE PUSH TO RE
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO SITE IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT TOUCHES
UPON A NUMBER OF FACTORS AROUND
ACCESSING THE FULL MEANS AROUND
RESPOND TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CRISIS THERE THERE'S THE NEED
TO EDUCATE AND ENGAGE SENT TO.
EXPLORE HOW WE BEST DO SUICIDE
RISK ASSESSMENTS THE FOLLOW UP
THAT WE DO AFTER THOSE RISK
ASSESSMENTS WE NEED TO TRACK
THAT KIND OF RISK ASSESSMENTS
THAT ARE BEING DONE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE THE DATA STRATEGY. I
JUST I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
COKE HAS REALLY REVEALED HOW
QUICKLY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN GIVE CAN
CREATE ACCESS TO REAL TIME
INFORMATION I'M JUST SO
IMPRESSED THAT EVERY NIGHT WE
CAN SEE DATA ON HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
RECEIVED THE VACCINE. THOSE
DATA ARE AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS UNFORTUNATELY OUR
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS OUR
DATA ARE IN NO WAY AS
ACCEPTABLE AND AS TIMELY AS
THAT INFORMATION. THE CAPTION
IS ROCK THE CREATION OF THIS
OFFICERS PREVENTION AS OUTLINED
IN THIS REPORT TO REALLY DO
PROVIDE THE LEADERSHIP. TO
ADDRESS EACH OF THOSE ISSUES
AROUND TRAINING AWARENESS DATA
UNDERSTANDING AND TO PROMOTE
THE RIGHT KINDS OF PROGRAMMATIC
AND STRATEGIC INTERVENTIONS
THAT ARE NECESSARY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTIES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR SCHOOLS.
ARE AT PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHERS WE NEED THIS HIGH
LEVEL CONVERSATION ABOUT
SUICIDE SO THAT WE CAN THE
STATEMENT TIES MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO ACCESS CARE. IN
THE COMMISSION'S WORK IN
TALKING WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUICIDE SURVIVORS. THEY OFTEN
SPEAK VERY ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONNECTING WITH
SOMEONE WHO HELPED THEM GET
THROUGH EIGHT A MOMENT OF
STRESS A MOMENT OF CRISIS- THAT
OFTEN THEY HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT FOR QUITE SOME TIME. BUT
THEIR ABILITY TO CONNECT IS
ACTUALLY WHAT OFTEN HELPS THEM
MOVE PAST THAT MOMENT OF CRISIS
AND MOVE TOWARDS RECOVERY AND
LONG TERM HEALTHIER
RELATIONSHIPS IN TERMS OF THEIR
PRICES. IN ADDITION TO CREATING
THIS OFTEN SUICIDE PREVENTION
YES PLAN REALLY CALLS FOR
BUILDING OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO SUPPORT SUICIDE PREVENTION
THAT IS ABOUT IDENTIFYING BEST
PRACTICES. AND DOING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING TO PROMOTE
THEIR ADOPTION ACROSS THE STATE
WE HAVE A VERY DISTRIBUTED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN
THIS STATE. AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION ISN'T JUST THE
PURVIEW OF ONE ENTITY IT REALLY
MEANS ENGAGING MULTIPLE
PARTNERS ACROSS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
REALLY NEED TO BUILD OUT
TRUSTED CHANNELS THAT PEOPLE
CAN TALK WITH OR CAN TALK TO OR
CAN ACCESS IN TERMS OF
INFORMATION ON SUICIDE THERE'S
THIS PERSISTENT NOTION THAT
TALKING TO PEOPLE ABOUT SUICIDE
WILL INCREASE THE RISK OF
SUICIDE WHEN IN FACT THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IT'S QUITE
THE OPPOSITE. WE ALSO NEED TO
REALLY BUT YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
STRATEGIES TO MINIMIZE RISK BY
PROMOTING SAFE ENVIRONMENTS WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT REDUCING
ACCESS TO LETHAL MEANS AND SO
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FOR
EXAMPLE. FUNDED A BARRIER ON
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE TO
REDUCE SUICIDE RESTS THERE. IN
THIS COUNTRY WHERE WE- CAN USE
IT IS OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AND THERE ARE
SOME VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTIES IN
OTHER STATES. THAT ARE WORKING
WITH GUN CLUBS GUNS SHOPS AND
GUN OWNERS TO CREATE POWERFUL
MESSAGES TO SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO
ARE GUN OWNERS. TO KEEP THEIR
GUNS SAFELY LOCKED AWAY OR TO
TRANSPORT LEGALLY TRANSFER
THEIR GUNS TO A TRUSTED
NEIGHBORS OR FAMILY MEMBERS
DURING PERIODS OF CRISIS THAT
WE CAN REDUCE ACCESS TO VEHICLE
MEANS. WE ALSO HAVE TO. IMPROVE
THE EARLY IDENTIFICATION OF
RISKS AND IMPROVE THE
CONNECTION TO SERVICES ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON. IS TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
KINDS OF SUICIDE SCREENING
THAT'S HAPPENING AND HOW WE CAN
CREATE A MORE STANDARDIZED
APPROACH TO SUICIDE SCREENS AND
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF
THE SCREENS AND WHAT THEY TELL
US. ABOUT RISKS ACROSS THE
STATE. INCLUDING SCREENS THAT
HAPPENING THROUGH SCHOOLS AND I
MENTION THAT BECAUSE THE
CONVERSATION I JUST HAD AROUND
AS WELL HOW. AND LASTLY I WOULD
SAY. WE ALSO NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR SUICIDE RELATED SERVICES
AND SUPPORT EXACTLY WHAT WE
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS POST
PENSION. RIGHT OFF AND WE HEAR
FROM FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE HAD SOME SUICIDE
RELATED INCIDENT AND THERE ARE
ACCESSING CRISIS SERVICES- BUT
UPON RELEASE FROM HOSPITAL OR
AFTER AN ASSESSMENT THERE ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE POST PENSION
FOLLOW UP THAT IS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. BECAUSE THE RISK THAT
MIGHT HAVE LED TO THE SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS AND SUICIDAL BEHAVIORS
OFTEN DOESN'T GO AWAY. SO TOOK
THIS REPORT IS REALLY DESIGNED
TO CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE SET
OF STRATEGIES THAT CAN
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO SUICIDE AND N. AS
STATED IN THE TITLE STRIVE TO
GET TO ZERO IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF SUICIDE DEATHS WE
HAVE IN THE STATE. IN THE
AGENDA- YOUR STAFF ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE WORK THAT WE
ARE DOING TO IMPLEMENT THE PLAN
AT THE MOMENT AND SO IS
MENTIONED THERE THE COMMISSION
HAD SET ASIDE. TWO MILLION
DOLLARS JUST OF OUR OPERATING
FUNDS WE SHIFTED AROUND SOME
FUNDS INTERNALLY IN ESSENCE WE-DELAYED SOME PAYMENTS FROM ONE
FISCAL YEAR TO THE NEXT.
RECOGNIZING THAT BECAUSE OF
COBEN SUICIDE RISK WOULD BE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AND WE
WANTED TO ADVANCE THE WORK IN
THIS PLAN AS QUICKLY AND
AGGRESSIVELY AS WE CAN. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THESE BONDS TO
STRENGTHEN LOCAL PLANNING WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS AND SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH COUNTIES TO
BUILD OUT A LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE SO THAT COUNTIES
CAN LEARN FROM AND WITH EACH
OTHER. WE RECOGNIZE THAT QUITE
OFTEN THE EXPERTISE IS IN OUR
COUNTIES AND THEY'RE ASKING FOR
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO LEARN FROM EACH OTHER. WE
ARE INVESTING A TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AROUND REDUCING ACCESS
TO LETHAL MEANS WITH A HEAVY
EMPHASIS ON GUNS- AND AGAIN
THAT IS ABOUT ENGAGING PEOPLE.
AROUND STATE OWNERSHIP OF GUNS
AND CREATING SAFE PROTOCOLS AND
PRACTICES IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
GUN OWNERS SO THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT RISK OF SUICIDE HAVE A
WAY. TO SAFELY I'M BASS SET
ASIDE OR LOCK UP THEIR
FIREARMS. WE SOME OF THESE
FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO
INCREASE TRAINING BOTH IN TERMS
OF. RECOGNIZING SIGNS OF
SUICIDE HOW TO ENGAGE HOW TO
TALK TO PEOPLE WHO ARE THINKING
OF SUICIDE AND HOW TO DO FORMAL
RISK ASSESSMENTS. AND THE LAST
PIECE THAT WE'RE THAT WE HAVE
NOT YET GOTTEN STARTED WITH IS
REALLY BUILDING OUT A RESEARCH
AGENDA FOR SUICIDE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER. THERE MANY
AREAS IN HEALTHCARE THAT WE
HAVE DONE JUST A PHENOMENAL
JOB. OF MAKING AVAILABLE DATA
IT IS USEFUL FOR DECISION
MAKING- WE HAVE TO STRENGTHEN
OUR UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STATE. FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION. THE LAST OF
QUESTIONS. IN IN THE AGENDA
REALLY GET OUT WHAT ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US VERY
QUICKLY. TO ADD TO RESPOND AND
I WILL SAY BASED ON YOUR LAST
QUESTION ABOUT CAN WE MOVE
FASTER ON SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH.
FOR THE COMMISSION SUICIDE
PREVENTION IS PART OF OUR
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH STRATEGY
AND WE WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. MOVE VERY
QUICKLY TO DISTRIBUTE. NEWLY
AVAILABLE AND HSS A FUNDS TO
OUR SCHOOL AND COUNTY PARTNERS
WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN- MY
STAFF SAYS THAT. WE COULD
PROBABLY DO THAT IT'S AN S.
SIXTY TO NINETY DAY TIME FRAME.
IF COUNTIES CAN RESPOND THAT
QUICKLY WHICH THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF THE
STRESS THAT THEY ARE UNDER
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. BUT IN
TERMS OF- OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
TO STRENGTHEN OUR SAYS THAT
PREVENTION WORK AND I REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON RETURN TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SO
MUCH ATTENTION AND AWARENESS OF
RISKS ACCRUING TO YOUNG PEOPLE
AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF
NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR
STUDENTS TO RETURN THAT IF THEY
ARE HEALTHY THEY WILL BE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE HEALTHY. AND
SO TRAINING AND SUPPORT FOR
TEACHERS AND WHAT WE MIGHT CALL
FRONTLINE WORKERS BECAUSE THEY
ARE VERY MUCH ON THE FRONT LINE
IN TERMS OF OUR SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR YOU WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE NEEDS OF OUR
SCHOOL STAFF WE ALSO HAVE TO
BUILD OUT AWARENESS AMONG
SCHOOL STAFF OF WHAT SUICIDE
PREVENTION MEANS AND HOW TO
ENGAGE THE KINDS OF RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE HOW TO DO
REFERRALS AND HOW TO ACCESS
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
THERE ARE. NUMEROUS PROGRAMS
AROUND THE STATE THAT ARE. IN
THAT ARE IN POSITION TODAY-
POCKETS OF EXCELLENCE THAT CAN
SUPPORT THE SCREENING THAT IS
NEEDED FOR STANDS AROUND
SUICIDE PREVENTION. THAT CAN
TRIAGE THOSE NEEDS WITH THE
RIGHT KINDS OF INTERVENTIONS
QUITE OFTEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE SCHOOLS ARE ON SCHOOL SITE-
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED BY
DIRECTOR KELLY IN DECEMBER TO
DINO. A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
IN SOME PLACES THAT CAN VERY
EFFECTIVELY STRENGTHEN OUR
SUICIDE RESPONSE. WE ALSO NEED
TO RECOGNIZE OPPORTUNITIES TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CRISIS NETWORKS
AND I MENTIONED THIS EARLIER
AND IT WAS MENTIONED THAT HELLO
HOPE IS REALLY CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE TO
LEVERAGE DIGITAL PLATFORMS AND
TECH TEXT BASED STRATEGIES THAT
COULD BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY NEED TO ACCESS
INFORMATION OR CARE- BUT MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO. GET THE
PHYSICALLY DOWN TO EIGHT A. M.
I MENTAL HEALTH. PROVIDER AND
SO WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT THAT IN
TERMS OF CRISIS SERVICES BUT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE KINDS OF
STRATEGIES AS A WAY TO REDUCE
THE DEMAND ON CRISIS SERVICES
HOW CAN WE CREATE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. TO MITIGATE THE
NEED TO TURN TO THOSE WHETHER
IT'S AN ER OR OR OTHER KIND OF
A CRISIS SERVICES. WE ALSO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE- OPPORTUNITIES TO
DO MOBILE CRISIS BETTER THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES HAS A
THERAPEUTIC TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. THAT'S GETTING VERY
GOOD REVIEWS IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THIS INNOVATION AND
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE KINDS OF STRATEGIES THAT
BRING CRISIS STAFF TO THE HOMES
OR WORKPLACES OR LOCATIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED. AND
WORK HOW MIGHT THOSE KINDS OF
STRATEGIES TO STRENGTHEN OUR
SUICIDE PREVENTION
OPPORTUNITIES IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE.
IN IN IN IN TERMS OF. MY LAST
COMMENT IS REALLY IN THE FALL
OF THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE WE REALLY NEED TO
STRENGTHEN. THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE LEVERAGE OUR SCHOOLS. AND I
AND I JUST IN LIGHT OF THE
COMMENTS ABOUT MANAGED CARE AND
COUNTIES WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
MANAGED CARE PLANS OFTEN DO
RESPOND TO MILD AND MODERATE
BUT COUNTIES ALSO I DON'T KNOW
HOW SERVICES ACTED THE
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
COMPONENT. ALSO HAVE A MANDATE.
TO PROVIDE PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES AND SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN BUILD OUT THAT
PARTNERSHIP. AND THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND SCHOOLS CAN BE
HERO HEALTH INCLUDE MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND THAT PARTNERSHIP
ALSO NEEDS TO BE ENGAGED AROUND
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON ON THE
PLAN OR HOW SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD SET
ASIDE. IS BEING DEPLOYED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE HAVE
MONICA MORALES DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU EVERYONE I'LL
BE DISCUSSING A LITTLE BIT OF-
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE ARE NOT
SUICIDE AS WELL AS- AN OVERVIEW
OF THE CDC. A SUICIDE
PREVENTION GRANT THAT ARE AT
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED SO-
WITH THE DATA- IN TERMS OF THE
MOST CURRENT STATED ON SUICIDE.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY NINETY
IN BIOSTATISTICS DATA. FIRST
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FEET SUICIDE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THE RATE
OF SUICIDE DEATHS IS MORE THAN
THREE TIMES HIGHER AMONG MEN.
THAN WOMEN. RATES OF SUICIDE
ARE HIGHEST AMONG WHITES
FOLLOWED BY AFRICAN. EXCUSE ME
FOR ALL THE BY AMERICAN. INDIAN
ALASKAN POPULATIONS. THE
HIGHEST RATE OCCUR AMONG.
OLDEST RESIDENTS EIGHTY FIVE
YEARS OLD AND OLDER. OUR ARMS
ARE USED IN MORE THAN ONE THIRD
OF SUICIDES OUR ARMS FOR
HOUSTON 41% AMOUNTS TO A SITE
FOR EXAMPLE IN 35% OF MY ALSO
SITES WERE USED IN- SO SIDE
REDUCED HANGING SUFFOCATION.
AMONG FEMALE DESCENDANTS
HANGING SUFFOCATION AND
POISONING OR THE MOST COMMON.
WELL 70% OF FEMALE SISTER SITES
HOUSTON FIRE ARMS. ADDITIONALLY
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN DATA FROM
THE CALIFORNIA VIOLENT DEATH
REPORTING SYSTEM SHOW THAT
NEARLY ONE IN TWO SUICIDE
DISSIDENTS HAD A CURRENT
DIAGNOSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS. IN MORE THAN ONE IN
FOUR HAD AN ALCOHOL OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEM. ONE IN
FOUR HAD CURRENTLY OR IN THE
PAST UNDERGONE MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT. 22%
HAD A HISTORY OF ATTEMPTING
SUICIDE PRIOR TO THE FATAL
INCIDENTS. AND 20% HAD
DIAGNOSED THEIR THOUGHTS OR
PLANS TO DIE BY SWORD I SUICIDE
WITHIN A MONTH PRIOR TO THEIR
DEATH. 18% WERE KNOWN TO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE CURRENT OR
FORMER INTIMATE PARTNER.
SEVENTEEN HAD A PHYSICAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS. SIXTEEN OF DISSIDENTS
HAD SERVED IN THE US ARMED
FORCES. THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
REPORTS NATIONALLY FROM THE
SENATE FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
INCREASED IN AN INCREASES IN
ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS HAS MENTIONED ALSO
FIRE THEIR SPEAKERS AS SUCH
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EFFECTS. AND THE IMPACT OF THE
CALL WITH PANDEMIC ON SUICIDE
RATES IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER WE
DO NOT HAVE THE DATA THAT
DEFINITIVELY SHOWS AN INCREASE
IN SUICIDES DURING THE PANDEMIC
AT THIS POINT. IN TERMS OF THE
OVERDOSE STADIUM. CALIFORNIA'S
OPIOID OVERDOSE SURVEILLANCE
DASHBOARD CURRENTLY HAS DATA
AVAILABLE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
CDPH HAS ANALYZED TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY FATAL DRUG
RELATED OVERDOSE DATA THROUGH
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY I WILL
SURE THESE FINDINGS WITH YOU
TODAY KEEP IN MIND THEY ARE
LUMINARY IN NUMBERS ARE LIKELY
TO CHANGE. DATA ON OVERDOSE
SHOW THAT FEDERAL DRUG RELATED
OVERDOSES HAVE BEEN INCREASING
SINCE TWENTY- TWO THOUSAND SIX.
ELIMINATE DATA FROM TWENTY
TWENTY INDICATE THAT DRUG
RELATED OVERDOSES HAVE RAPIDLY
INCREASED FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY. FOR EXAMPLE
FROM JANUARY THROUGH AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY YOU SEEN FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHT
DRUG RELATED FATAL OVERDOSES.
THIS COMPARES TO FOUR THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
JOINT RELATED HATER OVERDOSES
FOR THE SAME PERIOD OF. TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT'S A 32% INCREASE.
IN PARTICULAR THERE HAD BEEN A
RAPID INCREASE IN FENTANYL
RELATED OVERDOSES. THERE WERE
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU KNOW
RELATED FATAL OVERDOSES
OCCURRING JANUARY THROUGH
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY.
COMPARED TO NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOR THE SAME PERIOD IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN. CENTER NOW
CONTRIBUTES TO MORE OPIOID
RELATED FATAL OVERDOSES IN
EITHER HERRON OR PRESCRIPTION
OPIATES EXCLUDING SYNTHETICS.
AND FENTANYL RELATED FATAL
OVERDOSES ARE ESPECIALLY
PREVALENT IN TO. GIVE ME YEAH
PREVALENT AMONG INDIVIDUALS
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF
AGE. PSYCHOSTIMULANT WITH THE
ABUSE OF POTENTIAL SUCH AS
METHAMPHETAMINE AND ECSTASY
REMAIN A CONCERN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. FROM JANUARY
THROUGH AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
PSYCHOSTIMULANT WITH ABUSE
POTENTIAL CONTRIBUTED TO. TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
FATAL OVERDOSES. UP 38% FROM
THE SAME PERIOD IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN SUMMARY THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS FOR SYNTHETIC OPIATES
EXCLUDING METHADONE IS HIGHER
THAN EXPECTED BASED ON PAST
WERE TELLING TWO TRENDS HOWEVER
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE CANNOT ATTRIBUTE THE
TWENTY TWENTY X. AXIS STEPS TO
ANYONE BECAUSE AT THIS POINT. I
WOULD NOW TRANSITION TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON- CITY KEEPS WORK
WITH SUICIDE PREVENTION THE CDC
GRANT. PUBLIC HEALTH RECOGNIZES
THAT SUICIDE IS PREVENTABLE
COMPLEX ISSUE AND CDPH IS
WORKING TO ADDRESS UNDERLYING
CAUSES TO KEEP SUICIDE FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
HISTORICALLY OUR ROLE HAS BEEN
ON SUICIDE SURVEILLANCE ND
EDUCATION UP UNTIL SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY CITY PH WAS
AWARDED A GRANT FROM THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
AND NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ANNUALLY OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD TO IMPLEMENT A SUICIDE
PREVENTION PROGRAM. PURPOSE OF
THE GRANT IS TO IMPLEMENT AND
EVALUATE. ADOPTION
IMPLEMENTATION OF SUICIDE. L.
C. PH TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND DATA TO THIRTEEN
COUNTIES WITH HIGH RATES OF
SUICIDE. TARGETING COMMUNITY
SUCH AS YOU VETERANS AN OLDER
ADULT MALES. THANK YOU FOR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT
MEETS SPECIFIC CRITERIA WILL BE
FUNDED TO IMPLEMENT THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES
PERTAINING TO REDUCING ACCESS
TO LETHAL MEANS EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT BRIEF INTERVENTIONS.
AND PROVIDING PARENTING SKILLS
FAMILY RELATIONSHIP PROGRAMS
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
PROGRAMS. THIS IS A FIVE YEAR
GRANT THAT BEGAN IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY AND ENDS AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE FOCUS
OF THIS YEAR'S GRANT. IS ON
PROGRAM EVALUATION PLANNING
DATA ANALYSIS IN TEACHING AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
IDENTIFYING THE FOR COUNTIES
THAT WILL BE FUNDED.
IMPLEMENTATION OF LOCAL
EVIDENCE BASED SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES WILL BE
JUNIOR AGAIN YOUR TO WHICH
STARTS THIS YEAR SEPTEMBER.
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
TERMS OF AB TWELVE AND TWENTY
ONE TWELVE- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS WAS SIGNED IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH ALLOW CITY PH TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE MENTAL HEALTH IN OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
IN ITS NEW STRATEGIC PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS. ESTABLISHING
AN OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
WILL ALLOW C. PH TO SERVE AS
THE DESIGNATED STATE ENTITY TO
IMPLEMENT THE FULL FIND ENERGY
VALUATION. CITY PH WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
AND ALIGNING STATE WHAT TO
SACRAMENTO EFFORTS AND
RESOURCES THROUGH PLANNING AND
COLLABORATION ACROSS THEY BURST
PARTNERS AND SYSTEMS AS NOTED.
BY OUR PREVIOUS SPEAKER. ONCE
KIDS TO A FIRST STEP IN X. ITS
SUICIDE PREVENTION WORK BY
APPLYING AND RECEIVING SUICIDE
PREVENTION GRANT FROM CDC. THE
GRANT ONLY HAS THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO A SMALL
NUMBER OF COUNTIES. THE CDC
GRANT WILL ALLOW C. PH TO
AMPLIFY THE STRATEGIES OUTLINED
IN THE SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN
AT THE ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITIES PROPOSED FOR
THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION ARE MORE SUBSTANTIAL
AND BEYOND THE SCOPE OF CDPH
NEW CDC GRANT. THE SUICIDE PLAN
ALLIANCES WHAT FRAMEWORK THAT
INCLUDES FOUR KEY STRATEGIES
AND TWELVE GOALS. IT REQUIRE
SHEPHERDING AND EVALUATING THE
SYSTEM APPROACH TO SUICIDE IT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT PREVENTION
SCREENING TREATMENT TREATMENT
IN THE PROVISIONS OF EQUITABLE
SERVICES ACROSS. THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE. MUCH MUCH BEYOND THE
SCOPE- THAT THE CDC GRANT
CURRENTLY HAPPENS. THE C. PH
WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION AS
ENVISIONED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. THE
DEPARTMENT VALUES THAT PERSON
TO BE INVOLVED IN TODAY'S
HEARING- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AT THIS POINT I CAN PASS
IT ALONG TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
HELLO I'M I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT A DOCTOR LIKE BORN WAS-
HAD TO PULL AWAY FOR AN URGENT
MATTER AND SO HE WILL NO LONGER
AFFORD TO HEARING IN SOUTH
BEACH AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ON BEHALF THE DEPARTMENT. ALL
IN LIGHT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IMMEDIATELY MOVED TO A LOOKS
YOU CRISIS COUNSELING PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE DONE IN PREVIOUS.
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
AT CAL HOPE IS THE CALIFORNIA
CRISIS COUNSELING PROGRAM
FUNDED BY FEMA EXAMS THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S SUBMITTED A VERY
AMBITIOUS PROPOSAL IN FACT ONE
OF THE LARGEST THEY'VE EVER
SEEN IF NOT THE LARGEST I'M AND
WAS FUNDED OVER SEVENTY MILLION
TO CREATE A ROBUST STATEWIDE
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO REACH ALL
OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH A VARIETY OF
COORDINATED STRATEGIES CRISIS
COUNSELING USES PEER LEVEL
INDIVIDUALS. TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE TO PEOPLE FEELING
STRESSED AND ANXIOUS FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND-
OTHER AS SOCIAL CHALLENGES. CAL
HOPE PROVIDES NO CLINICAL
SERVICES ANYONE NEEDING
CRITICAL CARE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES ARE REFERRED TO THE
COUNTY AND HEALTH PLAN DELIVERY
SYSTEMS. THE HELP OF THE CHALCO
PROGRAM IS SCHEDULED TO OPERATE
FROM NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THROUGH AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THOUGH WE DO ANTICIPATE
SAYS THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
HAS ANNOUNCED THEY WILL EXTEND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY TO
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BUT THERE MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
CONTINUE THE CALVET FUNDING
THROUGH THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. CAL HOPE HAS
THREE MAIN PROGRAMS MEDIA WEB
IN SUPPORT. ON THE MEDIA AND
WEB FRONT IT DELIVERS
EDUCATIONAL AND SUPPORTIVE
MESSAGING AND MANY LANGUAGES I
DESIGNED TO REACH COMMUNITIES
SUFFERING FROM THE PANDEMIC.
ONE OF OUR HIGHEST PROFILE
EFFORT WITH GETTING HELP HOPE
STICKERS ON THE LA KINGS HOCKEY
HELMETS. WITH HOCKEY PLAYERS
PROMOTING THE VALUE OF REACHING
OUT FOR HELP. ON THE SUPPORT
FRONT WE HAVE THE CAL HOPE WARM
WINE IS AVAILABLE FOR SOMEONE
NEEDING HELP AND COACHING
THROUGH A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
ONLINE HELLO HOPE HOPE SUPPORT
ALSO CONNECTS PEOPLE WITH YOUR
CRISIS COUNSELORS MATCHING
PEOPLE TO OTHER- SIMILAR
CULTURES AND LANGUAGES YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND AND SUPPORT THEIR
EXPERIENCE CRISIS COUNSELORS
MEET WITH INDIVIDUALS IN A
SERIES OF. VIDEO VISITS- AS
WELL AS CONNECTING THEM TO
CLINICAL CARE IF THEY NEED SO.
CAL HOPE STUDENTS SUPPORT- IS
THE LAST OF THE THREE PRONGS
AND A SUPPORT SECTOR AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CVS AND OTHERS SCHOOLS
INCLUDING TO HELP TEACHERS AND
STAFF. RECOGNIZE CHILDREN WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND CONNECT
CHILDREN TO SERVICES. CAL HOPE
IS OUR BIGGEST EFFORT TO
PREVENT SUICIDE CURRENTLY
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY YOU'RE HELPING PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH STRESS FEAR AND
THE LOSS- BY DE ESCALATING THE
SITUATION BUILDING HUMAN
CONNECTIONS AND CONNECTING THEM
WITH RESOURCES TO PREVENT THEM
FROM. SPIRALING INTO A CRISIS.
DO YOU SEE AS ALSO THAT ALSO
SUPPORT SUICIDE PREVENTION
SERVICES YOUR EXISTING FUNDING
SOURCES. YES HAS THE ONGOING
CONTRACT WITH DIDI HIRSCH TO
BE- APPROXIMATE THREE SORRY.
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE MHSAA. DO
SUPPORT THIRTEEN LIFE ALIGN
CENTERS. DCS ALSO PORT SUPPORTS
GENERAL PREVENTION EFFORTS
THROUGH ALLOCATING BLOCK- BLOCK
GRANTS FROM D. SANTA FUNDS TO
COUNTIES FOR PREVENTION WORK
MANY COUNTIES HAVE ALSO USED M.
HSA FUNDING TO SUPPORT CRISIS
HELP LINES AND SERVICES. LAST
DAC ASKING TO YOU OVER TO
MILLION DOLLARS OF CURRENT
STATE OPIOID RESPONSE FUNDING
TO ENSURE TREATMENT FOR OPIOID
INSTEAD STIMULANT ADDICTION AS
A PART OF THIS WORK DO YOU SEE
AS HAS MADE AVAILABLE OVER.
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND DOSES OF
NALOXONE LEADING TO OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND OVERDOSE REVERSALS WE
ARE AWARE OF THAT THE
DISTURBING TRENDS IN SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER IN OVERDOSE DEATHS
IN REMAIN MORE THAN COMMITTED.
THAN EVER TO GET ALL FEDERAL
FUNDING INCLUDING GRANT FUNDING
OUT QUICKLY TO OUR NETWORKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
GET TREATMENT EASIER OUT ON THE
STREETS THAN- THAN OTHER DRUGS-
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
<c.red>EALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION DR</c>
KELLY. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS AND I WILL BE
ANSWERING BOTH OF OUR QUESTIONS
BOTH QUESTIONS ONE INTO FOR
ADMISSIONS JOHN MYSELF WOULD
TO- START BY ACKNOWLEDGING. AT
THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST AS WORK AS WELL AS THE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION'S WORK IN THIS SPACE
AND DIRECTOR EWING. OVERALL AS
MISS MORALIS STATED
CALIFORNIA'S SUICIDE RATE IS
LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
AT TEN POINT SEVEN FOR ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
COMPARED WITH FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND NATIONALLY HOWEVER
THESE RATES ARE NOT CONSISTENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SOME
REGIONS OF OUR STATE HAVE
HIGHER RATES OF COMPLETED
SUICIDE THAN OTHERS. IN
PARTICULAR AND ARE RURAL AND
NORTHERN PARTS OF THE STATE.
THE COUNTY I'M SORRY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AS IN
CALIFORNIA AS PREVIOUSLY STATED
WHITE MEDIC COUNT FOR SEVEN IN
TEN DEATHS BY SUICIDE ALTHOUGH
MORE WOMEN AND YOUTH OF COLOR
ARE AT RISK OF ATTEMPTING DEATH
BY SUICIDE. EVERY CALIFORNIA
COUNTY IS REQUIRED UNDER TITLE
NINE REGULATIONS TO OPERATE A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CRISIS LINE
FOR ITS RESIDENTS AND THESE
CONTINUE TO BE A CRITICAL
ACCESS POINT. FOR INDIVIDUALS.
IN NEED GIVEN THE RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT THE FIRST PLACE A
PERSON WITH SUICIDAL IDEATION
WILL TURN TO AS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER. HOWEVER SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT CALIFORNIA SUICIDE
PREVENTION EFFORTS HAVE LARGELY
BEEN DRIVEN BY COUNTIES AND I
JUST A FUNDED INITIATIVES. FIND
THE PASSAGE ABOUT ME JUST A IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FUR. COUNTIES
MADE SUICIDE PREVENTION ONE OF
OUR MAIN STRATEGIC INITIATIVES
AND OLLECTIVELY INVESTED. A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF AND JUST
A DOLLARS INTO STRATEGIC
INITIATIVE TO ENHANCE THE
OVERALL STATEWIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AND WE DID THAT
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF COMMENTS
I WHICH IS THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY. SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINES PREVENT
SUICIDE BY ENSURING THE
IMMEDIATE SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT BE AT RISK OF SUICIDE
AND LINKING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
TO SERVICES. AS IS COOPER JUST
STATED FUND SUPPORTING SPONSORS
HAVE SUPPORTED EXISTING HOTLINE
SUCH AS DIDI HIRSCH WHICH
SERVES THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION AND TRANSITIONS MENTAL
HEALTH. AS WELL AS THEY HAVE
GONE TOWARDS EXPANDING LANGUAGE
OPTIONS. EXPANDED HOURS OF
OPERATIONS AN ACCESS MODE SUCH
JUST TEXT AND CHAT AS WELL AS
TARGETED OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS. I
LIKE TO NOTE THAT FOR DIDI
HIRSCH WHICH IS THE PROVIDER
FOR SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY. IN
TWENTY TWENTY. FEBRUARY OUR
AVERAGE CALLS TO DIDI HIRSCH
WORK TWENTY ONE. IN MARCH WHEN
CO THAT STARTED. OUR CALLS WENT
UP TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND THEN
IN APRIL THEY INCREASE TO THREE
THOUSAND AND THEY REMAIN ABOUT
THAT NOW. BUT WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT. FEBRUARY
THOSE CALLS WERE ALL SUICIDE.
PREVENTION MARCH AND APRIL AND
THROUGHOUT THE PAST YEAR
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON
KOPET HELPING PEOPLE GET HOOKED
UP WITH FOOD BANKS THEY'VE BEEN
MORE OF A RESOURCE THAN THEY
HAVE. FOR THE ENTIRE POPULATION-
TODAY COME A SECOND TO SUPPORT
STATEWIDE SUICIDE PREVENTION
EFFORTS FUNDED BY COUNTY SUCH
AS EACH MIND MATTERS.
FUNDAMENTAL WHICH IS OUR
SPANISH LANGUAGE CAMPAIGN OF
EACH ROUND MIND MATTERS AND
KNOW THE SIGNS SOCIAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS COMING SUPPORTS
COUNTIES IN INTEGRATING THE
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGNS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH. A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
RESOURCE NAVIGATION IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PAY PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
EQUITY ISSUES AND ENSURING THAT
WE ARE ADDRESSING SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE TO THE PEOPLE WE ARE
PROVIDING IT TO. THEM I JUST
SAY ALSO FINDS ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE SUICIDE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE THREE CRISIS
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. COUNTY IS
ALSO OPERATE WARM LINE'S MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES AND SERVICE THE
BACK END ON SUICIDE PREVENTION
LINES. OF THESE SERVICES-
THEY'RE AVAILABLE COUNTY WIDE
WITH NO. COST TO THE PERSON
WHO'S RECEIVING THE SERVICES
THAT WE ARE NOT BILLING DOESN'T
MATTER YOU HAVE KAISER IF YOU
HAVE MEDIC CALORIE OF NO
INSURANCE. AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
SAY FUNDS COUNTIES ARE ALSO
FUNDING A BRAVE TRAININGS FOR
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS
SCHOOLS ARE EMPLOYERS AND
COMMUNITY OTHER COMMUNITY
PARTNERS SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
FOR STATE. ASSIST AS WELL AS
QUESTION PERCENT PERSUADE AND
REFER TRAININGS- ST ARE COUNTY
THE ASSIST TRAINING. HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO LAY
PEOPLE. AND OUR VETERANS SYSTEM
OF CARE MANY VETERANS ARE
HESITANT TO REACH OUT TO THE
CURRENT VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
TO ADDRESS THEIR SUICIDALITY
AND THEY'RE ALSO HAS A CHANCE
TO REACH OUT. THROUGH NINE ONE
ONE SO ASSIST HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN REDUCING OUR NUMBERS
OF COMPLETED SUICIDES. PER THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING- WE HAVE
DATA WE HAVE AN OFFICE WE WANT
TO SHARE THAT THE DATA AND OUR
BEST PRACTICES BECAUSE SUICIDE
PREVENTION IS NOT SIMPLY
ADDRESSED WITH A CRISIS LINE OR
A HOTLINE. YEAH WE NEED TO
REDUCE STIGMA TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO NEEDED SERVICES
FOCUSING ON MAKING MENTAL
HEALTH. THE FOCUS BECAUSE WE
ALL HAVE MENTAL HEALTH. WITH
RESPECT TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER IN TREATMENT IN
PARTICULAR OVERDOSE PREVENTION
EACH COUNTY ALSO HAS A
SUBSTANCE USE PREVENTION FIVE
YEAR PLAN WITH MEASURABLE GOALS
TIED TO ARE COUNTY SPECIFIC
DATA PREVENTION PLANS ARE
GROUNDED IN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW BECAUSE PREVENTING
ADDICTION FOR USE IS VERY
DIFFERENT PROCESS THAN FOR IT
UP ALL SO WE ARE REALLY FOCUSED
ON STRATEGIES THAT TEND TO
YOUTH VERSUS THOSE WHO ARE FOR
ADULTS DIFFERENT BANKS- SO
COUNTIES AT THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE DONE A LOT TO
KEEP OUTPATIENT SERVICES
AVAILABLE VIA TELEHEALTH OR
EVEN IN PERSON BUT ACCESS TO
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES AND
RECOVERY RESIDENTS FORCED OR
SOBER LIVING ENVIRONMENTS HAS
BEEN CHALLENGING DURING COLD
BECAUSE OF THIS THE THINGS THAT
WE MENTIONED IN OUR FIRST
PANEL. FOR EXAMPLE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO ADAPT
EXISTING FACILITIES OR EXPAND
INTO NEW ONES AND ALTHOUGH
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL AND
UNNECESSARY MODEL STEP DOWNS
RECOVERY RESIDENCES OR SOAKS UP
LIVING ENVIRONMENTS- CANNOT BE
FUNDED THROUGH MEDICARE. WE
KNOW THE RISK OF OVERDOSE
RELATED DEATHS IS
OVERWHELMINGLY HIGH FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BEING
RELEASED FROM INCARCERATION AND
WE BELIEVE CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT CDC ARE
REGARDING PRISON RELEASE
POPULATIONS IS KEY. CDCR
REPORTED THAT IT OFFERS
NALOXONE OR NOR CAN I TO
INMATES UPON DISCHARGE IN UP
280% OF INMATES RECEIVED THAT
THAT THAT MEDICATION WHICH
INDICATES A REAL NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE PROVIDES
COUNTIES WITH ADEQUATE
NOTIFICATION IN COORDINATION
AROUND PRISON JUST CHARGES.
OVERALL COMMUNITY BASED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PREVENTION IS CURRENTLY FUNDED
VERY MINIMALLY I WITH OUR SAM'S
A BLOCK GRANT BUT THOSE FUNDS
MUST COMPETE WITH OTHER BLACK
GRANT SERVICES SUCH AS RECOVERY
RESIDENTS SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
THINGS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
COVERED UNDER DRUG HOW. MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT DEDICATED
INVESTMENT WILL NEED TO BE MADE
IN OPIOID OVERDOSE PREVENTION-
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AS A SOME OF OUR
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE STATED
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT HEROIN
OR OPIOIDS WE ARE SEEING
FENTANYL WHICH IS AN OPIOID-
ADULTERATED COCAINE AND
METHAMPHETAMINE RESULTING AND A
DIFFERENT KIND OF AN OVERDOSE.
AND THAT MIGHT NOT BE AS EASILY
TRACKED FOR THE CDPH DASHBOARD.
AS MISS MORALIS STATED. IS MORE
ON- SO WE NEED TO REALLY FOCUS
ON ON OVERDOSE PREVENTION
MOVING IT SO THAT IT'S MORE ON
PAR WITH THE TYPE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING COUNTIES
RECEIVE THROUGH AN HSA EVER
REALLY GOING TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT ADDICTION. THE THREAT OF
FENNEL AGAIN IS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING OVERDOSES AMONG OUR
YOUNGER POPULATION TO MAKE
LATIN ME LACK AWARENESS ABOUT.
OF THE AT RISK OF OVERDOSES
UNDER MEDI CAL ARE DRUG MEDI
CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEM
ALLOWS FOR THE REIMBURSEMENT OF
RESIDENTIAL DRUG TREATMENT
WHICH WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE
FUNGIBLE UNDER THE I AM D.
EXCLUSION. AND EXCHANGE FOR
INCREASED COMMUNITY BASED AND
OUTPATIENT SERVICES AND SO
WHILE THE DRUG MEDI CAL
ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEM WAS
GROUNDBREAKING. NATIONALLY IT
REFORMED OUR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT AND
MEDICAID. IT WAS IMPLEMENTED ON
A VOLUNTARY BASIS AND THERE ARE
MANY COUNTIES HAVE YET TO
IMPLEMENT THEY'RE NOT HOLDING
OFF BECAUSE THEY DON'T SEE THE
BENEFITS TO MAKE THE SWITCH. IT
REALLY IS ABOUT A KANEMI OF
SCALE. IT IS ABOUT NOT HAVING
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO ESTABLISH
NEW SERVICES AND THE ABILITY TO
ABSORB THE DEPENDENT DEMAND FOR
SERVICES. IN ADDITION TO MORE
TARGETED INVESTMENT OF S. U. D.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE STATE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO TARGET
SCHOOLS FOR BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT. I COUNTY SPECIAL
EXPERTISE AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT AND HOLISTIC
FAMILY COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAKE
US IDEAL PARTNERS FOR EXPANDED
SCHOOL BASED PARTNERSHIPS
MOVING FORWARD. AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO KNOW IS THAT
RECOVERY HAPPENS. THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CABRERA. NOT SURE OF
YOUR COMMENT OR INCLUDED IN DR
KELLY'S OR IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE WHERE. GROUT ALL
HOLD OPERATIVE FUN THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I WILL PULL IT BACK
UP TO THE DíAS TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS AND- FIRST I WANT TO
ACTUALLY THANK AND APPRECIATE
THE HARD WORK THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION IS
DOING ON WORKING ON DEVELOPING
A STATEWIDE. SUICIDE PREVENTION
STRATEGIC PLAN AND WANTED TO-
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY IF YOU
COULD AFTER HAVING HEARD FROM
DH CS AND CDPH ABOUT THEIR
SUICIDE PREVENTION WORK AND
FIGURING OUT HOW WE COULD
CREATE A COORDINATED RESPONSE-
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. HAPPY TO THANK
YOU- THANK ARAMBULA- YOU KNOW I
THINK WHAT I HAVE HEARD TODAY
AND WHAT WE'VE HEARD OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. IS THAT B.
YOU KNW BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- THE
COMMISSION THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. YOU KNOW WE
WOULD INCLUDE IN THAT
DISCUSSION THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- YOU KNOW MANY OF OUR-
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SERVING-
EDMONTON PARENTING. FAMILIES
YEAH EVEN FIRST FIVE RIGHT BUT
ALSO ON THE LOCAL SIDE ARE
COUNTIES OUR SCHOOLS- WE HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES IN CALIFORNIA TO
FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESS SUICIDE
RISKS AND RATES AND BRING THAT
DOWN. M. THE CAPUCHINS
RECOMMENDATION TO CREATE THE
OFFICES HAVE PREVENTION IS
REALLY ABOUT BRINGING TOGETHER.
THE TOOLS THE PARTNERS THE
STRATEGIES AND THE LEADERSHIP
IT'S THIS FUNDAMENTAL
LEADERSHIP ROLE OF NOT TAKING
OVER WHAT'S HAPPENING BUT
COORDINATING SUPPORTING
EMBRACING THE STRAIN THAT AS
DIRECTOR KELLY TALKED ABOUT. IS
IN PLACE IN MANY IF NOT ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. IT'S THIS
MUSICIANS OF INTERSECTION ALITY
BETWEEN EDUCATION MENTAL HEALTH
LAW ENFORCEMENT HOSPITALS- M.
IT'S THESE AREAS WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO. THE STATE IS TRYING
TO SUPPORT PRACTICES AND
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES IN
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT DICTATING
ARE MANDATING HOW THEY DO IT
BUT THROUGH A FACILITATION AND
CAPACITY BUILDING STRATEGY THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT IN CONCERT WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. WE WERE
INVOLVED WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE CALVET PROPOSAL. AND I
HAD THE FORTUNE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH THE REGION AT NINE
ADMINISTRATOR WITH FEEDBACK.
ABOUT THE STATE'S APPLICATION
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT OUR
OUR DISASTER PREPAREDNESS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS NOT AS
ROBUST. AS ARE PREPARED AS IN
OTHER AREAS FIRE SUPPRESSION-
EVACUATIONS RIGHT WE HAVE DONE
WE ARE BETTER PREPARED IN SOME
OF THESE OTHER AREAS THEN WE
ARE IN THE BEER HALL SPACE. AND
I WOULD AG ADD THAT THAT
INCLUDES SUICIDE PREVENTION
WORK AND SO I THINK FOR ME THE
TAKE AWAY IS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS THE RESOURCES AND THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE EXPERTISE
AND THE TOOLS. TO FUNDAMENTALLY.
ADDRESS THE RISKS THAT WE FACE
WHEN IT COMES TO SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND ACTUALLY GET TO
THIS NOTION OF ZERO- WITH THE
RIGHT KIND OF COORDINATION AND
ENGAGEMENT. AND THAT'S THE
PIECE THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
MISSING I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
ANSWER IS TO. ARM YOU KNOW
CONSOLIDATE THESE STRATEGIES
BECAUSE THERE ARE REASONS WHY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS DOING WHAT IT'S
DOING AND WE NEED TO LEVERAGE
THE STRENGTHS OF EACH OF THESE
PARTNERS. AND BLEND THEM IN
WAYS THAT ARE IMPACTFUL ACROSS
WHAT IS AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
AND COMPLICATED STATE- YOU KNOW
AND I AND I WOULD YOU KNOW LOOK
NO FARTHER THAN. THE NEEDS OF
OUR IN OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
AND THE DIFFICULTY THAT WE
OFTEN FIND. CONNECTING TRIBAL
SERVICES WITH FEDERAL SERVICE
SINCE COUNTY BASED SERVICE AND
STATE SERVICE SINCE- THIS IS
VERY COMPLICATED WORK THAT IF
WE REALLY CAN BRING TOGETHER
THE VOICES AND THE VISION OF
ALL OF THESE PARTNERS WE CAN
MAKE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON YOUR
BUSINESS JUST AYE PREVENTION
AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT THAT
COLBERT HAS MADE MENTAL HEALTH.
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF MOST OF
US IF NOT ALL OF US UNDERSTAND
THEIR WE HAVE SEEN DRAMATIC
REDUCTIONS IN STIGMA DRAMATIC
INCOME ENHANCEMENTS OF PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY MENTAL
HEALTH MATTERS ALL OF OUR WORK
WITH EMPLOYERS WITH EDUCATORS-
WITH WHAT YOU KNOW WE OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS NONTRADITIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS. WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ENGAGED IN MENTAL HEALTH
THEY'RE RECEPTIVE ATTY TO THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY IS
TREMENDOUSLY GREATER THAN IT
WAS PRE PANDEMIC. IT'S
INCUMBENT ON CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS BUT THE
LEADERSHIP IN PLACE AND REALLY
WORK ACROSS THE MANY STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES INCLUDING SOME
OF OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. TO
DEPLOYED A STRATEGY THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IN WAYS THAT WE CAN
GET TO ZERO. THANK YOU TO OPT
IS YOUR QUESTION NO IT DOES
AND- I THINK WE'VE HEARD DR
GOLLY SAY THAT COULD BE
NINETEEN SHOULD BE AN EXCEL
AROUND FOR MUCH CHANGE AND
REALLY WOULD. HOPE THAT DURING
THIS PANDEMIC WE CAN SEE. THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITHIN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SUICIDES
IN TERMS OF OUR DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND THE REAL NEED
FOR US TO HAVE. COLLABORATION
AND SO IF I COULD I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK A POINTED QUESTION FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT IT.
REALLY IS BASED ON THE FACT
THAT SUICIDES AND- OVERDOSE
DEATHS ARE DEATHS OF DESPAIR.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT I REALLY
FEEL THAT IT BEGGING FOR REAL
STRONG LEADERSHIP. IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL AND I'M HPING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DESCRIBE HOW
IT PLANS TO PROVIDE INCREASED
COORDINATION AND POWERFUL
LEADERSHIP IN GENERAL ON THESE
ISSUES. THE QUESTION IS FOR
EITHER DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES OR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. OUR
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WAS
GOING TO RESPOND. WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS- THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES IS FULLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS- AND AREAS IN THE
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
LEVERAGING ALL SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED IN ORDER TO REDUCE
SUICIDES. AND GET ZERO I JUST
TO BE CLEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARE VERY
COMMITTED TO THAT EFFORT. YEAH
I WOULDN'T AT. THANK YOU YEAH
THIS IS MONICA MORALES FOR THE
RECORD I DEFINITELY ECHO ON THE
SPEAKERS WE'VE BEEN TRACKING
THIS YOU KNOW FOR QUITE SOME
TIME WE HAVEN'T HAD OBVIOUSLY
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE'VE WAITED A
PRIORITY IN TERMS OF OUR
SURVEILLANCE- IN TERMS OF THEIR
REPORTING THAT WE TRYING TO DO
TO REALLY AT LEAST BRING THE
AWARENESS UP OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE'VE ORGANIZED
INTERNALLY IN OUR DEPARTMENT
ACROSS PROGRAMS. AND FOR US
IT'S A HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
APPROACH AS A WHOLE BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW MENTAL HEALTH YOU ALSO
HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
RISK FACTORS SUCH AS HOW TO
BACK WHO PLAYS A ROLE WE NEED
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT HOW THIS
IMPACTS CHRONIC DISEASES AND SO
THESE ARE THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKING CE
DEPARTMENT BUT IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO HAVE THE BACKBONE
AT THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE.
PREVENTION PLAN IS OUTLINING IN
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
ONE ON ONES WITH A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT SISTER DEPARTMENTS
WORKING OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
COMMISSION AS WELL WHEN NEEDED-
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD AS A THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE STATED
TO REALLY MAKE AN INTENTIONAL
ALIGNMENT ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS AND IN PROVIDING A-STRONG STRONG LEADERSHIP ROLE
TO REALLY GET THIS GOING IT'S
NOT FOR THE LACK OF WORK THAT'S
TAKING PLCE. THEY DIDN'T
EMBRACE IN THAT VISION THAT THE
PREVENTION PLAN HAS AND PUTTING
THE RESOURCES IN THE LEADERSHIP.
IN PLACE TO KIND OF MOVE THAT
FORWARD. I FEEL ALL. TO UPLIFT
MY- CALL IN SEEK MATES UP. FOR
THE OFFICE OF. SUICIDE
PREVENTION AS WELL AS- BE QUITE
GRATEFUL FOR THEADMINISTRATION
AND SECURING THE CAL HOPE-
GRANT FROM FEMA AND SAM SO I
HAVE BEEN A- BIG SUPPORTER OF
PEER LEVEL- INDIVIDUALS AND
BELIEVE THIS IS A GREAT STEP.
FORWARD FOR US AS A STATE. WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK VERY
MUCH THE PANEL THREE AND MOVE
ON TO PANEL FOR ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND PROPOSALS
SPECIFIC TO HIGH NEED
POPULATIONS. WE HAVE EIGHT
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL AND
WILL HOLD ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS
UNTIL AFTER THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED. IF WE CAN PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD EVENING I'M
STEPPING CLENDENIN DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AND I'M JOINED BY
CHRIS EATON SAYS DEBBIE
DIRECTOR OF OUR FRIENDS LIKE
SERVICES DIVISIONS. WHEN ASKED
TO DISCUSS TWO ITEMS THAT
COMMUNITY CARE COLLABORATIVE
PILOT PROJECT AND THE I. S. T.
DIVERSION UPDATES US ALL. BOTH
OF THESE ARE RELATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS HAVE BEEN FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES. AND BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND THE DEPARTMENT.
CONTINUED TO EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
YOU ARE PENDING ADMISSION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WHICH OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS IN RESPONSE
TO THE INCREASING ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT ACTIVATED CAPACITY
IN ITS STATE HOSPITALS.
PARTNERED WITH THE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S TO ESTABLISH JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS IN CONTACTED WITH LOS
ANGELES TRYING TO PROVIDE
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAMS. EACH OF THESE EFFORTS
HAS BEEN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASING REFERRALS TO THE
DEPARTMENT HOWEVER DESPITE ALL
THE EFFORTS THE REFERRALS HAVE
CONTINUED TO. GROW AND EXCEED
CAPACITY. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL THAT
WERE PENDING PLACEMENT TO
IDIOCY TREATMENT PROUD HUBBARD.
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED SINCE THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN THIS
NUMBER GROW SIGNIFICANTLY DUE
TO THE PROTECTIVE MEASURES THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED IN RESPONSE TO
CURB. SO IN NINETEEN THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE AGENDA
SH TODAY THE WAIT LIST IS
NEARING SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
PATIENTS. AS A RESULT OF THIS
WAY UNLESS THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE
INCREASING PRESSURE TO TIMELY
AMEND I S. T. DEPENDENCE FOR
TREATMENT. EVERY YEAR OVER THE
YEARS THE DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT
HAS CONDUCTED AN ANALYSIS OF
THE I. S. T. POPULATION TREATED
IN THAT SYSTEM AND THROUGH THIS
ANALYSIS WE HAVE FOUND. THE
MAJORITY OF INDIVIDUALS AND
MELTED I WASN'T TALKING TO
STAND TRIAL HAVE NOT RECEIVED
SUFFICIENT MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PRIOR TO THEIR ADMISSION. INNER
CYCLING IN AND OUT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
APPROXIMATELY 50% HAVE NOT
ACCESS COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT IN THE SIX MONTHS
PRIOR TO THEIR ARREST. IN 45%
HAVE HAD FIFTEEN OR MORE REST
BEFORE THEY'RE COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
SH ADDITIONALLY NEARLY ONE HALF
WERE UNSHELTERED. HOMELESS AT
THE TIME OF THEIR ARRESTS. THIS
YEAR THE PART AS PER. TO
ESTABLISH THE COMMUTER CARE.
PROJECT COMPETENT TO STAND.
TRIAL WE ARE REQUESTING TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND WORK POSITIONS AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION I'M GOING FOR THIS
EFFORT STE UNDER THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WITH A
CONTRACT WITH COUNTIES TO
ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
CARE AND TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES. AND THROUGH
THIS DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WE
SEEK TO PROMOTE A COMMUNITY
BASED CONTINUUM OF CARE OR
FELONY EYES TWO DEFENDANTS IN
THE STATE. THAT SUPPORTS THE
PRINCIPLES OF DE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION FOR THESE
DEFENDANTS WE CAN BEST BE CARED
FOR IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
SETTING IN THE COMMUNITY. WHILE
RECOGNIZING THAT DEFENDANTS
WITH CERTAIN VIOLENT CHARGES
MAY NEED TO BE TREATED IN
SECURE FACILITIES INCLUDING
JAIL TREATMENT FACILITIES. AND
STAFF THE STATE HOSPITALS. WE
ALSO SEEK TO DEMONSTRATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS WITH STREAMLINED
RESPONSIBILITY AND ALIGNED
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL FOR THIS
POPULATION TO DRIVE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES. AND REDUCED
INCARCERATION RECIDIVISM
RECIDIVISM AND HOMELESSNESS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. SH WE ARE.
STATE TIMELY. OF COMPETENCY AS-
FAR IS TWO DEFENDANTS. WITH
RESPECT TO THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROPOSAL ON THE I. S. T.
WAITING LIST AND WHEN THE
IMPACTS OF THE PROPOSAL WILL
REALLY BE DEPENDENT UPON WHICH
COUNTIES PARTICIPATE AND THE
NUMBER OF ID I JUST USED TO BE
SERVED BY THE COUNTIES AT THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING REQUEST IN THE
NUMBER I S. T. IS THAT COULD BE
SERVED BY THE FUNDING AND THE
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE WAIT
LIST NEXT FISCAL YEAR. HOWEVER
UNTIL WE KNOW WHICH COUNTIES
WILL PARTICIPATE IN THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF HIGHEST USED TO BE
SERVED BY THE COUNTIES AND HOW
QUICKLY THE COUNTIES CAN BEGIN
SERVING THE HIGHEST USE IT WILL
BE DIFFICULT TO ASSESS WHAT
THAT. ACTUAL IMPACTS COULD BE.
SH IN ADDITION TO THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WE ARE
ALSO REQUESTING ONE TIME
FUNDING OF FORTY SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION IN GENERAL FUND IN
BUDGET YEAR. AND ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FOUR YEARS
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TO EXPAND. OUR
EXISTING I. S. T. DIVERSION
PROGRAM. THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED ONE TIME
HUNDRED MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH THE I. S.
T. DIVERSION PROGRAM. THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
CONTRACTS WITH CHINESE TO
DEVELOP NEW OR EXPAND EXISTING
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEEN FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL OR
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE COUNTY
COMPANY. STAND TRIAL ON FELONY
CHARGES SH I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO DEBBIE DIRECTOR
PROCEEDINGS WILL PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL. DETAILS ABOUT BUT
THESE PROPOSALS AND HIGHLIGHTS
ON OUR EFFORTS TO DATE IN
IMPLEMENTING IS TO DIVERSION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME'S CHRIS DANCING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR PROGRAMS LIKE SERVICE
SENSE. THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
DETAILS OF THE MOVIE CARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT. I S.
CHEESE LIKE TO CALL THE CCGT.
BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO START OFF
BY ACKNOWLEDGING- A WHILE NOT
TO THE SAME SCALE CRISES
EXPERIENCED BY THE PANDEMIC
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING ANOTHER TYPE OF
CRISIS AND NOT THROUGH THE
INCREASING CRIMINALIZATION OF
THOSE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS-
THE IMPACT OF THIS CRISIS IS
DIRECTLY CORRELATED TO THE
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE RATE
OF THOSE BEING ARRESTED AND
COMMITTED AS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. AND STEPHANIE
NOTED OVER THE YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS INCREASED ITS
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF AYE ISSUES
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT'S OVER NINE HUNDRED BAD
BETWEEN OUR STATE HOSPITALS IN
JBC CHEAPER GROUNDS AND MORE
RECENTLY STARTED TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR COUNCILS.
INCLUDING DIVERSION AND A
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAM THE CCP PROPOSAL IS THE
NEXT STEP IN THIS PASS AND
EVOLUTION OF LESSONS. LEARNED
FROM THESE PARTNERSHIPS. HI
STEPHANIE MENSCH WE'RE PER IN.
OF TWO ONE THIRTY THREE POINT
TWO AND YEAR IN A HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING. SOME OF THE KEY
FEATURES OF THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDE ONE ON GOING FUNDING
WHICH ARE DEVELOPMENT A RISK-
OF BUILDING OUT NEW PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES. ONE TIME FUNDS TO
SUPPORT PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS BY
CURTIS. LITTLE TOWN NEEDS. ARE
AND THREE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH THE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT NOW WILL BE
APPLIED IF IDEAS H. AS. WELL AS
OUR CONTRACTED EXPERTS. SO THIS
REALLY IS A WHOLE LIST FUNDING.
THAT PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
TREATMENT SERVICES HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION WHICH OFTEN
REPRESENTS THE HIGHEST MORE
USERS IN THE SYSTEM- AND AS
WELL AS THE STAFF- CERTAINS
INDIVIDUALS- OUR VISION FOR
THIS DEMONSTRATION PROJECT IS
OUR PARTICIPATING CHANNELS TO
PROVIDE A CONTINUUM OF SERVICES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WHICH CAN
INCLUDE BOTH WALKED IN AND
WALKED TREATMENT SETTINGS
EVERYTHING FROM JAIL BASED
COMPETENCY TREATMENT TO ONE
LAKH RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS.
EVERYTHING BETWEEN. IN ADDITION
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO DSHS
FOR THOSE. WHO BEHIND US THE
WHOLE CARE. I THINK I SHOULD
JUST TAKE A- TO SAVE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT COMPANIES NOW
WE'RE TALKING WITH DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO EVERY LEVEL
OF CARE READILY AVAILABLE IN
TIME FOR A JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IMAGINATION. SO WITHOUT WE
FULLY EXPECT THAT THE CONTINUUM
OF SERVICES UTILIZED IN THE
FIRST AND SECOND YEAR OF THE
PROGRAM MAY LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT. THEN IT WILL BE IN
FUTURE YEARS PARTICULARLY AS
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
BANKING OF A WHOLE COUNTRY
WALMART EIGHT. WHAT TO THIS IS
A DUMB. PROJECT BECAUSE- ONE
THERE'S A LIMITED NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT WILL PARTICIPATE
AND SHE WERE PROPOSING AN
INITIAL THREE YEAR
DEMONSTRATION HEARING AID WHICH
WILL RUN THROUGH THE SCHOOL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS THE PERIOD IN WHICH
WILL COLLECT OUT COMING FISCAL
DATA FROM THE COUNTIES TO.
ROUTE ONE EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF STREAMLINING
RESPONSIBILITY TO DRIVE
IMPROVED OUTCOMES IS DEFINITELY
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL AS TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE FUNDING
WORK OPPOSING. WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING ON FUNDING REALLY
BECAUSE THE COUNTIES THAT ELECT
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROJECT
WILL BE ASSUMING FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
RESTORATION OF THE COLONY I
ASKED YOU POPULATION IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND- AND- IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE INVESTMENT
MADE IN THIS SPACE WILL BE
ONGOING AS WELL. I'M SO JUST TO
KIND OF RUN THROUGH THE DETAILS
OF THE FUNDING PROPOSED IN THIS
PROJECT- AS MENTIONED WE'RE
PROPOSING IS ONGOING BASS LINE
OF FUNDING FOR JUSTIN COUNTIES
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
INVESTMENT. FOR THE BASELINE
FUNDING THIS IS WHAT WE CALL
OUR EVENING WALK OR ANYTHING
THAT WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
TRANSFER TREATMENT HOUSING AND
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES. WE
DEVELOP THIS FUNDING ESTIMATE
BASED ON A PROJECTED TOTAL
ANNUAL POPULATION- OR TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CHU I. S.
JEANS. WHICH IS REALLY BASED ON
A THREE YEAR AVERAGE ACTUAL AYE
ISSUE REFERRALS THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS RECEIVED- FROM A
SAMPLING OF LARGE MEDIUM AND.
SMALL SIZED TOWNS. CONSISTENT
WITH METHOD OF PSH ASKED TO AND
HOW. TOTAL EACH. HOW BASED ON
THEIR ACT THREE AB TRYING.
ALAMEDA APPLIED THIS AS TO HOW.
LEVEL TO A PROPOSED RATE
ALLOCATION OF 1-008-000-3405
FOR EACH PATIENT THIS RATE IS
EQUIVALENT TO THE AVERAGE AND
WILL COST YOU TREATING ISTEP.
SHANE IN THE STATE HOSPITAL
BACK- WE PROPOSE THAT THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE TO COUNCIL
MEMBER ALLOCATION PROCESS. IN
ADDITION TO OUR ON GOING
FUNDING ON THE FIRST YEARWILL
ALSO INCLUDE ONE TIME FUNDING-
WERE DECIMATED FORTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO REMAINS ON THE
PSH WAIT LIST AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
IS NOT THAT IT NEEDED TO BE A
SIEGE PROGRAM. THAT IN ADDITION
UP TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS- WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE WHICH CAN THEN
BE USED TO SUPPORT ALL PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS THAT
INCLUDES. ON START UP COSTS
RELATED TO RECRUITMENT HIRING
TRAINING AND STAFF AS WELL AS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL DIRECTLY SUPPORT- COUNTY I
ASKED YOU POPULATION. IN
ADDITION WE WOULD PROPOSE TO
TRANSFER ANY FINDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO COUNTIES. OTHER
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS ARE SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE ARE ANY
CHINESE- WHO ARE CURRENTLY
CONTRACTING WITH. US ARE FOR
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM WE WERE
JUST SUPPOSED TO TRANSFER ALL
THOSE FANS- IN ONE FELL SWOOP.
TODAY COUNTY- TO ALLOW FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN MUSICALS. ONE
OTHER PROPOSAL HIGHLIGHTS. AND
AS I NOTED EARLIER COUNTIES
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO DSHS FOR
IRIS RESTORATION TREATMENT-
NEED WOULD PROPOSE TO DO THIS
REAL ESTABLISHING AN ALLOCATION
OF BAD DAYS FOR HER TO
SCREENING HOW HIS ARM AND- ARE
ALSO PROPOSING THAT COMES WITH
YES OUR PREMIUM RATE STARTING
AT A HUNDRED AND 50% ARE
CURRENTLY BAD RATE AND THEN
SHARED RATE. STRUCTURE WITH
CRIMINAL INCREASES AND THAT
RATES WILL BE APPLIED FOR ANY
BAD DAYS AND ACCESS ACCOUNT. OF
EACH AND- IN ADDITION COUNTY.
EIGHT WITH WILL BE REQUIRED TO
TREATMENT PLANS MAKES GOING
REPORTS ON BASIS AND ON
AFFORDABLE BASIS SENATE
DEMOGRAPHIC AS WELL AS
TREATMENT DATA BANKS ARE. I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE-
THE PLAN TO EVALUATE THE NEED
TO REASSESS THE BASELINE
FUNDING AMOUNT FOR COUNTIES
BASED ON UPON ANY CHANGES TO
THE OVERALL GROWTH IN COUNTY
POPULATION THAT MAY DRIVE YOU
CRAZY. HM AS WELL AS ANY COSTA
FACTOR THAT NEED. INCREASE
OUTSIDE THE TERMS CONTROL. NEC
AT NAY SHE IS FROM THE WILL PER
IN THE IN THE LEVEL WILL REMAIN
WITH THE- BUT MUST BE WITHIN.
IN ANY- INTERVENTIONS OR
EXTREME SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF I. S. G. INDIVIDUALS
DECLARED HIGHEST G. WE ARE NOT.
TO DO THE BASE LEVEL OF. AND AS
PART OF THAT REINVESTMENT OF
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE S. H.
THEIR PLANS WITHOUT
REINVESTMENT. WITH RESPECT TO
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES ARE
STILL TO BE DETERMINED. IDEAS
EACH HAS- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER DEVELOP THEIR FUNDING
ASSUMPTIONS BASED UPON MODEL OF
SEVERAL DIFFERENT COUNTIES OF
BEARINGS SIZES AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN- DISCUSSIONS WITH
INTERESTED COUNTY SEVERAL
COUNCILS. I WILL PROVIDE
UPDATES AND THEN IT WOULD BE
CHEN REGARDING WHO- THIS IS
PART OF THE PROJECT. I WAS
THERE AND SHIFT OVER TO THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM I. SAW START
OFF FIRST BY PROVIDING AN
UPDATE ON THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
THEN WILL MOVE INTO OUR NEW
SPENDING LAST. TO RECAP DCH WAS
AUTHORIZED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. I AM TARGETS NICHOLS
WHO ARE HERE FOUND I. S. T. OR
LIKELY TO BE FOUND I S. T. Y.
CHARGE AND ADOLESCENT OTHERS.
CRITERIA FOR ELIGIBILITY. OF
THE NINE OF THE WILL HUNDRED
MILLION NINETY NINE FIVE
MILLION WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO
FIND COUNTY SPECIFIC NINETY ONE
MILLION WAS EARMARKED FOR
FIFTEEN COUNCILS BUT THE
HIGHEST RATE OF FELONY. YOUR
CURLS H. AND THEN ANOTHER HALF
MILLION WAS NOTABLE TO OTHER
COUNTIES REPETITIVE APPLICATION
PROCESS. REMAINING HUNDRED WAS
DEDICATED TO OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT PROGRAM- AS PART
CURRENT MOST CURRENT UPDATE
YOU'RE WORKING WITH A TOTAL OF
TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT DIVERSION PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE AND HAVE
CURRENTLY COMMITTED NINETY SIX
POINT ONE MILLION IN FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORT. HE'S
COUNTIES COLLECTIVELY PROJECTED
SERVER EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE INDIVIDUALS WHICH IS 20%
HIGHER THAN OUR ORIGINAL
ESTIMATE OF SEVEN HUNDRED. AS
OF DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
THIRTEEN POUNDS HAVE ACTIVATED
THEIR PROGRAMS AND ADDITIONAL
SEVEN HOUSEHOLD EXECUTED
CONTRACTS ALREADY IN PLACE WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT AND HAVE PLANNED
ACTIVATION DATES THIS WINTER.
NOW ONE COUNTY IS CURRENTLY AND
CONTRACTORS BALL AND THEN FOR
COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY WRAPPING
UP THEIR CONTRACTS. ALL OF THE
TOP FIFTEEN POUNDS ORIGINAL
YOUR MARKET THIS FUND FUNDING
ONE COUNTY HAS OFFICIALLY OPTED
OUT MEDIA SUPPORT TEAM FROM OUR
WHAT WE CALL ORIGINAL TOXIC
CHICHARRONES. AND SOME OF OUR
COUNTIES HAVE OPTED FOR A LOWER
FUNDING THRESHOLDS ARE
COMMENSURATE WITH CERTAIN THE
LOWER NUMBER OF CLIENTS THIS IS
RESULTED IN SOME SAVINGS THAT
INCREASE THE POOL OF FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE. AVAILABLE TO
OTHER TOWNS. AND SO FOR THOSE
REMAINING FRIENDS WE HAVE
RELEASE YOU HAD ROUNDS- CHOOSE
COUNTY. COUNCIL PREFER. ONE IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
ANOTHER IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AND HAS SINCE AWARDED
FUNDING TO ELEVEN WHICH RUNS.
AS OF JUNE. I KNOW THIS IS ALL
DATA- BUT AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY- ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN DIVERTED TO EIGHT POUND
RUN PROGRAM FUNDED IDEAS EACH
THE REASON WHY THIS DATA IS
SOLD IS THAT WE- AND THE
STATUTE REQUIRES COUNTIES TO
SUBMIT DATA NINETY DAYS AFTER
THE END OF. EACH QUARTER- AND
SO AS AS MAY REVISION
APPROACHES WILL BE ABLE TO
ACQUIRE. MORE CURRENT DATA-
SOME OF THE IN. IN SERVICES AND
WAY BY PURCHASING CHINESE
INCLUDING. MANAGEMENT YOUR
SUPPORT SPECIALIST WHAT IS YOUR
CRISIS. EXPANSION OF FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPSAND
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
IN ADDITION A VARIETY OF
HOUSING OPTIONS THAT ARE BEING
ACCESSED- BY DIVERSION PLANS
INCLUDE MASTER LEAST RESIDENCES
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING RESIDENTIAL
CARE AND SOBER LIVING HOMES AS
WELL AS TRANSITIONAL HOUSING-
SUPPORTING THE COUNTIES IN THE
SPACE HAS KIND OF COME INTO IN
IN CHIU BUCKETS ONE IS TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS YES
EACH IS FOCUSED OUR EFFORTS IN
SUPPORTING COUNTIES THROUGH-
DELIVERING TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO DATE ME
DELIVER CLOSE TO SEVENTY HOURS
OF FORMAL TRAINING ALONG WITH
LOTS OF INFORMAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EXISTING ACCOUNTS TO
NETWORK AND LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN OUR TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WAS
PRIMARILY FOCUSED. ON TOPICS
AROUND INITIAL PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS SO HOW
TO IDENTIFY ELIGIBLE CANDIDATES
WHICH RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS TO
USE AND THEN CURRENTLY- TOPICS
ARE MORE FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
COUNTIES AS THEY'RE ACTIVATING
YOUR PROGRAMS ON INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE APPROPRIATE
MEDICATION CYCLE PHARMACOLOGY
IN CONSIDERATION FOR
PRESCRIBERS HOW DID NEEDS REST
RISK ASSESSMENTS TO INFORM
QUITE TREATMENT PLANS ARE- AND
THEN ACTUALLY DOING VERY CASE
SPECIFIC CONSULTATIONS WITH
EXPERTS AROUND MORE DIFFICULT-
DIVERSION HE SAYS. AND THEN THE
LAST AREA OF FOCUS BEEN AROUND
OUT OF. AND WHAT WE'RE AFTER
AND SO WERE REQUIRED COLLECT.
OUTLINED IN WELFARE. BECAUSE.
THREE SIXTY ONE- AND THEN ALSO
AS PART OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN
ENACTED BUDGET GST EACH WAS
REQUIRED OR IS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND WORK WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO REPORT
ON- ANY TRIAL COURT DATA
RELATED TO THAT WATER MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION. STATUTE ONE.
ONE THOUSAND ONE POINT THREE
SIX JUSTER. I GUESS SHARE A
COUPLE OF HIGHLIGHTS- FROM THIS
DATA COLLECTION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN. TWENTY
PROXIMATE NEED FORTY QUARTS
SUBMITTED INFORMATION AND
REPORTED THAT OVER NINETEEN
HUNDRED PETITIONS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION. HAD BEEN
RECEIVED AND ABOUT 29% OF THOSE
ARE MORE RELATED TO- PARTITIONS
ON A FELONY CHARGE. IT
ADDITIONALLY QUARTZ REPORTED.
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOR
DIVERSION. I WERE GRANTED OF
WHICH THIRTY CHEAP. WERE
RELATED CHECK. PROBLEMS AREN'T
CHARGE. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DMCH IS REQUESTING TO
EXPAND THE DIVERSION PROGRAM AS
STEPHANIE MENTIONED WE ARE
REQUESTING OUR ONE TIME FUNDING
OF FORTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION TO EXPAND THE CURRENT
I. S. G. DIVERSION PROGRAM THIS
IS REALLY MADE UP- ABSURDITY
SHE MAIN PART. ONE IS- TWENTY
EIGHT ALMOST JUST UNDER TWENTY
NINE MILLION ARTISTS FOR THE
EXPANSION OF DIVERSION PROGRAMS
TO ANY NEW CARAMEL THAT- WE'RE
NOT ALREADY CONTRACTING.
PROJECTING TO SERVE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY DEDUCTIBLES WITHOUT
FUNDING AND THEN THE OTHER
PIECE WOULD BE SEVENTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION THAT WOULD BE
TARGETED R. G. INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL. SERVERS
IN OUR EXISTING. BROWN'S SO I
TOLD WOULD BE SIX POINT ONE
NINE AND ENERGY WE ARE REQUEST
THAT FOR PER POSITIONS AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY BALLOT TO.
THAT ALLOW IN ORDER POP AND-
PROGRAM- AND THEN IN ADDITION
LASTLY WE ARE REQUESTING- ARE
ENCOURAGED AND IT'S A
EXTENSION OF OUR REGIONAL
FUNDING- AND THAT REALLY IS
DRIVEN BY. THE FACT THAT WE
STILL HAVE SOME FUNDS ON THE
TABLE RIGHT TO SPEND EVERY
DOLLAR AND STILL NEED A LITTLE
EXTRA TIME TO ROLL OUT- THIRD
ON COMPETITIVE FUNDING
APPLICATION PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN GET THOSE FUNDS OUT. AND
JONES G. OBVIOUSLY THOSE FUNDS
WILL HAVE THAT FOR MOVIE YEAR.
TERMS TO THEM TO SPEND THOSE
DOLLARS- WITH RISK TO OUR THE
QUESTION AROUND WHY YOU'RE
SEEKING RESOURCES TO XPAND THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM AND WIENER
HAPPENED- SINCE SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS I THINK I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE KNOWLEDGE
OF THEIR HAVE BEEN SOME DELAYS.
ON THIS PROGRAM- AND OF. THAT
PLANT THE PROGRAMS AND BEGIN
DIVERTING INDICATE. ARE DURING
THE SPRING AND SUMMER IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAT THEY WERE-
OBVIOUSLY DELAYED DUE TO THE
VARIOUS IMPACTS RESULTING FROM
THE PANDEMIC- SOME OF THESE.
IMPACTS INCLUDE COURT CLOSURES
ARE BUDGET UTS AND HIRING
FREEZES IN THE ECONOMY MASS
RELEASES OF INMATES AT THE
LOCAL JAIL AS WELL AS VIRUS
OUTBREAKS AT THE JAILS WHICH
SORT OF HINDERED SORT OF THOSE
OPERATIONAL- PROCESS IS THE
REQUIREMENT TO GET IN THERE AND
YOU ASSESSMENT OF INDIVIDUALS
IN THE JAIL- BUT AS WE SORT OF
HEADED INTO FALL AND NOW
WINTER- ALONG WITH THE RE
OPENING. THE COURTS WE'VE
STARTED TO SEE A LOT OF
MOVEMENT AND ACTIVITY WITH
THESE PROGRAMS AND YOU- EXPECT
THE MAJORITY OF OUR PROGRAMS
SHOULD BE. UP AND RUNNING. THIS
FISCAL YEAR. I'M NOT AND SO
SAID THAT IN IN TURN OF WHY
SEEKING RESOURCE ONE BIGGEST-
STEPHANIE ADDRESS THIS EARLIER
ARE WE- SYSTEM HIGH WHY THAT IS
DUE TO THE DELAY WITH HIM OF WE
NEED REALLY WALKED ALL OF THE
OLD SO WE TO ADDRESS THE- AND
SO EXPANSION OF DIAPERS WILL IS
ONE OF THE FEW OF. ACCURAY FOR
AS TO YOU CAN PASS. FOR I G. IN
A- SHE KNOWS. AND ALLOW JOHN
CHIU COOPER DEFENDANTS BEFORE
ACTUALLY BEING TO. AS AN I. S.
G. COULD BE A PATH TO REDUCE
THE- NUMBER BRIAN CHEESE AND
STATE. AND THEN WE ALSO DO YOU
KNOW THAT MANY EXISTING COUNTY
PROGRAMS HAVE EXPRESSED. IN
EXPANDING THEIR PROGRAMS
THROUGH- ADDITIONAL FUNDS AND-
ACETATE- AND- WE ALSO LEARNED
JUST THROUGH OUR ONGOING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH- THE COUNCIL
AND ALL JUSTICE IN THE HOUSE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS
JUSTICE CENTER AND DSHS
PARTICIPATION IN STATEWIDE
COUNTY VIRGIN TRAINS POSTED BY
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD
WARN THAT MANY TRAVELS NOT
CURRENT PURCHASE NOT CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE DECISION I
LET HAVE ACTUALLY DEVELOPED
SOME DIVERSION PROGRAMS TARGETS
MISTER LEONARD POPULATION HAS
TO MORE CLIENTS TO POPULATION
AND THOSE PROTOCOLS WOULD BE
EXPANDED TO. INCLUDE THE. ISSUE
POPULATION. WITH RESPECT TO THE-
A IS THAT YOU EACH BEING ONE
FORMAL EVALUATE- IF SO WHAT THE
TIME. WELL THE INITIAL FUNDING
ALL FOR THIS WAS FOCUSED ON.
THAT DATA WORK BY STATURE- AND
DID NOT INCLUDE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT FORMAL VALUATION
HOWEVER OUR DATA COLLECTION
DOES INCLUDE DEMOGRAPHIC AND
SERVICE LEVEL DATA. WHICH WOULD
BE WERE REGULARLY- ANNUAL
ATHLETES AND IN ADDITION MORE
MONITORING OUTCOMES TRACKING
BEST PRACTICES AND DEVELOPING A
COMPENDIUM THAT WILL SUMMARIZE.
COUNTIES PROGRAM AND OUTLINED
THE SERVICES AND INTERVENTIONS
USED AND CLIENTS AS WELL AS-
PROVIDED A SUMMARY THE CLIENT
SERVICES- AS OF OUR BUDGET
REQUEST. INCLUDED ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THESE EFFORTS AND SUPPORT DATA
COLLECTION. AND THEN LASTLY I
WANTED TO ADDRESS- THE LAST
QUESTION WHICH WAS PLEASE
DESCRIBE HOW DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS THAT USE YES EACH
INCLUDES THE S. ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF THE HOMELESS
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVED
POPULATIONS. AND WAIT TO
COMPLETION OF SERVICES AND
REPLENISHING SECTIONS I HAVE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS-
I THINK THE BIGGEST FEAR IS A
DEVELOPING JOINT TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOCUSING
ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY AROUND- WORKING
WITH THE- JUSTICE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATIONS
ONE A GREAT EXAMPLE. OF THIS
IS- LAST YEAR PARTNER WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT HELP CARE SIR CENTER
C. H. D. A AS WELL AS THE
HEALTH WANTS TO FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO DEVELOP
TRAINING COUNCIL STAFF. AND
FOCUSED ON THIS MITIGATION
STRATEGIES AND INTERVENTIONS-
AND NOW THAT WAS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND REALLY TARGETED
DIRECT LINE STAFF AND
SUPERVISORS WHO ARE ALL WORKING
WITH THIS POPULATION FELT. THAT
DIVERSION AND WORKING WITH
COUNTY LEARN THAT THERE WAS A
NEED IN ACROSS. FOR LEARNING
ABOUT WORKING WITH THIS OP AND
SO- NOT ONLY IS YOUR DIVERSION
BUT ARE USED SEE DEEP SEA
PROGRAM ALWAYS. CHEERS G. MORE.
SPACE AND- CONTINUE SHOOT
PARTNER OUR OUR SISTER AGENCY.
ON ALL THEIR. ADDITIONALLY OUR
SAY THAT COUNTIES PARTICIPATE
IN THE C. D. P. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE REQUIRED TO. A WRITTEN
PLAN BACK ADDRESS HOW THE TO
LET OTHER FUNDS PROPERTY. AND
STANDS OUR EXISTING. JUNE TRY
THIS- AND- SO THAT MADE- SOME
OF THE OTHER. SENDING YOUR MARK
WILL BE A BIG ROLE FOR
INCREASING THAT CAPACITY IN THE
PEOPLE WATCHING ONE. IN
ADDITION- WE ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING REGULARLY- DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS WELL AS
SOCIAL SERVICES ALONG WITH OUR
AGENCY DEPUTY DEPUTY SECRETARY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS AND
THE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WERE. MADE AVAILABLE TO. SO
LET'S NOT RIGHT WILL OPEN IT UP
AND OR NEED TO RETURN PRESENTER.
THANK YOU VERY NEXT WE'LL HEAR
THE OF HOW CARE SIR. RIGHT
GIVEN THE LATE HOUR I WILL TRY
TO KEEP IT BRIEF BUT OF COURSE
OPEN TO QUESTIONS AT THE END
WHEN THE PANELISTS ARE DONE. SO
AS YOU CAN CLEARLY HEARD ON THE
HEARING TODAY- UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR INCREASED ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. WE
HAVE. BEEN LOOKING INTO AS
STATISTICS IN REGARDS TO NEEDED
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND WE CURRENTLY ARE
INDICATING THAT WE HAVE. WITH
INPATIENT INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC
BED CAPACITY IS ABOUT TWENTY
ONE BEDS TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND EXPERTS ESTIMATE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE PROBABLY NEED A
FIFTY R. YEP FIFTY TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IS NEEDED I'M
IN CALIFORNIA. WE ONLY HAVE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SEVEN Q. A MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT BEDS IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DRIVERS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
MISMATCH OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND-
ON THAT SIDE I THINK THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA FACES A
REAL ESTATE COSTS LEADING TO
CHALLENGES OF BUILDING NEW
FACILITIES- THERE HAS BEEN
HISTORICAL NOT IN MY BACKYARD
MENTALITY AND ZONING
RESTRICTIONS. A DIFFICULT.
ASSESSING FOR ACCESSING LOW
INCOME HOUSING AVAILABLE-
ADDITIONALLY THE RESTRICTIONS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REGARDS TO YOU- SERVICES IN
INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL DISEASE
OR I AM DIS. AND THEN LASTLY
COST BASED REIMBURSEMENT
PROVIDING COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN COUNTY
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS FROM
BUILDING FINANCIAL RESERVES
THAT COULD OTHERWISE ALLOW FOR
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE- BUT YOU KNOW A CLEAR
NEED- FROM THE CONVERSATIONS
TODAY AND RESEARCH OF WHAT'S
NEEDED IN THE COMMUNITY. TO
REALLY INCREASE THE COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT
RESOURCES AS WELL AS MAXIMIZING
THE AVAILABLE REAL ESTATE IN
LIGHT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PUTS FORWARD A PROPOSAL
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION OVER A THREE
YEAR- EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COUNTIES AND
TRIBES TO ACQUIRE- AND
REHABILITATE REAL ESTATE ASSETS
IT'S TO EXPAND THE COMMUNITY
YOU CAN TO I'M A BEHAVIOR TREAT
RESOURCE AND CAL. DO YOU SEE
BELIEVE WE COULD INCREASE
CAPACITY OF UP TO FIVE THOUSAND
BEDS WITH THESE FUNDS WHICH
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN SERVICES FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
FURTHERMORE IT WILL OPEN UP
OPPORTUNITIES THIS CALIFORNIA
WORKS ON ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER
ASK WITH CMS ON THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR R&D STAYS. ARE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT DH CS IS AND
THE ARE COUNTY PARTNERS ARE
VERY COMMITTED. TO ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE THE FULL CONTINUUM
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA A LOT FOR ALL
STEP DOWN IN DIVERSION SERVICES
IS A TO ENSURE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SERVICES AT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF CARE- AND
THAT WHEN THEY AREN'T AND I AM
D. THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
APPROPRIATE LOWER LEVEL
COMMUNITY SERVICES TO
TRANSITION TO. A DCS
ANTICIPATES THAT HAVING OF THE
APPLICATION UP AND RUNNING BY
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
WE WILL REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO
PROVIDE A 20% LOCAL MATCH-
INCLUDED IN OPERATING BUDGET AN
ONGOING SOURCE THE FUNDS. AS
WELL AS COMMITTED TO CONTINUOUS
DEDICATION- DEDICATED USE FOR
THIRTY YEARS R. DH CS HAS HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
SACK AND CVH DA AND WE WILL
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM ON
FLEXIBILITIES WITHOUT LOCAL
MATCH. WE DO THINK THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE AN HSA FUNDS COUNTY
GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS THE
VALUE OF PROPERTY OR LAND WE
WANT TO BE FLEXIBLE WITH THEM-
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE MOVING
THE NEEDLE IN THIS SPACE AND
MAXIMIZING. THESE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. ADDITIONALLY D.
CS OF PLANS YOU CAN A- GAS
ANALYSIS IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
ONE A TWO AND- OUR APPLE.
PROCESS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE ARE
CURRENT GAPS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
FULL CONTINUUM A TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE STRATEGICALLY. CLOSING
THOSE GAPS AS WE START TO FUND
PROJECTS- IN THE SCORING OF OUR
APPLICATIONS WOULD TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT. WE WOULD ALSO BE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO COUNTIES THAT
ARE SLIGHTLY SMALLER AND NEED
THAT TYPE OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH THIS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY. ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO SUPPORT THE COUNTIES. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
I LSO WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
YOU KNOW BUT BASED ON OUR LAST
SPEAKER THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS BUT
SPECIFICALLY AS YOU HEARD SOME
STATISTICS EARLIER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF. STATE HOSPITALS
YOU KNOW APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
PERCENT- HAD NOT OF THOSE AN
ICED TEAS- I HAD NOT ACCESS
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT SERVICES- IN THE SIX
MONTHS PRIOR TO THEIR ARREST IN
NEARLY 50% OF THE EYES TEETH.
WERE UNSHELTERED HOMELESS AT
THE TIME OF THEIR ARREST- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW IN ADDITION
TO- WHAT WERE BEEN HEARING TO
THIS HEARING THOSE STATISTICS
ALONE- YOU KNOW BUILDING ACCESS
TO COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY
BASED. BASED MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESS SERVICES IS GOING TO
BE CRITICAL- IN WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL THERE ARE
SOME THINGS WITHIN CAL AIM THAT
WE THINK WE SHOULD HIGHLIGHT.
IN REGARDS TO BEING ABLE TO
MOVE THAT NEEDLE IN ADDITION TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL-
PUT FORWARD FOR CONSIDERATION.
SO THERE'S TWO PIECES WITHIN
CAL AIMED I WILL GET YOU OTHER
KIND OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH KELLY
PROPOSALS IN ISSUE FIVE BUT-
RIGHT NOW I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON
ENHANCED YOUR MANAGEMENT IN
LIEU OF SERVICES. AND SOME OF
OUR JUSTICE INVOLVED PIECES I
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE AND
TALENT FOR THIS HIGH NEED
POPULATION. SO THE ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT IS MEANT TO BE A
COMMUNITY BASED INTENSIVE
BENEFIT- THAT ALLOWS FOR ON THE
GROUND- INTENSIVE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS. AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSED TARGET
POPULATIONS THE ONES THAT ARE
MOST PERTINENT TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY INCLUDE
CHILDREN WITH COMPLEX MEDICAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS- INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS OR WHO ARE
AT RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK FOR
INSTITUTIONALIZATION WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS CHILDREN
WITH EACH YEAR IS EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WITH CO OCCURRING
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS- AND
LASTLY. INDIVIDUALS
TRANSITIONING FROM
INCARCERATION AND YOU HAVE TO.
COM IS OR BE HEALTH NEEDS I
REQUEST. IT TRANSITION SERVICES
INTO THE COMMUNITY. SO THOSE
ARE THREE OF OUR MAIN TARGET
POPULATIONS FOR ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT. I'M THERE ARE SOME
WHAT WE'RE CALLING IN LIEU OF
SERVICES PROPOSED IN CALAIS
AND- WHICH ESSENTIALLY
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES THAT CAN
BE OFFERED TO A BENEFICIARY CAN
MEET CERTAIN ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA. IN LIEU OF HIGHER
COST SERVICES INPATIENT STAYS
EMERGENCY ROOM XTERRA. UP AND
THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF IN LIEU
OF SERVICES THAT WE THINK WOULD
GREATLY IMPACT OF THE
POPULATION BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY I'M INCLUDING HOUSING
TRANSITION NAVIGATION SERVICES
DEPOSITS. TENDENCY ASSISTING
SERVICES SHORT TERM POST
HOSPITALIZATION HOUSING WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE TRANSITIONS OUT
OF INSTITUTIONS- INCLUDING BOTH
AS- INCARCERATION AS WELL AS I.
N. D.'S. RECUPERATIVE CARE- AS
WELL AS THEY HAVE DILATATION
PROGRAMS AND SOBERING CENTERS.
ARE GIVEN YOU KNOW THE
CONVERSATION HAVE AROUND
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION I'M LET
ME JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
AROUND HOW THE ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT- SERVICES WOULD
BENEFIT US SOMEONE IN THAT
POPULATION- SO SAY YOU HAVE A
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL WHO IS-
BEEN ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL.
SOMETIMES THE IN CURRENT STATE
SOMEONE COULD STAY HOSPITALIZED
FOR. UP TO SIX. IBM MONTHS
OFTEN SOMETIMES A VERY LONG
PERIODS OF TIME YOU SEEN IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF STATES WORKING
WITH OUR PUBLIC- OUR OUR
HOSPITAL COLLEAGUES- BUT LONG
LENGTH OF STAY. THIS WOULD
ALLOW SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION OUT TO RECRUITMENT
OF CARE SERVICES. AND BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE MEDICAL SERVICES.
LIMITED MEDICAL SERVICES WHILE
THEY TRANSITION WHILE LINKING
THEM UP THROUGH ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT TO VARIOUS HOUSING
NAVIGATION SERVICES. ALLOWING
FOR THAT APPROPRIATE STEP DOWN
WHILE ALSO IDENTIFYING ANY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
MAY. NEED AND GET THEM INTO
THOSE NEED TO IT'S- SO REALLY
THINKING THE WHOLE COMPLY CAN
TO. ALSO WITH IN CALAIS IN-
THEY IS A FOCUS A JUSTICE. FOR
EXAMPLE PROPOSES A THIRTY DAY
IN RE TRUST SOMEBODY IS
INCARCERATED TO START THE
TRANSITION SMOOTHLY BEFORE THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS RELEASED FROM
JAIL IT ALSO- PROPOSES
MANDATORY ENROLLMENT IN MEDI
CAL MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL A
PRIOR TO RELEASE WITH WARM
HANDOFFS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WHETHER THAT BE THE COUNTY. OR
THE MINUTE OF THE MANAGED CARE
PLAN DEPENDING ON THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED- ALSO
WITHIN CALAIS MORE ALLOWING
SUBSTANCE USE HISTORY OF PRIOR
TO INCARCERATION TO MAKE
SOMEONE ELIGIBLE FOR TREATMENT
UPON RELEASE AND MANY OF THE-
ENHANCE YOUR MANAGEMENT IN LIEU
OF SERVICES THAT I MENTIONED
WITH THE TARGET POPULATION BUT
ALSO GREATLY BENEFIT JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS
COORDINATING CARE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE GETTING WHAT THEY
NEED. I THINK TELLING BILLS WE
ARE VERY MUCH SO ON THE
NECESSARY KIND OF POLICY AND
BENEFITS NEEDED TO CREATE THE
WILL CONTINUE- AND INCREASE
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES- ENSURING THAT
APPROPRIATE TRANSITIONS ARE
TAKING PLACE BUT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSION AND
THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING- AND
DRIVING THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
SOCIAL FACTORS THAT ARE OFTEN-
HINDERING SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO.
BECOME HEALTHIER- AND OR TO
SEEK TREATMENT AND SERVICES I
DO USE THE F. DOES PLAN ON
COVERING BEHAVIORAL KELLY MY
VIRGINITY IS AN ISSUE FIVE SO I
WON'T DUPLICATE- OUR COMMENTS
THERE- AND- BUT WILL YOU KNOW
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON A
FEW OF THE OTHER PIECES I THINK
WE ALSO ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY. WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN AND YOUTH- AND
FAMILIES SERVING FOSTER SYSTEM-
ARE RECEIVING AT ALL SERVICES
THAT THEY ARE NEEDED WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE IMPROVING
ACCESS TO PHYSICAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN COORDINATING
CLOSELY WITH OUR SOCIAL SERVICE
COLLEAGUES- IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE DEPARTMENT AT IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE S. LAW A
FOSTER Mà OF CARE WORKERS TWO
X. THIS VERY THING INCOME UP
WITH A LONG TERM PLAN. FOR HOW
WE CAN IMPROVE. OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH I'M
AND HOW WE CAN BETTER PROVIDE
PHYSICAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OR ON SOCIAL SERVICES-
AND THAT WORK GROUP WILL
CONTINUE TO MEET YOUR JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I'M SO THIS
WOULD BE THE END OF MY COMMENTS
TO LOOK FOR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DR
EWING. THANK YOU HI I'M DOCTOR
DANIEL. SO I THINK YOU KNOW IN
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
CONVERSATION. I WANT TO A
LITTLE BIT OF THE HISTORY.
CALIFORNIA IS FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS PROGRAM. THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
ACTUALLY PREDATES THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND WAS-
PIONEERED THE N. LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND THEN WAS
SUPPORTED WITH SOME HIGH THAT
LEGISLATION THAT WAS AUTHORED
BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DARRELL
STEINBERG- CALIFORNIA'S FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
DESIGNED TO SERVE OUR- OUR
MENTAL HEALTH CLIENTS WHO HAVE
THE GREATEST NEEDS. AND THE
GOAL OF THE PROGRAM WAS TO
WOULD SERVE THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
JAIL OR PRISON INVOLVEMENT AND
HOSPITALIZATION. AND THE ACTUAL
ORIGIN IN TELLING CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZED THAT AT THE TIME LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WAS PLACING
MENTAL HEALTH CONSUMERS IN A
STATE HOSPITAL. AND A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION APPROACH THE
COUNTY AND ARGUED THAT WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DELIVER CARE IN
A WHATEVER IT TAKES APPROACH.
THAT THEY COULD SERVE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY RATHER THAN IN A
LOCKED INSTITUTION. AND BY
SERVING THEM AND THE COMMUNITY
THEY COULD DRIVE DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDING AND OTHER FUNDING
STREAMS. I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT EVERYBODY WHO IS SERVED IN
A ESTATE HOSPITAL CAN BE SERVED
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND I DO WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT. THAT
YEAH I MENTIONED EARLIER IN MY
TESTIMONY THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD OUT AN EARLY PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAM. IN PART OF OUR EFFORT
IS TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW CAN
WE DESIGN COMMUNITY BASED CARE
O WE RELIED LESS ON
INSTITUTIONAL BASED CARE. AND A
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
ACTUALLY PROVIDES. A CONTEXT
FOR SAYING CAN WE INTERVENE.
MUCH EARLIER AGAIN B. M.
DEVELOPMENT OF SOMEONE'S MENTAL
ILLNESS SO THE DATA THAT TALK
ABOUT HIGH NOT HIGH NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE RECEIVING SIR-
WORK. INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT WEREN'T
NECESSARILY RECEIVING SERVICES
THEN ALTERNATELY BEING CHARGED
WITH A FELONY CRIME AND AS A
RESULT OF BEING DECLARED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
BEING DIRECTED INTO A STATE
HOSPITAL PROGRAM. THE
COMMISSION IS ACTUALLY USING
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
RECEIVED TWO YEARS AGO WE'VE
LAUNCHED SEVERAL PROJECTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN
REDUCE THE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE. NEEDING THAT HIGHEST
LEVEL OF INSTITUTIONAL BASED
CARE BY WORKING UPSTREAM SO WE
ARE DEVELOPING PSYCHIATRIC
ADVANCE DIRECTIVES MODEL AFTER
ADVANCE DIRECTIVES THAT ARE
COMMONLY USED IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD WHERE ARE FRESNO COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY IN A COUPLE OF
OTHER COUNTIES. ARE VERY
INTERESTED AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
DEDICATING COUNTY INNOVATION
FINDS THEIR MATCHING FUNDS THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING. FROM THE FIVE
NINE DOLLARS THAT WE ORIGINALLY
ALLOCATED TWO YEARS AGO. WE ARE
WORKING WITH I THINK IT IS-
TWELVE COUNTIES TO HELP THEM DO
THE SAME KIND OF DATA MATCH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL HAS DONE. TO LOOK AT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
AND COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND
UNDERSTAND HOW CAN WE BETTER
DELIVER COMMUNITY BASED CARE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE AT RISK OF.
STATE HOSPITALIZATION OR AGAIN
JAIL INVOLVEMENT OR
HOMELESSNESS. RIGHT THE
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
RECOGNIZING THE INCREASED
PRESSURE THAT WE'RE SEEING ON
STATE HOSPITALS. I'M THE
COMMISSION IS VERY INTERESTED
IN UNDERSTANDING HOW WE MIGHT
FORTIFY THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
IN THESE PREVENTION STRATEGIES.
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT WE CAN
SERVE PEOPLE VERY EARLY AND THE
ONSET OF PSYCHOSIS SO THAT
THEIR NEEDS DON'T ESCALATE TO
THE POINT. THAT THEY ARE
ARRESTED FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
TIMES FOR MISDEMEANORS AND THEN
HAVE A FELONY CHARGE AND BECOME
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. HOW
CAN WE STRENGTHEN THE FOR THE
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP MODEL.
AND I WOULD COMMENT THAT IT'S
CALLED A FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP MODEL. THE WORD
PARTNER REFERS TO THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION OR THE
COUNTY THAT IS DELIVERING CARE
AND IT'S FULL SERVICE BECAUSE
THE FLEXIBILITY OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FARMS
ALLOWS THE PROVIDER TO DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THAT PERSON HAS THE
CARE AND THE SUPPORT NECESSARY
SO THAT THEY AREN'T HOMELESS
AREN'T INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND AREN'T
INVOLVED WITH- ESTATE HOSPITALS
OR OR EVEN COMMUNITY HOSPITALS.
THAT COMMENT IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT
IS AVAILABLE. THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM WAS FOUND
TO BE SO EFFECTIVE IN THE
INITIAL EVALUATIONS THAT WERE
CONDUCTED. AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WAS ACTUALLY BEING
DRAFTED. THAT THE AXE THAT
STIPULATES THAT COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO SPEND AT LEAST HALF
OF THEIR COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT FUNDS ON FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS. AND AS INDICATED
IN THE ANALYSIS. THAT'S RUNNING
AROUND NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND THE REASON I
MENTION THIS IS BECAUSE THAT IS
YEAH. AMONG IF NOT THE LARGEST
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMMATIC
INVESTMENT THAT WE MAKE. IT
MEANS THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY. IF THE STATE CAN
SUPPORT IT BILLION COUNTIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS HOW WE MIGHT
STRENGTHEN THOSE INVESTMENTS
AND HOW WE MIGHT FIND WAYS TO
EXPAND OF THOSE INVESTMENTS. AS
AN EXPLICIT STRATEGY TO TAKE
PRESSURE OFF OF OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEM THE GOAL IS TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON INSTITUTIONAL CARE
RATHER THAN EXPAND RELIANCE ON
INSTITUTIONAL CARE. YEAH AND
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT WE'VE NOT
NECESSARILY MADE THE RIGHT KIND
OF INVESTMENTS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH COUNTIES. TO EXPLORE HOW
THAT CAN WORK THAT INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE. BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO IS
DEVELOPING PSYCHOSIS AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE DELIVERING
CARE AS EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
I'M ON AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS
AS THEY'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP
OUT THERE EARLY SIZED PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAM AND THEY'RE EXPLICITLY
TO FRACKING BASED ON PREVALENCE
RATES THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
RESEARCH SUGGESTS WILL DEVELOP
A PSYCHOTIC DISORDER. IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO COME IN
FOR SERVICES AND THEN ARE
WORKING VERY AGGRESSIVELY TO
SEE IF THEY CAN IDENTIFY THE
80% OR SO OF PEOPLE THAN THEIR
STATE WHO ARE NOT ACCESSING
CARE WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR OF
ON SET OF. A PSYCHOTIC DISORDER.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO TRACK.
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE WHO DO
HAVE A PSYCHOTIC DISORDER ARE
ACCESSING FOSTERS PARTNERSHIPS
SERVICES WE'RE ALSO BEGINNING
TO TRACK THE IMPACT OF.
RECEIVING SERVICES THAT THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT AS MUCH AS SIXTY NINE
THERE'S A IS MUCH OF THE 69%
REDUCTION. IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT. ALL WHO ARE SERVED
BY A FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
SO WE THINK THIS STRATEGY OF
DELIVERING MORE COMMUNITY BASED
CARE. WRAPAROUND CARE CARE THAT
IS TAILORED TO THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT IT THAT
SUPPORTS OUR ABILITY TO MOVE
UPSTREAM. IS THE WAY THAT WE
CAN AFFORDABLE THEY REDUCE
RELIANCE ON VERY EXPENSIVE VERY
DIFFICULT. INSTITUTIONAL KINDS
OF SETTINGS NOW THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE CAN TAKE PEOPLE
TODAY OUT OF INSTITUTIONS BUT
IT DOES MEAN THAT WE CAN BEGIN
TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IN
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SO THAT OVER TIME
WE'RE LESS RELIANT. ON STATE
HOSPITAL BEDS WERE LESS RELIANT
ON THESE CRISIS SERVICES AND
ARGUABLY WERE EVEN LESS RESIGN
RELIANT ON FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION A FAR BETTER THAN
WE'RE DOING TODAY. THE M. AND I
MENTIONED THE MONEY AGAIN
BECAUSE GIVEN THE SCALE OF THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN FOR
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE BEGIN TO LOOK
AT THE IMPACT OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND HOW WE MIGHT
LEVERAGE THAT. MAXIMIZING
FEDERAL DRIVE DOWN FOR EXAMPLE
I'M- ALSO PROVIDING THE RIGHT
KIND OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RESEARCH ANALYSIS AND SUPPORT
TO OUR COUNTY PARTNERS SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING THE
BIGGEST. BANG FOR THE BUCK THAT
IS POSSIBLE. THE QUESTION IF
YOU HAVE THEM THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM DR KELLY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR ARAMBULA
SO THAT THEY CAN BE A HEALTH
SAFETY NET REALLY SPECIALIZES
IN WORKING WITH OUR HIGH NEEDS
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
COVERED IN THIS PANEL ON
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS WITH A SERIOUS AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. AS WELL
AS THOSE WHO ARE JUSTICE
INVOLVED AND CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH HIGH ACUITY A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES WE
WORK REALLY WELL WITH THESE
POPULATIONS BECAUSE WE TAKE A
SYSTEMS APPROACH A
BIOPSYCHOSOCIAL APPROACH TO
CARE. AND WE'RE ABLE TO BRAID
OR MULTIPLE FUNDING STREAMS TO
DO A SORT OF OUT REACH MOBILE
CRISIS RESPONSE AT WE PAY FOR
LOCKED IN OTHER TREATMENT
SERVICES WHICH ALL TOO OFTEN
FALL OUTSIDE OF THE ROUNDOF
REGULAR HEALTH CARE INSURANCE
COVERAGE INCLUDING. THOSE
THINGS THAT ARE COVERED BY
MEDICARE. THE SILO FUNDING
STREAMS CAN ALSO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR STAKEHOLDERS AND
POLICY MAKERS TO GET THE FULL
PICTURE OF OUR RANGE OF
SERVICES- AND TO BE ABLE TO SEE
WHERE ACTUAL GAPS EXIST IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WITH THE
BROADER HOMELESS POPULATION
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 2225% OF
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAVE A SERIOUS
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT AN ACUTE
PORTION OF THE BROADER
POPULATION SAME FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER RATES ARE CLOSER
217220% ACCORDING TO THE- THE
HUD- ESTIMATES AND WHEN I FOUND
MYSELF IN WORKING WITH THIS
POPULATION OF CLIENTS FOR THE
PAST TWENTY NINE YEARS IS THAT
MANY OF OUR- OUR CLIENTS
DEVELOP BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AS A RESULT. OF
THEIR HOMELESSNESS NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND HOW LONG
PERIODS OF LIVING ON THE
STREETS CAN EXPOSE INDIVIDUALS
TO MULTIPLE LAYERS OF TRAUMAS
AND THE EXPERIENCE OF LIVING
WITH THE STIGMA AND BIAS THAT
ALSO COMES ALONG WITH A HERO
CAL HEALTH CONDITIONS CAN
ABSOLUTELY MAKE OUR CLIENTS
MORE VULNERABLE TO EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. I LIKE TO JUST
SHARE SOME OF OUR SUCCESSES IN
WORKING WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POPULATION AS WELL AS
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION HERE IN
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY AS IN MANY
OF OUR FTA COUNTIES- WE HAVE A
SYSTEM OF CARE FOR HOMELESS
POPULATION. IN SAMBAR DINO WE
ROLL WITH OUR SHERIFF'S
HOMELESS POLICING GROUP THAT
MEANS WE DEPLOY IT SIDE BY SIDE
WE SHARE THE AREAS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO USUALLY AND- ARE. OUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ESERT OR
UNDER FREEWAY EMBANKMENTS WE
SUPPORT OUR PARTNERS. AT BY
DOING CASE MANAGEMENT WE HAVE
BEEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAVE
BEEN THE SOLE SUPPORT. FROM
CASE MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO WERE LIVING IN
QUARANTINE AND ARE COPING
TRAILERS THAT CAME FROM THE
GOVERNOR FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
COVERED POSITIVE AND- NO PLACE
ELSE TO GO- WE HAVE PROVIDED
CASE MANAGEMENT FOR ALL OF OUR-
ROOM KEY OPERATION ROOM KEY AND
HOME KEY PROJECTS. AND WE ARE
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE. HAD AN
MHSAA. INNOVATION PROJECT
CALLED INROADS FOR INNOVATIVE
REMOTE. ONSIDE ONSITE ACCESS
AND DELIVERY OF SERVICES WHICH
IS A MOBILE UNIT THAT GOES INTO
OUR A REMOTE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS THAT BRINGS TO THE
UNIT OUR TO THE- HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT A CLINICIAN AND
ALCOHOL AND DRUG COUNSELOR WE
HAVE A NURSE PRACTITIONER FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE HAVE A STAFF
MEMBER FROM AGING AND ADULT
SERVICES A WE ALSO PAY FOR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SHERIFF
DEPUTIES TO DEPLOY WITH US AND
THE KEY THAT WE FOUND.
VETERINARY CARE SERVICES SO
THAT WE CAN. MAKE OURSELVES
AVAILABLE AND INCREASE TRUST
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING-
OUTING COMMUNITY WITHOUT HOME
WE CAN DO VISITS AND GET THEM
READY TO BE HOUSE BECAUSE WHAT
WE'VE FOUND IS YOU CAN'T JUST
LIKE SOMEONE OUT OF THE STREETS
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. AND PLACE THEM IN A
LOCKED HOME ARE LOCKED A HOTEL
ROOM AND EXPECT THEM TO STAY.
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO ALL OF
THAT FROM OUR SUCCESSES WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUP AGAIN
MANY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY. I SAID ON OUR
LINE JUSTICE GROUP WITH OUR
SHARE OF OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
A PUBLIC DEFENDER ARE SECURE
COURT JUDGES ARE PROBATION
CHIEF. AND MANY OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WHICH I THINK REALLY
SPEAKS TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
PARTNERSHIP AND RELATIONSHIP.
WE SUPPORT EACH OTHER WE DO
JAIL RE ENTRY FOR OUR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND AGAIN THANKS TO
THE MHSAA ARE THANKS TO YOU
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION DIRECTOR EWING WE
HAVE USED SP NINE ACE SB EIGHTY
TWO GRANTS TO CREATE A TRIAGE.
GROUP WE CALL IT TRIAGE
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT TEAM OR
TEST THEIR COLOCATED. WITHIN.
FORTY EIGHT DIFFERENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. A JURISDICTION AND
SHE SUBS. AND THEY DO COMMUNITY
POLICE. AND THE SAME SENSE OF
WORK WITH ON FOUR MEANT TO. I
CRISIS CALL DIRECT RACES WE-
TEAM I CAN FUNDED TO MHS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE SO THAT
WE REALLY BUILT THIS
PARTNERSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY COUNTY OF FUNDED
AND OPERATED FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT DIRECTOR
EWING WAS JUST DISCUSSING OUR
CORE HAVE BEEN COR TO THE
VISION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. THROUGHOUT THIS
PIECE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE A
WHATEVER IT TAKES APPROACH TO
THE HIGHEST NEEDS POPULATION.
WE HAVE AN FSP FOR HOMELESS
PEOPLE. I AM IN THE L. A. C.
DAY TEAM FOUND TO. IN OUTCOMES
FOR FSP PARTICIPANTS ACROSS
VARIOUS DOMAINS INCLUDING.
LINKAGE TO PRIMARY CARE REDUCE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT. AND WHILE PROJECT
ROOM KEY HAS HOUSE MORE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THOSE HOUSING EFFORTS
WERE NOT SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
AT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CLIENTS SOMEONE LIVING WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS OR AN ADDICTION
ON THE STREETS AND THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT AS NOT
BEING. PART OF THE A PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE VIA FEMA SO THAT
COUNTIES HAVE TO LEVERAGE OUR
OWN STAFF OUR OWN FUNDING.
AGAIN WE'RE- A CASE MANAGEMENT
STAFF AND CLINICIANS SO THAT
THEY CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICE IN
OUR COMMUNITY TO OUR HOMELESS
FOLKS. AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT TE COUNTIES HAVE TO PULL
THEIR STAFF WHO ARE ABLE TO
BILL FOR MEDICAL SERVICES AND
THEN PLACE THEM OUT TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ALBEIT NOT WELL
FUNDED- SERVICE DELIVERY.
HOUSING MORE INDIVIDUALS IS
GOOD FOR THE OVERALL MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY WE'VE ALSO
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY MORE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE IN NEED OF
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. TO SERVE THOSE FOLKS
ARE SERVICE. PROVIDERS OVERALL
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED BY COBIT OUTBREAKS
OFTEN DRIVEN MORE BY STAFF AND
CLIENTS AND BECAUSE OUR
TREATMENT PROVIDERS ARE OFTEN
CONGREGATE IN RESIDENTIAL IT
HAS BEEN CHALLENGING AT TIMES
TO DEAL WITH THE WAVES OF.
TEMPORARY CLOSURES AND
RESTRICTIONS ON CAPACITY THAT
HAVE COME WITH OPEN FOR ALL OF
OUR PARTNERS INCLUDING THE
STATE HOSPITALS AND OUR JAIL
SYSTEM. AT THE SAME TIME A
FELONY- ICED TEA WAITLIST HAS
ALMOST DOUBLED AS YOU HEARD
FROM- DISH SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC DUE TO THE CLOSURE
OF THE STATE HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE LESS. LOCAL CAPACITY TO
SERVE HIGH NEEDS POPULATIONS
NOT MORE WHICH IS ALSO DUE TO
COVERAGE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
MICHELLE STE SEE IF YOU CAN
MATCH. THANK YOU CARAMBOLA I'M
GOING TO SAY GOOD EVENING. I'M
GONNA SPEAK A LITTLE BIT- WHAT
MEDIC CAL AND MHS WHAT IS
WORKING ABOUT MEDIC COLLIN AND
BECAUSE THEY FUNDING AND WHAT
IS NOT FOR THE POPULATION- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
CONTEXT AGAIN TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT FITS WITHIN MEDICARE
HEALTH FUNDING AND WHAT DOES
THAT- FOR OUR MEDIC HEALTH
BENEFICIARY EVEN WITHIN OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION OUR
MEMBERS. NEED TO DO INTENSE
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT- EVEN
START MEDIC HEALTH SERVICES SO
FOR EXAMPLE TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF OUR INVESTMENT WITH
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AT CLIENTS
WHO HAVE SERIOUS AND PERSISTENT
MENTAL ILLNESS IT CAN TAKE
MONTHS SOMETIMES EVEN YEARS TO
BUILD TRUST OVER TIME WITH THAT
PERSON AND GET THEM TO ENGAGE
IN MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE
USE. TREATMENT SERVICES- IT CAN
TAKE A TYPICAL OUTREACH WORKER
ANYWHERE BETWEEN FORTY TO FIFTY
CONTACT BEFORE THEY WILL ENGAGE
IN SERVICES AND NONE OF THAT IS
MEDIC HOW BILLABLE WE WOULD
ARGUE THAT THERE NEED TO BE A
WIDER RANGE OF HOUSING AS WELL
AS TREATMENT OPTIONS AVAILABLE
TO THE- HIGH NEED POPULATIONS
THAT WERE SERVING AND FOR
EXAMPLE HELPING IS NOT COVERED
UNDER MEDICARE ALTHOUGH WE NEED
TO FIND. OUT AND OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES FOR THAT OUTSIDE OF
MEDICARE HOW- AND HSA FUNDS
HAVE BEEN LEVERAGED TO A LARGE
DEGREE FOR OUR HOUSING SERVICES
AND THEN WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
OUR- INSTITUTE OF MENTAL
DISEASE R. I AM D. EXCLUSION
WHICH IS REALLY SORT OF AT THE
QUARRY HERE AGAIN WHETHER A
PERSON IS ON MEDIC HOW OR NOT
DOESN'T MATTER IT IS. THE
PLACEMENT AVAILABILITY AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC IS THAT OUR
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL
CAPACITY HAS BEEN LIMITED BY
THE PANDEMIC AND SOMETIMES ARE
COUNTY YOU HAVE NOWHERE TO TURN
TO OTHER THAN OUR. I AND D.
FACILITIES FOR THAT LET BY OF.
WE HAVE ONE WHERE THERE ARE USE
CHU KEEP CARE- WHICH TOOK THEIR
PEACE PSYCHIATRIC CLIENT.
NEEDED TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS AND
RESTRICT ACCESS TO COPE IT AND
WHEN WHERE THEY USUALLY SPENT
AROUND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR ON MEDICAL
MEDIKAL BILLABLE IMPATIENT
BECAUSE- WHEN THEY WERE FORCED
TO TURN TO A LOCAL I. M. B.
PROVIDERS. THOSE COSTS. BY
ROCKETED TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WITHIN A MATTER OF MONTHS.
ANOTHER COUNTY IF AYE INDYCAR
ROSE BY 40% NONE OF THESE
ADDITIONAL COSTS WERE. PROVIDED
ANY KIND OF SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING AND SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICE
BUSINESSPEOPLE CHRISTINE WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING AT MEDIC HOW
BILLABLE SERVICES TO THE
POPULATION IT'S OFTEN NOT
INCLUDING THE FRONT END WHICH
IS THAT OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT
AND PREVENTION WORK WHICH IS
FUNDED UNDER THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. FOR THE BACKEND
WHICH ARE THE IMDB COSTS BOTH
BURKE- UNLOCKED AS WELL AS
BLOCK STUDY. NOR IS IT THE HOW.
ARRAY OF THIRD AND WITH THAT
THE SORT OF UNIVERSAL HOUSING
WHICH YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS IN THE HEARING
TONIGHT IS REALLY HOUSING
HOUSE- THE PROPHYLACTIC MET
MEDICINAL ASPECT TO IT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
POPULATION- YOU KNOW THOSE
RESOURCES ARE ALSO NOT SORT OF
AGNOSTIC WHEN IT COMES TO OUR-
CLIENTS WHO OFTENTIMES- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE HAVING TO PAY
FOR THROUGH THE MHSAA AGAIN.
SERVICES TO WORK WITH LANDLORDS
TO MAKE THEM UNDERSTAND- THE
NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION TO ME
TO GET THEM TO BE WILLING TO
HELP OUR POPULATIONS. THERE IS
A KIND OF NIMBYISM AND
DISCRIMINATION WITHIN- THE
HOUSING WORLD AS WELL WHICH
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR OUR
CLIENT ACCESS- BROADER HOUSING
INVESTMENT- WHEN IT COMES EVEN
TO TREATMENT PROVIDERS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A JUSTICE
INVOLVED POPULATION- IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO PLACE CLIENTS WITH
A HISTORY OF OUR- FACT THE
FENCES OR OTHER VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR. AND WE REALLY DO NEED
TO BUILD OUT A WHOLE NEW SYSTEM
OF CARE IF WE'RE GOING TO
EXPECT COUNTIES TO TAKE ON A
BROADER SEGMENT OF- BE
INJUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATION-
WE CAN PROVIDE SPECIALIZED
TRAINING WE CAN BUILD OUT THAT
EXTRA CAPACITY. BUT. TO A LARGE
DEGREE FOR THE VOLUME OF-
INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD BE ASKED
SERVE. THAT GOAL OR OF.
ORIENTED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THE
NOT A TODAY AGAIN ON A SCALE-
SO THOSE ARE OF THE HE- THAT
WE'RE LOOKING IN TERMS OF OUR
EXISTING CAPACITY TO THINK.
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL IS
FAIRLY WELL TIMED- AND WILL GO
A LONG WAY TO- STARTING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES IN THE MID TO LONG TERM
BUT IT HAVE TO BE FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH. TO BE TAILORED TO THE
REGIONAL LOCAL NEEDS AND GAPS
IN THE IN THIS CAPACITY- THERE
IS A SMALL POT OF FUNDING
WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WHICH IS AVAILABLE
FOR CAPITAL INVESTMENTS. BUT IT
COMPETES WITH FUNDING FOR
WORKFORCE AS WELL AS THE
EIGHTEEN WHICH ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND IT HAS TO BE
DIVERTED AWAY FROM THOSE CORE
FSP TYPE SERVICES THAT WE WERE
JUST SPEAKING TO- IF WE'RE
GOING TO APPLY IT AND SO-
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN NAVIGATING
ALL OF THESE SORT OF.
CATEGORICAL RESTRICTIONS AS
THEY ATTEMPTED TO PROVIDE THAT
FULL ARRAY OF SERVICES- WITH
RESPECT TO THE MATCH THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING I MUST
POINT OUT A BILL COMPELLED TO
POINT OUT CHAIR OF I'M GLAD.
THAT ME HAVE STRUGGLE TO FIND
ANY OTHER AREA WHERE- EARMARKED
FUNDING IS SO FREQUENTLY- AND
BE COLLECTED A MATCH AS FUNDS
WHICH ARE DIRECTED AT THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS. EVEN A LOCAL HOUSING
INITIATIVE- YOU KNOW THERE'S
SORT OF. A MATCH REQUESTED BUT
NOT REQUIRED THE SAME WAY THAT
IT IS WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND WE WOULD REALLY ASK
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT
APPARENTLY THERE- TWENTY THIRD
CERTAINLY GOING TO HAVE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO DO. AYE TUN CAN MAKE
THESE PROJECTS WHERE- AND HELP
ALREADY IN. SO MUCH OUT OF MY
CAL WE THAT THAT HIS OF AND
THAT HISTORIC IT MAKE TO BE
CLEANED- DID YOU TO WHICH VERY
NO COMPREHEND AND COMMON SET OF
INFORMATION ALSO ACROSS THE
VARIOUS SAFETY NET PLAYER
PAYER. AND SERVICES IN THE
FRUSTRATION WE UNDERSTAND IT
AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT THE STATE
DEVELOP A COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH STATE WIDE OUT CONTENT
PER FORM ANCE MEASURE-
INITIATIVE WHICH WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING CARE
ITEM BLOCKS- AS WETHINK THAT
THIS WILL ALSO SUPPORT THE
BROADER DATA WORK WHICH- WHICH
ISN'T. SO IMPORTANT HERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE L. A- COREY HOW SHE'D.
THANK YOU DR KOREAN SHEET AGAIN
WITH THE L. A. L. I'LL BE
GIVING COMMENTS ON ON THREE OF
THE ITEMS THAT THAT WERE UP FOR
DISCUSSION IN THIS PANEL FIRST-
THE STATE HOSPITALS CCD P.
DECK. THE NEXT THE DH CS
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL AND THEN- ALSO
BEGINNING SOME COMMENTS ON SOME
OF THE MEDICARE PROPOSAL SAYING
IN CALENDA DRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE HOMELESSNESS POPULATION- WE
PUBLISHED ANALYSES OF THESE
PROPOSALS ON OUR ON OUR WEBSITE
AND- IN ADDITION FOR CALLIN WE
HAVE THAT WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE
FORTHCOMING- THAT WILL BE-
RELATING SPECIFICALLY TO EQUITY
ISSUES AND CAL AIM AS WELL AS-
YOU KNOW A POST FOCUSED ON
ISSUES WITH THE- THE AGING
POPULATION KELLY. SO I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON SOME OF THE MAIN
POINTS THAT WE REYES AND IN
ALICE- SO FIRST FOR THE STATE
HOSPITAL CCTV. I'M WE ACTUALLY
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL- HOWEVER WE DO OFFER
SOME SORT OF SOME ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGIES TO ACHIEVE SOME OF
THE- GOALS OF THE PROPOSAL- THE
CCD PA ESSENTIALLY HAS TWO
GOALS ON THE FIRST IS TO MAKE.
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR FELONY ICY
TREATMENT AND TO PROVIDE A
FIXED AMOUNT- TO COUNTIES FOR
THEM TO PROVIDE SORT OF THE
COMPETENCY RESTORATION
TREATMENT OF FELONY ISD'S. THIS
IS. MAKE FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
COUNTY SO THAT THEY CAN INVEST
IN COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR PEOPLE ON THE FRONT END-
SORT OF BEFORE THEY EVEN
REACHED THE POINT WHERE I'M
THEY WOULD FIND THEMSELVES IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY WOULD BE
DECLARED. INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL- SO THAT THE RATE AT
WHICH PEOPLE ARE FOUND TO BE I.
ESTY DECREASES- BUT WHILE WE
DON'T RAISE ISSUES WITH THESE
OVERALL GOALS WE FIND THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT WELL STRUCTURED
TO ACHIEVE- SPECIFICALLY THE
GOAL ABOUT CATCHING PEOPLE ON
ON THE FRONT END BEFORE THEY-
ARE DECLARED. S. T. FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE THE FUNDING MECHANISM OF
THIS PROPOSAL MAKES WHETHER OR
NOT- THERE WILL BE AVAILABLE
FUNDS FOR COUNTIES TO INVEST IN
THESE COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH- SERVICES. ARE SUBJECT
TO CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY
AND- WE ALSO FIND THAT THE
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM ARE
ARE ARE ARE UNCLEAR- GIVEN
THESE CONCERNS- WE ARE
RECOMMENDING REJECTION OF THE
PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD DIRECTING
FUNDING- TOWARDS EXISTING STATE
HOSPITALS PROGRAMS FOR FELONY
ICY TREATMENT. I'M SURE THE
LEGISLATURE WISH TO PROVIDE
MORE FUNDING FOR THAT PURPOSE-
IN IN IN IN SOME. STRATEGIES
FOR SORT OF CATCHING
INDIVIDUALS ON THE FRONT END
BEFORE THEY SORT OF REACHED THE
POINT OF BEING FOUND I. S. T.
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION. ON
THIS PANEL ABOUT SORT OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN STATE
HOSPITALS IN INDIA H. THE GAS
AND- COUNTIES WITH THEIR AT
THIS P. PROGRAMS AND WE FIND
THAT THIS THIS COORDINATION AND
SORT OF- WORKING THIS
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO SORT
OF- TARGET. WHAT'S OUT THERE
AND WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET THAT
MORE DIRECTLY PERTAINS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR THIS
SPECIFIC POPULATION THE FOLKS
THAT ARE SORT OF- AT PARTICULAR
RISK OF BEING DECLARED IST-
WOULD OULD SORT OF BE A MORE
DIRECT WAY AT GETTING AT- YOU
KNOW THE OVERALL GOAL OF THE
PROPOSAL. AND WE THINK IT WOULD
BE A MORE EFFICIENT AND USER-
OF THE- STATE RESOURCE. I'M
CERTAIN. I WILL MOVE ON TO THE-
CONTINUE I'M INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL FOR DH CS- FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE SOME SUBSTANTIAL
DETAILS ON THAT REMAIN UNDER
DEVELOPMENT- THIS COULD INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT SPECIFIC
MILESTONES COUNTIES WOULD HAVE
TO MEET- IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
DISBURSEMENT OF FUNDS- OR HOW
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE EVALUATED-
SIMILARLY TO. THE ISSUE THAT-
L. A- RAISED EARLIER WITH THE
STUDENT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROPOSAL- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO INTENDS TO.
RELY ON BUDGET BILL FOR THIS
FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND- WE WOULD
SIMILARLY SUGGESTED TRAILER
BILL APPROACH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SORT OF HAS- YOU
KNOW SUFFICIENT IN COURT AND
SORT OF THE DESIGN OF. THE
GRANT PROGRAM- REGARDING THE
INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL WE AGREE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION WE
DON'T RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
CONCEPT OF. EXPANDING COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FACILITIES
AND TREATMENT CAPACITIES
CERTAINLY THIS IS A VERY
PRESSING- NEED ACROSS THE STATE
AND- WE ALSO FIND THAT THIS
THIS ONE TIME INVESTMENT IS. IS
LIKELY A GOOD USE OF THE STATE
SIGNIFICANT ONE FALL- ONE TIME
WINDFALL THAT IT HAS AT ITS
DISPOSAL- WE FIND THAT THERE IS
ENOUGH OVERLAP BETWEEN THIS.
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAM AND SOME
PRIOR. STATE GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT WERE. BASICALLY FOR ME
HEALTH FACILITIES- THERE WAS-
MENTION OF THE SB EIGHTY TWO
GRANT PROGRAM EARLIER AND- WE
FIND THAT THE THAT THE OVERLAP
BETWEEN THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM
AND THAT SORT OF PRIOR PROGRAM-
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO. APPLY LESSONS
LEARNED IN DOWN REALLY AVOID
SORT OF LIKE- CHALLENGES THAT
CAME UP WITH SOME OF THAT THE
PRIOR. PROGRAMS IN THIS AREA-
WE WOULD ALSO FLAG THAT THIS
PROPOSAL- AS MENTIONED ON THIS
AND THIS PANEL HAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT INTERACTIONS WITH A
COUPLE OF OTHER. MAJOR BUDGET
PROPOSALS FIRST- YOU KNOW AT IT
WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER THAT DAY
CALENDAR INCLUDES A COMMITMENT
TO PURSUE WHEN I AM THE WAY HER
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS FEDERAL
FUNDING- FOR SORT SERVICES IN
INSTITUTIONS THAT- NORMALLY
MEDICAID WON'T PAY FOR- AND IN
ORDER TO SORT OF GET THIS
WAIVER APPROVED THE STATE WOULD
HAVE TO. DEMONSTRATE A
COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
TREATMENT OPTIONS- AND THIS
PROPOSAL THAT THERE CONTINUE-
YOU KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL I'M COULD HELP THE
STATE SORT OF DEMONSTRATE BACK
IMAGE COMMITMENT FOR ITS WAIVER
OPPORTUNITY- AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO SORT OF
CONSIDER WHAT IT STANDS IS ON
THE- ACCOUNTING I AM THE WAIVER
COMMITMENT AND SORT OF WEIGH
THAT AGAINST THE- POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF. THIS PROPOSAL THAT
DAY- CONTINUE. INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM. IN A- THE- AND
AS AS A DISCUSS ON THIS CAN IS
PRETTY THIS PROPOSAL AS- PART
OF ITS OVERALL HOMELESSNESS
EFFORTS AND- WELL THERE'S
CERTAINLY OVERLAP BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND THOSE WITH
SIGNIFICANT. HEALTH NEEDS- WE
FIND THAT A TARGETING OF FUNDS
TO INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WOULD BE A MORE
SORT OF DIRECT WAY TO GET OUT-
BE MORE SORT OF DIRECT WAY TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S OVERALL-
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES. I'M AND
JUSTIN ARE MOVING ON TO CAL
AMEN SOME OF THE MEDIC HOW
PROPOSALS IN ALLEN FOR- YOU
KNOW HIGH RISK POPULATIONS AND
WE JUST HAVE SOME COMMENTS ON
THE- ECM IN IOS- PROPOSED NEW
BENEFITS AND CALAMP. ONE THING
WE'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT
WHILE MUCH OF CALIFORNIANS NEW-
MUCH OF CALLIN WOULD ALSO BUILD
ON OR ON REPLACE THE EXISTING
PROGRAM WHICH ALREADY SORT OF
PROVIDE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR- THE HOMELESSNESS
POPULATIONS OF FOR EXAMPLE THAT
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING. IMPLEMENTED IN
IN- SOME SELECT COUNTY
STATEWIDE- YOU KNOW HOWEVER
DOES NOT SORT OF JUST REFLECT A
CONTINUATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
BUT INSTEAD. REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO FINANCING
AND DELIVERING THE SERVICES
THAT TODAY ARE ON PROVIDED
UNDER EXISTING PROGRAMS SO FOR
EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW UNDER
CARRYING SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
AND RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED TO THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION- WOULD
BE CONCENTRATED SORT OF IN THE
MANAGED CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AS
OPPOSED TO- SORT OF THE
DELIVERY MODELS IN WHICH THEY
ARE CURRENTLY BEING PROVIDED-
WE ALSO FIND THAT CALTRAIN HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BRING MAJOR
POLICY BENEFITS. SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF SUCCESSFUL THE CM IN IOS
REFORMS COULD REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES BY FOCUSING
RESOURCES AND ATTENTION ON
MEDICARE'S HIGHEST RISK AND
HIGHEST NEED BENEFICIARIES
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- THAT
BEING SAID WE DO HAVE SOME.
OUTSTANDING YOU KNOW CONCERNS
TO RAISE ABOUT THESE COMPONENTS
OF CALLIE. ON THE CONCERNS
GENERALLY PERTAIN TO CALENDAR
THE CALENDAR PACKAGES THE
WHOLE- BUT THEY ALSO- YOU KNOW
ARE ARE LARGELY DRIVEN BY THE
ECM AND I LESS BENEFITS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE. THE START OF THE
MAJOR COMPONENTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FUNDING PLAN
FOR CALLIE- FIRST YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT DETAIL ON MAJOR
CALLIN COMPONENTS IS THAT'S
LACKING SORT WHICH SORT OF
LIMITS THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO FULLY. SCRUTINIZED
THE CHANGES PROPOSALS- SECOND
WE FIND THAT YOU KNOW CALTRAIN
GIVEN IT SCOPE AND COMPLEXITY
COMES WITH SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
RISK OVER THE LONGER TERM-
UNFORESEEN IMPLEMENTATION COSTS
COULD MATERIALIZE OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS AND- ANTICIPATING
STATE ANTICIPATED SAVINGS MIGHT
NOT MATERIALIZE QUICKLY ENOUGH
OR- AT SUFFICIENT LEVELS FOR
THE MULTI YEAR FUNDING PLAN TO
PROVE REASONABLE. ON THESE LONG
TERM FISCAL RISKS ARE
ESPECIALLY RELEVANT GIVEN THE
STATE BUDGET PROBLEM
ANTICIPATED TO RISE AFTER. ON
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO-
WE WOULD CALL WE JUST A FEW IS
FOR. ON THE MAJOR SORT OF
CALUMET CAL REFORMS FIRST YOU
KNOW WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE USED TO BUDGET AND
POLICY PROCESS TO RESOLVE SORT
OF KEY OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL. AND TO
PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE INPUT INTO
ANY CALENDAR COMPONENTS THAT
ARE ULTIMATELY ADOPTED- SECOND
GIVEN THE SCOPE OF CALLIN THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES THE
STATE- IS LIKELY TO FACE AS WE
WILL HOPEFULLY EXIT THE
PANDEMIC- WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE EXPLORE WHERE WHERE
DELAYS AND STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION AND-
IMPLEMENTATION AREN'T BY THE
BALL- IN THIRD TO ENSURE CALLIN
IS. SORT OF ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S GOALS WE RECOMMEND
ESTABLISHING ROBUST RECOMMENCE.
MECHANISMS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OVERSIGHT AND PROGRAM
EVALUATION- SO THAT THAT SORT
OF CONCLUDES L. A. O.'S
COMMENTS ON THIS- ON. THIS
PANEL AND- THANK YOU. THANK
VERY MUCH- I WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DíAS I WAS GOING TO
USE THIS. TIME TO INFORM THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO LATER BE
HEARING ABOUT CAL AIM BUT- I
WILL SAVE THAT COMMENTS FOR
MYSELF. I'M I WILL FOCUS ON
THREE QUESTIONS FIRST I AM
GOING TO- WANTS TO DISCUSS THE
FELONY ISD'S. I WANT TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HISTORICALLY
WHY THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A MISDEMEANOR I S. T.
AND A FELONY I S. T. AND WHY WE
DON'T HAVE PARITY IN THAT SPACE.
IS ANYONE OUT ABLE TO EXPLAIN
WHY THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO. EXPLANATION
JUST THAT IT IT HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY- THE MAN THE
MISDEMEANOR I IS HE'S BEEN WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE- I
COUNTIES AND THE FELONY IDEAS
TO USE IN THE TREATMENT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN THE-
RESPONSIBILITY OF STATE. WHY
THAT IS I DON'T KNOW. THEN IN
THAT LIGHT I'D LIKE TO RETURN
TO TOBY EWING IF I COULD
REGARDING- THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS- DURING THE
DESCRIPTION OR THE RIGHT UP IT
SAYS THAT THESE HEALTH SERVICES
ARE FOR THE UNDERSERVED FOR- OR
PREVIOUSLY UNDERSERVED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WITH VERY
HIGH NEEDS AND WITH SERIOUS AND
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS I BELIEVE
THAT WOULD ENCAPSULATE THE
FELONY I S. T. IS AND- WANTS TO
GET YOUR UNDERSTANDING WHY YOU
BELIEVE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
EXCLUDED THUS FAR FROM THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS. MISTER
EWING. PARDON ME I DIDN'T HAVE
J. C. TO TELL ME THAT I'M YET
MY- SO- SO APOLOGIES FOR THAT
I'M- SO TO CLARIFY THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP IS THE
COMMUNITY BASED CARE AND THE M.
BECAUSE THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
A CRIME THE STATE THIS IS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND THERE ARE
OTHERS HERE ON THE PANEL OF OUR
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA AND I AM
ON THE DETAILS. NO THEY ARE
DIRECTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS FOR TREATMENT
SO THAT THEIR COMPETENCY CAN BE
CAN BE RESTORED. IN CONTRAST MY
COMMENTS ARE ON THE FOSTERS
PARTNERSHIP IS THAT NO PRIOR.
TO THE FELONY ARREST. M. AND
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO MISDEMEANOR
ARRESTS THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP OPTION. IS HOW WE
DESIGN CARE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THESE VERY HIGH LEVELS OF NEED.
AND WHAT IS. SHOCKING IN SOME
WAYS IS LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE VERY WELL KNOWN TO OUR
COMMUNITY SYSTEMS BECAUSE OF
THE NUMBER OF ARRESTS THAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED. THAT IS
OUTLINED IN THE WORK THAT THE
PROPER STATE HOSPITAL HAS HAS
SHARED IN THE PAST- THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY RECEIVING THE FULL
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY BASED CARE.
SO THE FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE PRESSURE
OFF OF THESE SYSTEMS THE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE IS HOW CAN WE
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEMS
HOW CAN WE SUPPORT. THOSE
STRATEGIES ON THE PART OF
COUNTIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DELIVERING FULL SERVICE
CARE SERVICES IN WAYS THAT ARE
COST EFFECTIVE. AND THESE
BECOME PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE ARE
CYCLING THROUGH HOSPITALS JAILS
AND THE STREETS. M. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR FAR FOR
FOSTERS PARTNERSHIPS IT MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH. THE QUESTION FOR THE
STATE REALLY SHOULD LOOK AT
WHETHER THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP OPPORTUNITY IS A
BETTER ALTERNATIVE. BOTH IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CARE IN A VOLUNTARY
MANNER. KEEPING PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES KEEPING PEOPLE IN
SERVICES FOR WHICH THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL MATCHING
OFTENTIMES NOT ALWAYS BE
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED. ANY
IF THEY ACTUALLY. LOWER OUR
LONG TERM COSTS. N ADDITION TO
THAT WITH OUR THAT THE STATE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE THINKING EVEN
FARTHER UPSTREAM. HOW CAN WE
DELIVER CARE THROUGH PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION SO WE
DON'T EVEN NEED AS MANY FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP SLOTS. I'M
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
FINDING IN TALKING TO OTHER
STATES YES THEY'RE TYING
TOGETHER THEIR EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE VERY EARLY IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF US SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. WITH THEIR
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES OTHER STATES ARE
ARGUING THAT BECAUSE PSYCHOSIS
TENDS TO START IN THE TEEN
YEARS FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE. THAT
SCHOOLS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
GATEWAYS TO ACCESS TO
SUPPORTING PEOPLE TO ENTER INTO
SERVICES SO THEY DON'T BECOME.
SEVERELY AND PERSISTENTLY
MENTALLY ILL MENTALLY ILL AND
HOMELESS AND INVEST BECOME AT
HIGH RISK FOR MULTIPLE ARRESTS
AT HIGH RISK FOR FELONY CHARGES
AND IT HIGHER BEST HIGH RISK
OR- STATE HOSPITALIZATION. IT'S
NOT THE FOLKS THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH THE STATE HOSPITALS AREN'T
ELIGIBLE FOR A FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP WE- THEY MAY BE
PRIOR TO THEIR ARREST. IN ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS YOU WANT TO
UNDERSTAND IS ARE THOSE
PROGRAMS WORKING EFFECTIVELY AS.
THEY CAN AND HOW DO WE HELP
STRENGTHEN. THIS SO ALONG THOSE
LAWS IT LOOKS. I KEEP I'M GOING
TO STICK ON THESE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I FOUND THIS ISSUE
PARTICULARLY FAXING OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND- I'M REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND DIG
INTO THIS ONE DATA POINT WHICH
IS THAT. 50% OF THE I. S.
FELONY I S. T. POPULATION DID
NOT GET TREATMENT SIX MONTHS
PRIOR TO THEIR ARREST. AND SO
IF THAT'S THE CASE MY
UNDERSTANDING THEN WOULD BE
THAT THEY MOST LIKELY WERE
GETTING MISDEMEANOR. ARRESTS
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNDER FELONY
ARE THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS AND I'M WONDERING
WHAT. WAS LACKING WITHIN THAT-
THAT CARE THAT LED TOWARDS THE-
SUBSEQUENT FELONY ARREST AND I
THINK THE PART THAT I'M- I'VE
STRUGGLED WITH THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS IS THE DISK JOINTED.
ASPECT OF THIS. CARE AND I'M
WONDERING WHY WE AREN'T
STREAMLINING IT AND WHY WE
DON'T HAVE A- MORE- WHOLISTIC
APPROACH TO CARING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL TIME I GUESS NOW
MY QUESTION IS FOR DR KELLY TO
PULL YOU IN AND SEE IF I CAN
HAVE YOU COMMENT ON- THIS
DISCUSSION AT THIS TIME. SURE
THANK YOU TO RAMBLE WELL I
THINK FIRST OF ALL THERE
THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION BEING
MADE THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN.
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL AS A MEDICARE BENEFICIARY
SO THERE'S BACK NUMBER ONE-
ALSO WE ARE SERVING EVERYONE IN
COMMUNITY BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE AND I'M SURE OUR
PARTNERS DISH WILL HAVE MORE.
LEGAL INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
I'M GOING TO STATE BUT AT LEAST
SOMEONE IS FOUND TO BE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL THAT
MEANS THEY'RE THEY'RE CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS STOPS THEY HAVE AN
EVALUATION TO DETERMINE THEIR
COMPETENCY AND THEN THEY ARE
EITHER- THERE ARE A COUPLE. OF
COMPETENCY CAN BE RESTORED
WHETHER IT'S IN CUSTODY AT THE
JAIL SYSTEM LIKE WHAT WE HAVE
IN OUR COUNTY- AT OUR WEBSITE
DETENTION CENTER OR- THEY COULD
BE DEPENDING. ON A LOT OF
THINGS- PLACED AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL FOR THE RESTORATION OF
THEIR COMPETENCY BUT ONCE THE
COMPETENCIES RESTORING THE
IDEAS THEY WOULD GO BACK. THE
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING IS NOT
SHOUT ON THE CRIME MIGHT HAVE
STILL YOU KNOW STILL STILL
EXISTED SO IT'S THE PROCESS
THERE WE CERTAINLY SERVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON PAROLE OR PROBATION
WHO'VE COMMITTED CRIMES. AND
THIS IS BRINGING. DIFFICULTY
LIES FOR US IS- EVEN LOOKING AT
DIVERSION DIVERSION MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION FROM OUR
SECURE COURTS PERSPECTIVE. IS
IF THEY SEE SOMEONE WHO HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH- RELATIONSHIP TO
THE CRIME AND THEY CAN DIVERT
THEM FROM THE COURT PROCEEDINGS
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO. INTO
A JAIL SYSTEM AND THEY CAN THEN
BE. RECEIVED AND TREATMENT WITH
US- AND THERE'S NO FUNDING FOR
THAT THERE'S THE REGULAR
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE TOO MANY
CAL IF THE PERSON BEING
REFERRED TO AS A MEDIC CAL
BENEFICIARY SOMETIMES THEY ARE
NOT. SO ADD TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
IT BEING A DESPERATE SYSTEM
EIGHT IT IS THAT I THINK THAT'S
WHY HAVING THIS SORT OF A
HEARING TO TALK WITH ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS AT THE SAME TIME IS
VERY BENEFICIAL I WOULD LIKE
TO. TRANSPACIFIC TO THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS TO
I'M SURE CHRIS IS ON I CAN SEE
HER- I HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT PARTICULAR QUESTION DOCTOR
AND- WOULD LOVE TO POLARON
MISFEASANCE. SHE WIRING- WHY
I'M- MY PERSONAL. M. I MEAN I
KIND OF THINK THAT SHE STEM
FROM SORT OF THREE DIFFERENT
SONGS- ONE EIGHT ONE IS
CAPACITY THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEEDS- MORE ALTERNATIVES TO
DIVERT INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING CRISIS RATHER THAN
PUTTING THEM IN JAIL. AND I
THINK THAT THEY WROTE HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL. AS
WELL AS US-AS A AS AN
ADMINISTRATION AS A STATE
SOMETHING THAT I. N. G. WAIVER-
FROM THE EXCLUSION ARM ARE
GOING TO BASICALLY AND-
EXPANDED OUR ABILITY AT THESE
OPTIONS- ARM. TO AND I THINK
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECE OF IT IS BACK
AYE ISSUE CONTENT COMMITMENT IS
ONE OF THE ONLY PATHWAYS TO
COMPEL. OR RATHER FORCE SOMEONE
IN. AN ORDER THEM INTO
TREATMENT. RIGHT- AND CAN WE
LOOK OTHER STRAT. ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT WILL TO REDUCE
THE LIKE. OF SOMEONE EXCUSE A
MENTAL THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
LEAD TO THAT. SO HOW DO WE GET
TO THAT PLACE RIGHT AND THEN
THE OTHER PIECE THAT WE'VE JUST
BEEN HEARING- FROM THE PARTNERS
THAT WILL WORKING WITH.
DIVERSION IS REALLY HAVING AN
ADEQUATELY TRAINED TO WORK
TOWARDS- THOSE THAT ARE TRAINED
ON THE INTERVENTIONS AND
STRATEGIES TO EFFECTIVELY WORK
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THAT'S REALLY. YOU
KNOW- THAT'S ASSESSING RISK
THAT IS INCORPORATING
STRATEGIES TO MITIGATE THAT
RISK AS PART OF THEIR OVERALL
HOLISTIC TREATMENT PLANS SO
WORKING AT WORK. WORK
INCREMENTALLY- TACKLING NASRI
BUT THEY'VE REGION AND THEN
ALSO WHAT PROPOSING YOUR SEATS.
HE. BY YOU KNOW IT'S MY- SALT
THAT. THAT PROGRAMS LIKE THE
FULL SERVICE FOR. CAN BE FOR
POPULATION BUT I THINK THE IS-
AND TOTAL. THAT IT WAS ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS VERSUS WHAT THE
I. S. T. MEDNAX WHERE IS THAT
ABILITY TO COMPEL AND FORCE
TREATMENT- WHICH WE DON'T LIKE
TO SAY FORCED BUT IT IT IS IT
IS- IT IS THAT LEGAL MECHANISM.
MINUTE MECHANISM THAT IS
REQUIRING THAT INDIVIDUAL TO
RECEIVE TREATMENT I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
COMPETENCY RESTORATION IS
REALLY NOTHING MORE FROM OUR
ARMED STANCE. IS DESTABILIZING
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT IS- ON
EXPERIENCING ON OUR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS RIGHT STABILIZING
THAT INDIVIDUAL BEGINNING I'M
ON THE RIGHT MEDICATION
STABILIZING THEM AND THEN
TEACHING THEM YOU KNOW A FEW
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO DO IN
ORDER TO AFFECTED WILL STAND
TRIAL ALL. BUT ONCE THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS STABILIZED IN
WHATEVER ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
THEY COULD THEN BE REVOKED AT
AND CONSIDERED FOR DIVERSION OR
OTHER. SORT OF LOWER LEVEL
SERVICES IN THE- I'M GOING
BRING. IT'S TOBY YOU IN BUT I
WANT TO FOLLOW WITH A QUESTION
SEAT AND CAN AND- I DIDN'T READ
THE NEW ONE THAT HAVE ONLY PER
COUNTY AND NOT ALL CAN THAT
WOULD BE- GOING THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT AND SO
WAS HOPING YOU COULD ELABORATE
A LITTLE MORE ON SCALE AND
PRIORITIZATION FOR COUNTIES. AT
THIS TIME. SURE YEAH WE YES WE
ARE DEFINITELY ONLY PROPOSING-
TO WORK WITH A HANDFUL OF
COUNTIES. WE SERVE OUR MORNING
LOW BASIS I THINK WE'RE OVER
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED PER YEAR AND
WE ARE ONLY PROPOSING TO SERVE
THIS PROPOSAL UP TO TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO- BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE
COUNTIES IDENTIFIED NEED MODELS
ARE FUNDING ESTIMATE AND OUR
POPULATION ESTIMATE. ON A
SAMPLING OF TOWNIES THAT
REPRESENT KIND OF. A DIVERSE
GEOGRAPHIC. ARRAY OF. AS WELL
AS REP- SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE
SIZED COUNTIES- AND SO- WELL I
CAN'T NAME ALL OF THE FAMILIES
WE ARE WORKING WITH- WE HAVE
ASKED FOR TWO MINUTES BY THE
END OF MARCH AT THE LATEST SO
THAT WE CAN- DISCLOSE WHO THOSE
KINDS ARE BY AND BY THE TIME
AND LOCATION. WITHOUT A LIKE
TO- PULL TOBY PLEASE. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. YOU KNOW I WON TO
ADD THAT THE QUESTION YOU ASKED
REALLY IS THE ANALYSIS THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO CALL FOR. THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS IN
SOME PHENOMENAL WORK AND OPEN
THE DOOR ON THIS I THINK IT WAS
DR WARBURTON ARE A PART OF HER
TEAM THAT REALLY HIGHLIGHTED
THAT PERCENTAGE THAT YOU
REFERENCED AND SO THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE SERIES OF QUESTIONS HERE
AND WE ARE WORKING WITH COUNTY
USED TO DO THAT ANALYSIS I'M IN
A IN I THINK TEN COUNTIES WHERE
WE ARE HELPING THEM CONNECT
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH DATA AND
THEIR CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA.
BUILDING OFF OF THIS
DIFFERENTIAL INTERCEPT MODEL
AROUND VERSION SO THAT WE DON'T
WAIT UNTIL THERE ARE FIFTEEN
ARRESTS AND WE'RE ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ARE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE INFO SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE NOT ARE WE
DELIVERING COMMUNITY BASED CARE
IN A WAY THAT IS VOLUNTARY SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO MOVE TO A
CRIMINAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STRATEGY OR- AT A STATE
HOSPITAL KIND OF STRATEGY WHERE
IDEAS ABOUT COMPETENCY
RESTORATION. I'M BUT WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT ANALYSIS STATEWIDE
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT ANALYSIS
AS THOROUGHLY AS NEEDS TO
HAPPEN SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN MOVE
LIMITED DOLLARS FROM VERY
EXPENSIVE THE BAND CARE TWO
MORE FLEXIBLE AFFORDABLE MORE
VOLUNTARY PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION CARE AND AGAIN I
KNOW I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE
CAN TAKE PEOPLE OUT OF THE
STATE HOSPITAL TODAY THIS IS
MORE ABOUT HOW DO WE- MOVE OUR
RESPONSE TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HIGH END NEEDS. TO EARLY STAGES
RIGHT IF WE WERE TO USE A
CANCER ANALOGY WHAT'S ON THE
TABLE IS BUILDING MORE CANCER
WARDS RATHER THAN SAYING HOW DO
WE PREVENT AND INTERVENE EARLY
SO WE NEED LESS OF THESE HIGH
AND THE PRESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
AND AT THE MOMENT WE NEED BOTH
M. BUT THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE ANALYSIS.
AT EACH COUNTY LEVEL- AND
COUNTIES THAT IN TURN PASSED
BUT MANY DOWN. AND THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE THE STATE REALLY CAN
SUPPORT OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
TO TRACK POPULATIONS THROUGH
THE SYSTEMS AND IDENTIFY THE
AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR INTERVENTIONS.
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
USE DOLLARS MORE EFFECTIVELY
PARTICULARLY IF WE CAN PARTNER
WITH BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ENTERS A MEDIC CAL.
AND THE AND THE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE SECTOR SO I DON'T WE
DON'T KNOW THE PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE PRIVATE
SECTOR INSURANCE WHO NEED THESE
THIS LEVEL OF CARE. BUT IN THE
WORK THAT WE'RE SEEING AROUND
EARLY PSYCHOSIS IS QUITE OFTEN
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE INSURANCE BUT
AS THEIR NEEDS ESCALATE THEY
OFTEN DROP OFF OF THEIR
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE. AND THOSE
COST SHIFT OVER TO THE PUBLIC
SECTOR THAT'S AN AREA THAT
NEEDS FURTHER EXPLORATION- WITH
THAT I WILL TABLE THE-
QUESTIONS AND- APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENTED I DO KNOW WANTS TO
FOCUS ON- DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE.
INVESTMENT AND- I WILL JUST
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS SO WE CAN
HAVE THE I AM DEEP WAVER AND-
WANTS TO PUT IN THE LEGISLATURE.
VALUES INTO ASKING- FOR. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A LENDS
TOWARDS EQUITY AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT- THERE WERE
INVESTMENTS TO HELP TO PROTECT
OUR FOSTER YOUTH- WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE- REQUEST OF
DH CS AND SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON HOW WE CAN ENSURE
THOSE FUNDS- GOES TO THOSE
TARGETED POPULATIONS FIRST AND
SECOND WAS HOPING YOU COULD
COMMENT ON MACHEL CABRERA'S
COMMENTS REGARDING-
DIFFICULTIES WITH CERTAIN
COUNTIES AND SEE IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THE FLEXIBILITY ISSUES
AND NECESSITY FOR HAVING THAT-
TWENTY PERCENT. CAN YOU HAVE.
SO I THINK WE WOULD- DEFINITELY
AGREE WITH YOU IN REGARDS TO
CONSIDERING BOTH EQUITY AND
FOSTER YOUTH CONNECTIONS WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS I
THINK. AS WE- ALSO HAVE
INCLUDED A NUMBER OF R. KELLY
PROPOSALS THE NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT FOSTER YOUTH ARE GETTING
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN CONNECTION
TO THE FULL CONTINUUM IS REALLY
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE.
PARTNERING AND WORKING WITH
OUR- DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICE COLLEAGUES- RIGHT NOW
IN REGARDS TO YOU- FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WERE OTHERWISE SENT OUT OF
STATE- IN OUR COUNTIES HAVE
REALLY STEPPED UP IN REGARDS TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES.
ATTENDED THE VERY UNIQUE AND
COMPLEX NEEDS OF THOSE OF
FOSTER YOUTH AND CHILDREN- AND
SO I THINK WE WILL DEFINITELY
KEEP IN MIND HOW FOSTER YOUTH
CAN BE A BETTER SERVED THROUGH
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. A DOLLARS AS
WELL AS ENSURING THAT WE ARE
FOCUSING ON EQUITY GAPS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE CAN DEFINITELY
PUT THAT YOU'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON OUR EQUITY ROAD MAP
RIGHT NOW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
A CORE COMPONENT. OF THAT WORK
IN WILL DEFNITELY KEEP THAT IN
MIND. AS WE ARE LOOKING AT
THOSE THAT THOSE PIECES- IN
REGARDS TO A MISS COOPER'S
COMMENTS EARLIER REGARDING THE
25% LOCAL MATCH- I THINK WE ARE
VERY WILLING- AND REQUESTED
BOTH FROM C. SACK AND CBH DA.
WHAT ARE THE VARIOUS TYPES OF
PIECES THEY WOULD LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER FOR THE
LOCAL MATCH- AND WE WILL
PARTNER CLOSELY WITH THEM ON
THAT GIVEN THE- HISTORIC
RESPONSIBILITY OF COUNTY IN.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES WITH
THE COUNTY AS WE DO I FEEL LIKE
THE LOCAL MATCH IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL- AND
JUST REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH COUNTIES- AT ITS
YOU ULTIMATELY MAKE THAT WORK
AND SO. AGAIN OPEN TO THE
FLEXIBILITY THERE AND I KNOW
I'M POTS THAT WILL GET US
FEEDBACK WE CAN. IN REGARDS
THAT. I WILL JUST END BY-
REALLY THANKING APPRECIATING
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR- IN LIEU
OF SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
ENHANCED CARE BENEFITS WE HAVE
BEEN. WORKING AND ADVOCATING
FOR. HELP WITH SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND
REALLY BELIEVE THESE TWO
BENEFITS TAKE US A LONG WAY
TOWARDS- FINDING EQUITY AND
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE TO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK IN THIS
SPACE. WITH THAT WILL- THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL FOR AND MOVE ON
TO OUR FINAL PANEL ON THE MEDIC
CAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS- WE WILL HAVE FIVE
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL WILL
HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END.
PLEASE BEGIN. ALL RIGHT- SO I'M
GONNA START WITH GOING OVER A
FEW OF THE CALLIN PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVEN'T MENTIONED TODAY
I'LL BE BRIEF BECAUSE I DO KNOW
WE HAVE THE OTHER CALLIE. BUT
HEARINGS- THE PERSON REALLY HAS
TO DO WITH PAYMENT REFORM I DCS
IS PROPOSING TO TRANSITION FROM
A COST BASED REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY Q. A FEE SCHEDULE
OF REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY
AND THIS WILL REALLY HELP
REMOVE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THAT THE
COUNTIES FACED. REGARDS TO COST
BASED AUDITING REQUIREMENTS AS
WELL AS UNCERTAINTY WITH
ASSOCIATED FINAL COST RICK
RECONCILIATION AND
DOCUMENTATION ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE FACED IN THE PAST- IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH THIS A
PAYMENT RATE WE WILL HAVE TO
TRANSITION THE COUNTIES TO- AT
WHAT'S CALLED HEALTHCARE COMMON
PROCEDURE CODING SYSTEM OR TAKE
PIC. OF LEVEL ONE CODES- FOR
CERTAIN PROCEDURES AND CPT
CODES WHEN POSSIBLE WHICH WILL
ALSO IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO
LOOK AT VARIOUS HEALTH
OUTCOMES. AND THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES WITH FUTURE
REPORTING SO IT'S A IT'S A
DOUBLE POSITIVE THERE- THE
PROPOSAL WILL ALSO A GROUP NANA
REGIONAL OR PEER GROUPINGS FOR
THE RATE SETTING PURPOSES.
WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
GRANULARITY- IN DH CS REYES
SETTING AS WELL AS EQUITABLE
PAYMENTS TO COUNTIES. AND SO
IMPORTANT FACTOR THERE. ON THE
NEXT FOR- WITHIN KELLY HIS
AROUND THIS. AND ALSO QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE KEY CHANGES
AROUND MEDICAL NECESSITY IT
REALLY HELPS CLARIFY THE
DIVISION OF RESPONSIBILITY
BETWEEN MANAGED CARE AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS. AS WELL AS
CLARIFIED IN A VERY COMPONENTS
FOR THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I'M INCLUDING ENSURING
EASY ACCESS- FOR CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA.
HOMELESSNESS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM- FINE VARIOUS
EPS D. T. SERVICES AND
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT-
SERVICES. IT ALSO IS FOCUSING
ON ENSURING BENEFICIARIES CAN
ACCESS TREATMENT WHILE THEY ARE
BEING ASSESSED FOR DIAGNOSIS OF
PRIOR TO DIAGNOSIS. AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTING STANDARDIZED
SCREENING- IN TRANSITION TOOLS
TO ENSURE BENEFITS YEARS YOU'RE
GETTING. CARE QUICKLY AND
RELIABLY THERE IS A NO WRONG
DOOR IN TREATMENTS CO- WITH CO
OCCURRING DISORDERS AS WELL AS
CLARIFYING OUTPATIENT AND
INPATIENT MEDICAL NECESSITY
DEFINITIONS- IMPROVING THE DRUG
MEDI CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND LASTLY STREAMLINING
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ALIGN WITH MEDICAL CARE- AND
REDUCING- BURDENS ON PROVIDERS.
OF COURSE KEEPING IN MIND THE
UNIQUENESS OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE ALSO
ARE PUTTING FORWARD A PROPOSAL
AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTEGRATION- APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WITH THIS
YEAR IS MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS
ALSO HAVE A CO OCCURRING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER- AND
THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD REALLY
BENEFIT FROM INTEGRATED-TREATMENT WHERE WE CAN
IDENTIFY. THE STATE OF COVERS
OF MEDICAL AS YOU DEMAND
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THREE SEPARATE COUNTY
CONTRACTS TODAY- WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR COUNTIES TO
CONTRACT WITH PROVIDERS AND
OFFER INTEGRATED TREATMENT WHEN
A PROVIDER IS ABLE AND WILLING
TO PROVIDE. INTEGRATED AS
TREATMENT FOR CO OCCURRING
DISORDERS. OF FOR EXAMPLE
COUNTIES ARE SUBJECT TO TWO
SEPARATE ANNUAL QUALITY
ASSESSMENTS TO SEPARATE HOST
PAYMENT CHART AUDITS- INTO
SEPARATE REIMBURSEMENT COST
REPORTING METHODOLOGIES. IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE
SEPARATE- PROCESS THESE
PROVIDERS OFFERING INTEGRATED
TREATMENT TO A MEDICARE
BENEFICIARY MUST DOCUMENT- S.
U. D. TREATMENT ARMED SERVICES
SEPARATELY FROM MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT SERVICES. ALSO THE
PROPOSAL REALLY IS AROUND
STREAMLINING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS FOR BOTH THE S. U. D.
N. SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- THE BUDGET PROPOSES
TO ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENT OVER A
FIVE YEAR ROAD MAP THIS IS NOT
A SHORT LIVED- HERE. IN ORDER
FOR US TO HAVE A SINGLE
CONTRACT BY. TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN IS THE PROPOSAL. THE
DEPARTMENT ALL PUT FORWARD A
NUMBER OF IDNS ODS REFORMS ARE
WITHIN THE- PROPOSAL
ELIMINATING THE TUESDAY ANNUAL
LIMIT FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT. CLARIFYING THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR RECOVERY
SERVICES ARE REQUIRING ALL
FACILITIES TO OFFER- OR REFER
FOR MEDICATION TREES AT YOUR
ASSISTED TREATMENT. I'M TO ADD
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR
YOUTH UNDER TWENTY ONE AB
CULTURALLY DEFINED SERVICES AND
NATURAL HEALER FOR A BENEFIT
FOR INDIAN HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS IMPLEMENT
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT SERVICES
CLARIFY MEDICAL NECESSITY AS I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY AS WELL AS
OTHER VERY. NEAR TECHNICAL
UPDATES. THE DEPARTMENT IS ALSO
PUT FORWARD A PROPOSAL AROUND
DRUG MEDI CAL PARITY ARE THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO REVIEW
OUR PARITY ON A REGULAR BASIS
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PARITY ACT-
AND SO WE HAVE PUT FORWARD SOME
RECOMMENDED CHANGES FOR OUR
DRUG MEDI CAL COUNTIES.
INCLUDING ALIGNING GRIEVANCES
AND APPEAL PROCESS PROCESS
EASIER FOR BENEFICIARIES WHEN
THEY ARE DENIED SERVICES WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE IMPLEMENTING AND
NOTICE OF ADVERSE BENEFIT
DETERMINATION WE WOULD RE
REQUIRING DNC STATE PLAN
COUNTIES ARE NOW. REQUIRED TO
CREDENTIAL ALL OF THEIR-
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS AS WELL AS
PROVIDE A PROVIDER DIRECTORY-
SO- I'M A DMCA YES THE NC STATE
PLAN COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE A
CLOSE NETWORK OF PROVIDERS- AND
BENEFICIARIES RESIDING AT
COUNTY CAN RECEIVE DNC STATE
PLAN SERVICES FROM ANY
CERTIFIED. TNCS THE PLAN
PROVIDER HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
COMPLY WITH PARITY WE DO
STRONGLY FEEL THAT COUNTY
SHOULD CREATE AND PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THEIR COUNTY
A PROVIDER DIRECTORY ESPECIALLY
TO ALLOW FOR EASY ACCESS IN
SEARCHING FOR- SERVICES
AVAILABLE AND CLOSE TO THEM
WHICH WE DO THINK IT'S A BRIGHT
BENEFITS YOUR SHOULD HAVE.
WHICH MEANS THE NEXT ONE IT'S
REALLY AROUND LOOKING AT
NETWORK ADEQUACY FOR DMC-
COUNTY STILL BE VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THE WAY IT WORKS IN THE
MANAGED CARE COUNTIES BECAUSE
IT IS B. FOR SERVICE BUT
ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES CLOSE TO
THEIR HOME IS CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT SOMETHING WE WOULD BE.
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH THAT PARITY
PROPOSAL. OUR NEXT- IN REGARD
TO THE WORK ON- THE ENACT OF
SENATE. EIGHT OH THREE DH CS IS
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST AS A
DISTINCT MEDICARE PROVIDER
TYPE. COUNTIES OR AN ENTITY
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WILL CERTIFY THE PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE ACS STANDARDS- BY JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY ONE DH CS WELL
ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE
REQUIREMENTS FOR PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST- CERTIFICATION FOR
OUR PARTICIPATING COUNTIES- DH
CS HAS BEEN. CONDUCTING
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT REGARDING THIS
EFFORT WITH COUNTIES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATIONS APPEAR
ASSOCIATIONS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES. AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC- DH CS HAS ALSO BEEN
CONDUCTING LISTENING SESSIONS
WHICH ARE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AS
WELL. AND LASTLY I DO USE YES
RECOGNIZES THAT CALIFORNIA
FACES OF WORKFORCE CHALLENGES.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A SINGLE
WORKFORCE STRATEGY A 2% TODAY
WE HAVE SEVERAL STRATEGIES THAT
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING IN PLACE
TO SUPPORT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. I'M NOTABLY THE ONE
THAT I JUST WALK THROUGH OF A
REGARDING THE MEDIGAP HERE'S
EXPANSION DO YOU THINK THAT
WILL BE A GREAT DEVELOPMENT
REGARDS TO EXPANDING ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
WHICH WOULD BE ROLLED OUT IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWO. AND THEN
AGAIN MENTIONED EARLIER-
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PAYMENT REFORMS WHICH WILL GIVE
COUNTIES MORE FLEXIBILITY. FOR
PROVIDER PAYMENT AND REMOVE
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE BURDEN
SUMMER CHOIR MATES FOR COST
REPORTING AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR FAR TOO LONG. I SO WE
ARE WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
REFORMS IN THOSE AREAS AND
REALLY WORK I HOPE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND THAT. IS THE END
OF MY COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT HEAR FROM DR K.
ARAMBULA. SO WE WANT TO FIRST
OF ALL LIKE TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION ON CAL AMOS C.
B. H. J. IS STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROPOSALS AND CAL AIM.
INCLUDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PAYMENT REFORM MEDICAL
NECESSITY REFORMS MENTAL HEALTH
AND S. U. D. INTEGRATION AND OF
COURSE THE I AM D. WAIVER FOR
ADULT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND TAKEN TOGETHER WE REALLY
BELIEVE. THAT THESE REFORMS
WILL LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
OVERDUE SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
AND TRANSFORMATION. WE'RE ALSO
DEEPLY GRATEFUL TO DH CS. EVER
THEIR CONSISTENT ONGOING
EFFORTS TO ENGAGE WITH THAT CAN
BE HAVE A HALL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS FOR
INPUT ON THESE PROPOSALS. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE VALUABLE DELIVERY SYSTEM
REFORMS WE DO EMPHASIZE THAT IT
WILL BE CRITICAL. TO RETAIN THE
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. AND THIS
INVESTMENT WILL SUPPORT
SUCCESSFUL AND SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF PAYMENT
REFORM AND MEDICAL NECESSITY
PROPOSALS THAT REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
THEIR FISCAL AND IT SYSTEMS. I
BECAUSE COUNTY BEER HELP CANNOT
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT IN EXCESS
OF THE COST OF SERVICE DELIVERY
WE DO NOT MAINTAIN LARGE
OPERATING RESERVES AND WE HAVE
ONLY VERY LIMITED FUNDING OR
CAPITAL. IMPROVEMENTS AVAILABLE
TO THEM AND JUST SAY SO
CONSEQUENTLY UNLIKE THE MANAGED
CARE PLAN PARTNERS WE HAVE NO
MONEY SET ASIDE TO INVEST IN
THE TYPES OF SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL. BE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT CAL
AIMED. AT PRESENT COUNTIES MUST
OBSERVE A SERIES OF HIGHLY
RIGID AND PRESCRIPTIVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR REIMBURSEMENT
OF NEARLY ALL OF OUR SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH AND- SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES AND THESE
REQUIREMENTS. FOR REIMBURSEMENT
ARE ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
I'M NOT CLIENT CENTRED AND
ALMOST CERTAINLY HINDER ACCESS
AND EFFORTS TO IMPROVE HEALTH
EQUITY. THERE'S NO COMPARABLE
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE FOR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES THAT
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS. I HAVE
TO MEET SETTING THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH BAR FOR
ACCESS TO SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND BE ABLE
HEALTH SERVICES HAS BEEN
STIGMATIZING AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO THE GOAL
OF IMPROVING ACCESS. TO CARE-
OFTEN IT TAKES MULTIPLE VISITS.
ADD TO GET TASKS AND DIAGNOSIS
DONE ON THE PHYSICAL HEALTH
CARE SIDE- BUT OUR PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE PARTNERS GET PAID
AND I CAN- GET PAID
IMMEDIATELY. WE DON'T WE NEED A
DIAGNOSIS THAT SOMETIMES HARDER
WE NEED MORE TIME TO RULE OUT
IS THIS A PSYCHOTIC DISORDER IS
THIS A METHAMPHETAMINE INDUCED
PSYCHOSIS WHAT IS THIS. AND
JUST EXISTING CHALLENGE
HIGHLIGHTS THE VALUE OF THE
PROPOSED CAL AIM PAYMENT AND
MEDICAL NECESSITY REFORMS AND I
MISSED COOPER JUST TALKED ABOUT
AND THE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THESE REFORMS ARE SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED. THE REFORMS TO
ADULT AND CHILDREN'S MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS SPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AS IT WILL REMOVE THE
GATEKEEPER DIAGNOSTIC CRITERIA.
DIGESTERS PROPOSED TO SIMPLIFY
AND UPDATE MEDICAL NECESSITY
CRITERIA TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITIES FOR REIMBURSEMENT
SO IDENTIFYING A MENTAL HEALTH
OR SUBSTANCE USE DIAGNOSIS AND
ALSO TO REVISIT DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS. TO ALIGN THEM
WITH MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
FLEXIBLE APPROACHES WE NEED TO
SPEND MORE TIME TREATING OUR
CLIENTS NOT OUR CHART. AT
PRESENT AT WE ALSO WE ALSO
LOOKING FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE REFORMS INCLUDING- AT
LATER SAID AS PRESENT IN ORDER
TO REIMBURSE FOR THE MAJORITY
OF THE US SPECIAL MENTAL HEALTH
AND- S. U. D. SERVICES COUNTIES
HAVE TO REQUIRE VERY IN DEPTH
HIGHLY REGIMENTED ASSESSMENT
AND I TREATMENT PLANNING
PROCESS AND THESE REQUIREMENTS
ARE SIMPLY JUST TO GET INTO THE
DOOR SO IF YOU CAN IMAGINE
BEING SOMEONE WHO IS LIVING
WITH MAJOR DEPRESSIVE DISORDER
AND NOW YOU HAVE TO TELL YOUR
STORY OVER AND OVER AGAIN. IN
VERY LONG ASSESSMENT OR IF YOUR
CLIENT WHO'S DEALING WITH A
WITHDRAWAL FROM A SUBSTANCE
HAVING TO SET FOR OUR LONG
ASSESSMENT IN ORDER TO GET IN
THE DOOR AND GET YOUR NEXT
APPOINTMENT IS QUITE DIFFICULT
IT CREATES OF FIVE- EXCESSIVE
FISCAL RISK FOR COUNTIES WHEN
SERVICES ARE DISALLOWED
STRICTLY FOR MINOR
DOCUMENTATION. ERRORS FINALLY
WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL AS
WELL FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERED AT THE HAVE A HEALTH
DELIVERY SERVICES TO BE
ACCESSIBLE BEAT TELEPHONICALLY
TO CONTINUE TO BE ARRAIGNED
REIMBURSED AT THE SAME RATE AS
VIDEO SERVICES. GIVEN THE
DIGITAL BY THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND A PRIORITY ISSUE
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. SO
MANY OF OUR DESERT AND MOUNTAIN
REGIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A VERY LIMITED.
CONNECTIVITY AND THE CLIENTS
THAT WE SERVE A VERY LIMITED
DATA PLANS. CBJ HAS ALSO ENGAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION ENSURING
THAT WE TAKE EVERY OPPORTUNITY
IN THE CAL IN PROPOSED REFORMS.
TO VIEW ACCESS NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF PENETRATION RIGHT. BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF EQUITY WE
BELIEVE THE MORE OF THE
COMMUNITY DEFINED PRACTICES
HISTORICALLY FUNDED BY COUNTIES
UNDER AND I JUST SAY SHOULD
BECOME MAD COW REIMBURSABLE
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE MEDICARE
POPULATION. AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK ON THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES HERE TONIGHT. NEXT I
HAVE MICHELLE CABRERA SHE WOULD
LIKE TO COME. THANK YOU CHAD
NUMBER LAST I'M JUST GOING TO
BUILD UPON AS- A DOCTOR KELLY'S
REMARKS THAT THERE AND AGAIN I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THEM AT THE FUNDING CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN THE WAYS IN
WHICH CAL AIM. IS HOPING TO-
IMPROVE ACCESS IMPROVE WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO LEVERAGE- MATIC
HOW WITHIN THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE- AND YOU KNOW THAT
PAYMENT REFORM PROPOSAL WILL
REALLY GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
TRANSFORMING SOME OF THE- THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THAT HAS
BEEN COULD NOT JUST ON- COUNTY
PLANNED BUT ALSO- COUNTY
PROVIDERS THE CONTRACT
PROVIDERS- I WILL SAY THAT THE
LACK OF FISCAL STABILITY. AS
WELL AS B. R. CROSS BASED
REIMBURSEMENT HAS MADE IT
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO MAKE
SYSTEM REINVESTMENT AND CAN
TAKE ON AMBITIOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT IN A INITIATIVE OR
EVEN TO- MEANINGFULLY MAKE
EXPANSION PLANS SO WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THESE PROPOSALS
UNDER CAL EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
THE I. IN D. WAIVER PROPOSAL
WHICH AGAIN WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE STATE AND PULLING
TOGETHER- YOU KNOW. I WILL SAY
IN THE COMING YEARS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A BURGEONING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS I IT
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR
POLICYMAKERS TO CONSIDER HOW WE
SUPPORT THE INCREASED LEVELS OF
SERVICE. AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
RELIED ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FACT FOR THE LAST
DECADE AND MORE TO FILL SOME OF
THESE GAPS- IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
NOT MEDIC HOW REIMBURSABLE BUT
I WILL POINT OUT THAT THERE HAS
BEEN NO COMPARABLE INVESTMENT
IN OUR EDU THE THIRD AT THE
END. AND WHILE CVH DA CONTINUED
SUPPORT- THE POSSIBILITY OF
ALLOWING MORE FLEXIBLE USE OF
MHSAA FUND FOR STD SERVICES. I
THINK THAT IT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO HEY IF. POST THAT IT
IMPORTANT PRESS TO LOOK AT A
COUPLE. SERVICES BE WHAT
ALREADY. OUT MADE AVAIL FOR.
MENTAL UNDER THE AND MAKE- WITH
REGARD TO WORK FORCE SHORTAGES
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO HEALTH BIRTH
CENTER SAYS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL FACE.
SUBSTANTIAL SHORTAGES IN ALL
OCCUPATIONS AND- RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- OUR CURRENT
TRENDS IN UTILIZATION ARE SUCH
THAT WE WILL HAVE 41% FEWER
PSYCHIATRISTS THAN NEEDED IN
THE FUTURE- AS WELL AS 11%
FEWER A LICENSED MARRIAGE
FAMILY THERAPIST- AND ALPHEUS
W. ETCETERA. WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO- OPT INTO
AND SELF FINANCE- THE B. THE
BEGINNING OF MEDICARE HOW
REIMBURSED PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST THROUGHOUT MEDIC
HOW- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE HOPING- THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE CAN- SIXTY
EIGHT IN IN SECURING AROUND
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION IN
STATE GENERAL FUND. JEFF TO
HELP US SET UP STAND UP THE
STATEWIDE CERTIFICATION PROCESS
WHICH WILL BE MATCHED WITH
FEDERAL DOLLARS- WE HOPE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE BOTH REPORT
THAT- AND ALTHOUGH PEERS WILL
BE AGAIN AN OPTION THAT COUNTY
YOU CAN FINANCE EVENTUALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS BROUGHT
INTO MEDIC HOW IS THE UNIFORM
STATEWIDE BENEFIT. IN THE
MEDIA- WE WILL WORK ON ON
LIFTING THIS PROGRAM UP- COUNTY
THEY'RE ALSO FINANCING THROUGH
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT-
AND VARIOUS WORKFORCE EDUCATION
AND TRAINING PROGRAMS WHICH I
WILL NOT GET INTO THAT TOO MUCH
DETAIL ON HERE- BUT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND THEN.
WE ARE THANKS TO FUNDING FROM
THAT KAISER FOUNDATION WORKING
ON A STATEWIDE- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE CAPTAIN ALEX
THAT OUGHT TO LOOK AT NOT JUST.
OUT THERE IF WE HAVE THAT MAKE
WORKFORCE GAPS IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM BUT
ALSO- WHAT THE NEEDS ARE IN
TERMS OF EQUITY AND LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE POPULATION
DIFFERENCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
TO YOU CHERUB ARE BLACK AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR PULLING
TOGETHER THE. HEARING ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR OUR
CHRIS. THANK YOU NEXT WILL FROM
HOW SHE DOES THE LA ANALYST ON.
MORE THANK YOU DOCTOR IN YOUR-
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON THE HEALTH
SPECIFIC REFORMS OF THE
CALENDAR- WE CERTAINLY FIND
THAT THESE REFORMS COULD BRING
MAJORPOTENTIAL BENEFITS TO THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM
BY YOU KNOW MAKING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES MORE ACCESSIBLE
IN THE CASE OF YOU KNOW MEDICAL
NECESSITY REFORMS- OR LESSENING
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
COUNTIES WHEN IT COMES TO
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICE
DELIVERY IN IN THE CASE OF
PAYMENT REFORM- WE JUST HAVE NO
ONE BROUGHT ISSUE TO BRING TO
THE LEGISLATURES ATTENTION
FIRST- IN GENERAL UNDER
REALIGNMENT THE STATE IS YOU
KNOW REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO COUNTIES AS A RESULT
OF- NEW STATE MANDATES OR OR
SORT OF HIGHER LEVELS OF
SERVICE- SOME OF THE CALENDAR
HERE HEALTH REFORMS- COULD.
IMPACT THE FISCAL RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE AND COUNTIES
DUE TO REALIGNMENT- SO FOR
EXAMPLE ALTHOUGH THE REVISIONS
TO MEDICAL NECESSITY COULD LEAD
TO COUNTIES DRAWING MORE TRYING
DOWN MORE FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
SERVICES THAT ARE ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED THEY COULD ALSO LEAD
TO- INCREASING UTILIZATION OF
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES- AND IN
ADDITION YOU KNOW UNDER CAL
EIGHTEEN- THERE IS A PROPOSAL
TO- TRANSFER RESPONSIBILITY FOR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I'M FROM A MANAGED
CARE PLAN TO THE COUNTY IN TWO
CASES- WHICH COULD LEAD TO SORT
OF A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
COUNTY COSTS IN THOSE COUNTIES-
THESE YOU KNOW SORT OF
POTENTIAL ONGOING COSTS ARE ARE
NOT CURRENTLY BUILT INTO.
MINISTRATIONS FUNDING PLAN FOR
TELLING WOMEN WHETHER THE STATE
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SORT OF
FIND THE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
COUNTIES MAY BEAR FOR THESE
REFORMS IS CURRENTLY UNCLEAR-
AND SO BROADLY SPEAKING THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER SORT OF WHAT THE
IMPACT OF THESE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH REFORMS WILL BE SORT OF
ON THE STATE AND COUNTY FISCAL
RELATIONSHIP. UNDER UNDER REAL
LIKE. THAT'S THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- IN LIGHT OF OUR ON
THE FACT THAT WHEN WE STARTED
DR KELLY HAD A REALLY NICE PALM
TREE WHICH IS BEHIND AROUND THE
WINDOW AND NOW IT'S A PRETTY
DARK I WILL. KEEP MY COMMENTS
SHORT BUT JUST REALLY WANT TO
ELEVATE THE HARD WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE HERE IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH I. REALLY WANTED TO
UPLIFT WITH DR KELLY SAID THAT
WE NEED TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH
THEIR PATIENTS AND NOT OUR
CHARTS I REMEMBER THOSE
FEELINGS AND REMEMBER THOSE
TIMES AND I REALLY DO WANT TO-
ELEVATE THE FACT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FIGURING OUT
HOW WE CAN NOT TO DUPLICATE
REPORTING HOW WE CAN HELP TO
INTEGRATE TO TREATMENT HOW WE
CAN. NOT LABEL PEOPLE BUT
INSTEAD START TREATMENT SOONER
AND REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE-
GROUP OF REFORMS THAT WERE
SPEAKING WILL TAKE US A LONG
STEP FORWARD. WOULD LIKE TO END
SIMPLY BY ELEVATING PEER
SPECIALISTS- S. B. EIGHT OH
THREE BY SENATOR BILL LAST
YEAR. AND THE NEED FOR US TO
INCREASE SUPPORT SERVICES- I
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE NEED
FOR A UNIFORM UNIFORM STATEWIDE
BENEFIT. AND BUT AT THIS TIME I
WILL SIMPLY HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN AND APPRECIATE THE PANEL
AND THE BREATH OF DISCUSSION.
AT THIS TIME WE WILL NOW
ACTUALLY BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS A REMINDER WE WILL WELCOME
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON
THE AGENDA INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES. SIX THREE
TWENTY. WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE- WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I'D LIKE TO ASK IF
YOU CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF- WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND JUST AS A REMINDER. THE
PHONE NUMBER TECHCONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ALSO
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. IT
DIRECTLY TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO- WE GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTEEN FOR THE FIRST COMMENT
CLEVELAND. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR NUMBER AND
GAVE THE ACT ON BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA I'LL FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON TWO MAIN FINANCE
AND RESERVE OUR COMMENTS
REGARDING CAMPAIGNING YOUR
UPCOMING JOINT INFO HEARING
WILL GET FROM THE HELP
COMMITTEE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS. UNDER ISSUE ONE WE
GENERALLY SUPPORT THE MUCH
NEEDED AND LONG OVERDUE
INVESTMENT IN BUILDING UP OUR
CONTINUUM OF CARE CAPACITY.
WITH THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSAL BUT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
SOME OF THE FUNDINGBE DIRECTED
TOWARDS IMPROVING AND UPGRADING
EXISTING I KEEP THE SUN SH IN
OUR LIVE RESERVE FUND TO BUILD
OUT LINKAGES FOR DATA SO WE
ACTUALLY KNOW HOW MANY BAD.
RELATED SERVICES BY HOSPITAL
THANKS FOR THOUGHTS EITHER
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE. ON THE
FIFTH IMPACT NECESSARILY
TALKING TO EACH OTHER LASTLY WE
WOULD BE AT THE PRUDENT ALSO
ADVOCATE FOR ONGOING FUNDING
FOR INCREASED STAFFING AND
WORKFORCE. AS MENTIONED BY THE
BEACH THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
MICHELLE COVERED AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WHAT GOOD WOULD NEED
THE BUILDINGS BEING WITHOUT THE
PROPER STAFFING. AND LASTLY
UNDER ISSUE TWO ON THE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ATLANTA HOPPING BACK
MAN WHO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU WALK ME ASSURE OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKERS WHO HAD THE CLINICAL
EXPERTISE. ARE ENGAGED IN
SERVICE PROVISION AND THAT
THERE IS ALSO TARGETING OF THE
FUNDING. FOR THAT HAPPENED A
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO WE KNOW ARE THE ONES THAT
HAD INCLUDES MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THE YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER. MEXICO TO LIE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS THE
RATE GET IT AND I WOULD BE
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT HELPED
OF OFFICE OF MULTICULTURAL
SERVICES FOR TWELVE YEARS I AM-
I KNOW I'LL PRETTY BORED BY
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
I'M CALLING FOR THE SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS BUT ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR THE SURPLUS OR FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THIS
PROJECT. I THINK I PRESENTED
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY IN TERMS OF
THE TWENTY TWO YEARS I WORKED
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH. I WANT TO REMIND. YOU
THAT THIS PROGRAM. BUT I WAS
THE ARCHITECT OF THE PROGRAM
AND THE CALIBRATED BECAUSE IT
WAS. LEVINE TO ADDRESS THE
OVERWHELMING DISPARITY THAT
EXISTED IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
CONTINUE TO INVEST- MANY OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
TODAY AND DISCUSS WHAT TALKING
ABOUT YOU CAN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I THINK WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT- THROUGH INVESTMENT
IN. PREVENTION THANK YOU FOR
THE- UP BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE ADVERSELY IMPACT BY
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
DISCUSS THE DAY HOMELESSNESS.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL PROBLEM AT THE
TIME- THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH.
HALF MANY OF THESE ARE. PROGRAM
IN MANY DIFFERENT. BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE ON THE THIS BY THE
MIDDLE THE LOOK AT THE LESS OF
HOW MAY BE PROGRAM WERE-
ALLOCATED AND SO THERE.
MELENDEZ AN ECHO OKAY- IT'S
PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED BECAUSE
THERE WAS LITTLE PROGRESS BEING
MADE AND WE DO THINK CALIFORNIA
DISPARITIES IN MENTAL HEALTH
ACCESS AND APPROPRIATE CARE THE
MEDICARE MEDICAL NECESSITY
CRITERIA IT'S GOOD TO HEAR THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CHANGES
BECAUSE THAT CREATED A MAJOR
BEAR YOUR FOR MULTI CULTURE
COMMUNITIES THE LACK OF
LANGUAGE THE ACT LACK OF. MULTI
CULTURAL WORKFORCE- THE LACK
OF- PERSONAL OF DESIGNATED
POPULATION- PROGRAMS DESIGNED
FOR THIS POPULATION HE'LL
CONTINUE TO LACK IN OUR STATE I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THE INVESTMENT PROGRAM IF THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO GROW UP
MULTI CULTURAL WORKFORCE OF
PEOPLE WHO KNOW AND WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE- IN THE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY FUNDED- WE NEED TO
GROW A CULTURALLY SPONSORED
INTERVENTION PREVENTION PROGRAM
AND INVEST IN PREVENTION. SO
THAT WE CAN- WORK TO SERVE
PEOPLE IN THE- BEGINNING OF
MENTAL HEALTH STRESSORS NOT AT
THE DEEP END IT IS MORE
EXPENSIVE OKAY HOSPITAL CARE
THE MAIN OPPONENT GETS GUIDE
TODAY SO I HOPE YOU JOIN ME IN
MY SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONNECT. THIRTY PROJECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
THAT JOHN GILMORE. AND I'M THE
FORMER CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA MULTICOOKER MANY
MENTAL HEALTH COALITION
GOVERNMENT MEMBER OF RACIAL
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES COALITION.
I'M ALSO THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF
AMERICA. CALIFORNIA AND- CO
COORDINATOR FORMALLY OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICANS DO DEFINING
WORKGROUP ORDER TO YOUR CD ART
AP PHASE ONE. THE FOUNDATION
PHASE OF THE REDUCING
DISPARITIES INITIATIVE WHICH-
WAS A CENTRAL AND CRITICAL. TO
BRING IN ABOUT TWENTY TO FIND
EVIDENCE FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THIS IS A PIVOTAL PROGRAM
MHSAA IS PRIMARILY STILL THE
SAME THE C. R. V. P. FUNDING IS
LESS THAN 1% OF ALL IMAGES
STATE FUNDING. WE LOOK A CALL
THAT NEVER THING ELSE. THIS
PROGRAM IS SO CRITICAL TO THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE MIDDLE
HELP. SYSTEM IT MUST CONTINUE.
IT MUST CONTINUE I URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE IT AT THE LEVEL
DESCRIBER MISS RACHEL GUERRERO
AND OTHER PEOPLE HI TO ME WE
MUST CONTINUE THIS TO FULLY
SERVE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LIKE TO
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS KELLY PARKS I'LL BE
COMMENTING ON BEHALF OF TWO
PLANTS FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE AND HER STAFF
FOR THAT REALLY ROBUST AGENDA
AND A VERY EXCELLENT
CONVERSATION ABOUT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES THIS EVENING. ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY- BOTH ENTITIES ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND STRUCTURE
FUNDING- THE FUNDING WILL
BETTER PREPARE CALIFORNIA FOR A
POST PANDEMIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEMANDS AS WELL AS CALLIN
IMPLEMENTATION- I'D ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THEY'RE EVALUATING THE
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY FIT WITH LOCAL INITIATIVES
AND HOW THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL CAN EXPAND ACCESS TO
SERVICES- THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INVESTMENTS THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WELL RESERVE THE BULK
OF OUR TELLING COMMENTS FOR
UPCOMING BUDGET. HEARINGS ON
THIS ISSUE BUT IN REGARDS TO
THE COMMITTEE'S QUESTION ON HOW
IT SERVES. HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
WE DON'T THINK THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL IS SUFFICIENT AS IT
PROVIDES PLAN SPEAK OPTION TO
PROVIDE HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND DO NOT HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT TIME TO A
CONTRACT WITH HOMELESS
PROVIDERS INCLUDING COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. INSTEAD
WE REQUEST HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICES BE A STATE WIDE
BENEFIT ADMINISTERED TO THE
COUNTY BOARD EASY AND BENEFIT
WE SUPPORT INCREASED ACCESS TO
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SHOW THE CHAIR'S
COMMENT REGARDING COORDINATION.
AND L. A. O.'S RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH BE OFFERED BETTER
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE
SUPPORT CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT AS WEEKLY
DATA WILL DEMONSTRATE THANK
GOODNESS. THEY REDUCING MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND FINALLY
REGARDING ISSUE NINE WE SUPPORT
IT DELAYED THE EXPANSION OF THE
POST PARTUM ELIGIBILITY
EXTENSION AND REQUEST
ELIMINATING. THE FUNCTION
COMPLETELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TO GO
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
HASSAN ACCESS AND I'M MUCH
OLDER NOW THANK YOU CHAIR AND
I'M VERY I WANT ONE FACTS YOU
ISSUES BRIEFLY ADDITIONAL THREE
WILL BE A GREAT CONCEPT IS THE
YES YEAH ALTHOUGH. ALL OF THAT.
AND ARE. I BELIEVE THE YEAH IT
WILL BE MIGHT BE BEFORE BEING
OKAY FINE THEN HAVE THAT IT.
THAT ACT. ON ASIA TYPE ARE
UNDER THE ONLY EASY TO FORGET
THAT THAT ASSEMBLY SAID THINK
OF FULLY FUNDING THE- TWENTY
SCHOOLS PARTNER. AT EACH. I'M
ISSUE NUMBER WITH A FOUR LOT
WITH A DOLLARS YEAH. SACRAMENTO
SAN WE BELIEVE THAT HIGHER
LEVEL CREATION WILL BE FIVE
TRACK I. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE LINE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BERMAN THANK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO COME IN ON A FEW ISSUES-
BURKE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE
THREE AND THE THIRD PART
PREVENTION EFFORTS INCLUDING
THE OPPOSITE SIDE PREVENTION.
ISSUE FOR- THIRD DEPARTMENT
HOSPITAL FELONY I S. T.
PROPOSAL WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE OAKLAND COUNTY LEVEL
OF MULTI BEACH CA AND THIS
COUNTRY STAND THAT PROPOSAL A
LITTLE MORE CLEARLY WE'RE ALSO
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR THE
COMMUNITY. BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE ON AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THAT- IT
MORE DETAIL- ALSO WILL- WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF OR ALL OF THE
CALLING EFFORT BUT AGREED THAT
SOME START UP COSTS WILL NEED
TO BE FUNDED THAT THEY GIVE A
WHOLE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT MONEY
WILL HELP IN THAT MANNER. AND
THEN TO ISSUES THAT WERE NOT
HEARD REALLY QUICKLY WITH
SUPPORT- FUNDING- ASKED FOR TO-
ADD THAT WOULD BE IT YES TO
IMPLEMENT- NOW SENATOR EGGMAN
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND
ALSO IF YOU ELEVEN WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK. YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU TO MY ONE
NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS AND STAFF ARE
TELLING OF OUR OWN BE HAPPY THE
CHILDREN PARTNERS ON ISSUE TO
WE APPLAUD PROPOSED TOLD HOW
THE TO HEALTH AND THAT HOWEVER
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE PORT OF
ENTRY MANY INVESTMENTS BEGIN IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD TO ALIGN WITH
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN THE ALL
CHILDREN THRIVE. EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AND MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES THE AUTHORED THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE LOCAL K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL RESOURCES
THIS CAN BE ACHIEVED BY
EXPANDING THE PROPOSED AWASTHI
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
BACK BUDGET PROPOSAL TO EIGHTY
POINT FIVE MILLION SO THAT ALL
SCHOOL TO APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM
LAST YEAR. AND DO NOT RECEIVE
FUNDS MAY DO SO WE ALSO URGE
THE STATE WIDE PLANNING AND
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ON STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH TO INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL AND EXCELLENCE AND
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE AGENCY TASKED
WITH PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND LOCAL DECISION
MAKERS HAVE OPPORTUNITY ENGAGE
IN RESURGENT MULTI SYSTEM WORK.
ON ISSUE THREE WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL THE PROPOSAL TO FULLY
FUND THE OPPOSITE- SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND CDPH MEDICAL
WILL BE CRITICAL TO ATTRACTING
ONGOING PANDEMIC ABUSE SUICIDE
IN PARTICULAR BLACK GIRLS
LATINA GIRLS IN NATICK YOUTH
SHOWED INCREASED RISK FACTORS
FOR SUICIDE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNTS TO
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS. WHICH
HAVE BEEN FURTHER EXACERBATED
BY INCREASED SOCIAL ISOLATION
THAT HEIGHTEN THE TENSION
AROUND THE PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPACT OF
POLICE VIOLENCE IN THE LAST
YEAR. ON ISSUE ELEVEN WE
RECOGNIZE THE URGENT CRISIS
LEVEL NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE AND
APPLAUDED MINISTRATIONS
RECOGNITION OF THIS WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE AND MAGIC
I THANK COUNTY FLEXIBILITY
STILL WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY FOR
FURTHER OBSCURE WELL LITTLE
DATA EXIST ABOUT COUNTY
SPENDING SERVICES PROVIDED.
OUTCOMES ACHIEVED IN PARTICULAR
AT THEIR RELATED SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN THIRD EIGHT EIGHT WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER HOW TO MEET THEIR
URGENT. DYNAMICS NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND FOR FAILINGS IN
THIS CAR WHILE. THAN THAT DATA
TO ENSURE THE THOSE NEED. THOSE
NEEDS ARE BEING THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CAN. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALL PLEASE. ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING EVERYONE
HI MY NAME IS KHAN I AM THE
THAT THE RECTOR OF THE TEMPLE
AND FAMILY CAN BE FOUND HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY BUT YES THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER I KEEP BEING
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OF THE DISPARITY PROJECT THE R.
T. P. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE ASSEMBLY PRACTICE BUT
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND MEMBERS BUT
OPTED TO TAKE. OUR ORGANIZATION
AND OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS HAVE
BEEN ON THE GROUND IN MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY BODY TO CALL IT
NINETEEN AND IT'S IMPACT ON THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
ABOUT IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY. A
QUICK STORY A WEEK BEFORE
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OLD MATTER OF ONE
VILLAGE HOUSE HAD STOPPED WILL
COME DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY AND
HAVE BEEN HAPPY WITH FIVE
O'CLOCK SHE DID NOT WANT TO
REACH OUT FOR HELP INITIALLY
BECAUSE SHE DID NOT SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE THAT KNOW HOW TO GET
OR WHAT HE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO
GET HELP HOWEVER SHE HAD
ATTENDED OUR MEANT TO HOLD
WORKSHOPS. NEED FOR AND QUICKLY
CALL OUT YOU LANGUAGE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT LINE OUR
BILINGUAL BY PROJECT MANAGER
WAS ABLE TO QUICKLY AT THE PARK
AND THE FEELING THAT THE POINTS
YOU NEED SHE IS NOW ATTENDING
OUT MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING
SERVICES INC MILE CAMBODIAN THE
ONLY KEYBOARD LANGUAGE
COUNSELING PROGRAM IN ORANGE
COUNTY I THINK ON THE WAY TO
WEEK HOW THE SO THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO CARE FOR HER FAMILY
AND. HOPEFUL ONE YEARS OLD. AB%
YOU COMMUTING WHILE THAT
PROGRAM A- FIGHT BACK YOU. GET
THE WITH AT THE B. P. WHICH
PROVIDE LANGUAGE. AND ALL THE
WORKSHOP ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
AND CORPORATE WITH THE THANK
YOU T. V. P. OF THE RESULT OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT. 13% OF THE
PEOPLE AND HOW CAN THE AUDIENCE.
WHILE BROKE. REPORTEDLY IN THE
BACK OF FROM. WHAT DEPRESSION
THE SOME BECAUSE BOOKED THE
NIGHT BUT- THE APPLE IT IS VERY.
THAT THE SPECIALLY DURING AN
AFTER THE DOWN THE THAT THE ARE
THE PROUD. BE WEEK TO INCREASE
MENTAL MEAT AT THE REEBOK OF
THE DOWN THE- WE PULLED SUPPORT
THE PREP. FIFTY MEANING DOLLARS
ONE. THE FROM FEDERAL OF THE
DAY FUND HE ADDED FEEDBACK AT.
THE THESE ONE COMP. WITH THE
PAIN THAT THE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE ADDITIONAL YEAR I YOU
PROVIDE. THE CONTENT ON THE
INDY GRAND AND BACK TO CAN.
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO. NO CALLER
PLEASE. TO THE TIMELINE TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWO HUNDRED I THINK THAT ME FOR
ME TO HARPER TECH AWAY FROM
THIS. HEARING IS HEARINGS
LAPSED HOPE INTENDED THAT.
PERNICIOUS LIFELONG MENTAL
ILLNESS START OF THE YOUNG AS
AGE FIFTEEN AND OUR CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN ISOLATED. KEPT AWAY
FROM RELATIONSHIPS KEPT OUT OF
SCHOOL NOW FOR A YEAR. SO IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF YOU ASK THE
LAB COAT HOW TO STOP THE VIRUS
THAT SPREADS THROUGH HUMAN
INTERACTION. DO NOT BE
SURPRISED WHEN THEY TELL YOU TO
STOP HUMAN INTERACTION. STOP
HUMAN INTERACTION WALKERTOWN
MASCOT KEEP YOUR DISTANCE
DANGER YOUR LOVED ONES ARE NEAR
NO HUGS NO HANDSHAKES WE NEVER
NEEDED THEM ANYWAY. WELL BY
NEIGHBOR GO ONLINE FOR SCHOOL
FOR WORK FOR PLAYING A NEW
NORMAL JIM KINDERGARTEN
SCREENING ACTORS. A SOCIAL
DILEMMA FEAR DRIVEN ALGORITHM
POLARIZING EVERYONE'S DYING
ANTIFA AND WHITE SUPREMACISTS
LEADING AN INSURRECTION BAD
ACTORS HIDING IN MOB. THE
MADNESS OF CROWDS HEARD
STUPIDITY CD CWHL W. T. ASKS
WHY IS MASQUERADING AS SCIENCE
SCIENCE THE STUDY'S MODELS WITH
FALSE INPUTS CREATING FALSE
OUTPUTS AMPLIFIED. BY HIDDEN
AGENDAS. EATING MY HYSTERIA.
IT'S COMPLY WITH ABSURD PAULA
POLICY ABSURD THE HURT THE MORE
AT THE NO POLICE NEEDED SOCIAL
SHAMING WORKS JUST FINE YOU
KNOW PEER PRESSURE HE DESERVE
IT THEY WON'T WEAR A MASK MUST
BE RACIST OR STUPID NATURAL
HERD IMMUNITY NO SUCH THING
VACCINE HERD IMMUNITY FOR
TRAINING SHOULD CHANGE YOU HAVE
MADE THIS PROBLEM WORSE OVERALL
VIRUS WITH A NINETY NINE POINT
9% SURVIVAL RATE AND NOW YOU
WANT MORE OF OUR MONEY TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. THAT YOU CREATED.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
NEXT WE ARE DEADLINE TO- TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS ADRIAN SHELTON THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS HEARING
DEDICATED TO THE TOPIC OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ITEMS TO COMMENT ON TONIGHT WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE OAC
STUDENT SERVICES ACT
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS AN
ISSUE NUMBER Q. AND SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO EIGHTY POINT FIVE
MILLION. WHICH IS THE AMOUNT
NEEDED TO FUND THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT APPLIED. ALSO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO IS THE DH CS PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THROUGH MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
PLANS. WE SUPPORT THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL BUT ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
L. A. L. SAT KEY DETAILS ARE
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT AND GIVEN
THAT. MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
NOT GENERALLY IN SCHOOLS WE
SUPPORT A STRONGER MANDATE THAT
THEY PARTNER WITH THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM. WE
ALSO ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL TO FIND AT THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND WE
MUST HAVE MORE COORDINATED
STRATEGY. TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE HAD IN
PARTICULAR FOR AT RISK GROUPS.
AND LASTLY WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT COULD
BE THEY'LL HELP CONTINUE ON.
THESE ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED
FUNDS TO BUILD OUT OUR SAFETY
NET FOR KIDS AND ADULTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. HELLO NINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN LINES
OPEN. BY THEN. OKAY YES MA'AM-
YES HI THIS IS WILLIAM KANKAN
OKAY RESEARCH WE ARE TECHNICAL
PROVIDING TO BE- AFRICAN AND
WORKING CLASS USE AND WORK
FIRST OF ALL EXAMPLE ISLAND
LIKE A I DON'T IMAGE OF THE
WILL NOT WHO LARGE INFLOW MORE
THAN ONE OF THE BOB OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED STATE YOUR REALLY
LOOKING BACK IN TIME A BEEN AND
THEN WHILE YOU'RE THE FIRST
TIME I WAS. YOUR KIDS ON THE
COURT OF ISSUE ONE ON ACCORDING
TO THE RP- I JUST WANNA MAKE
SOMETHING- AND- THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE FINAL
AGAINST THE CLARIFICATION OR
HOPE THAT THE- RECOMMENDATION
TO THE COURT SHORT TERM BRIDGE
FUMBLE- OF COURSE HERE YOU
PROJECT- UNTIL EVALUATION IS
AVAILABLE AND IS PHENOMENAL BUT
WHAT HAS BEEN REQUESTED AND THE
LETTER FROM THE PHILIPPINES-
PARTNERS- AND I CAN JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT AS TO
WHY- AT THIS POINT THE-
EVALUATION IS EXPECTED TO BE
PRESENTED IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THE CONTRACT- FOR
THE PARTNERS ALL- AT THIS POINT
ENDING ON APRIL. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO I THINK MY EXTENSION IS IN
YOU KNOW IT IS- IN BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO COME GRATEFUL BUT
IF ONE TIME COSTS THAT BETWEEN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
WHATEVER PRIOR TO- FUNDING
MECHANISMS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
ACTED OUT WITH THAT WOULD BE
AMPLE- YOU KNOW FOR THE WEAPONS
THAT YEAR I HOPE THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S GOING- AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE ONE TIME OPPORTUNITY
BETWEEN WHAT THE SURPLUS- GOT
IT WOULD BE A SHINING- THIS
OPPORTUNITY WORKING NOW WHAT
THE- FUTURE- IN. UNCERTAIN IF
YOU LOOK AT THE- I THINK IT AS
ANOTHER LISTENING THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE HEARING- TO THE
COCKSURE AT SOME OF THE DAM THE
STAFF- THE LANDSCAPE THAT- THAT
THE CBO THANKS IN TERMS OF- THE
COURT FROM COUNTY STATE AGENCY-
PRIVATE- PRIVATE- PROVIDERS IS
VERY TRACTION OUT MOSTLY CLOSED
DOORS- I'M LESTER HOLT FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP ALREADY- ANTONITO
COLLECTED THAT NEEDS TO BE IT
WILL BE A DROP THERE IS A- ARE
THEY CURRENTLY.
UNDERWAY WITH
THE. AND WE'RE CALLING ON THE
OTHER DEVELOPMENT IF THERE IS
NOTHING LIKE THE P. THERE'S NO
VOICE. FOR THE CBO THAT
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT RIGHT
NOW I WILL CLOSE WITH THAT ONCE
AGAIN LIKE IN DECEMBER OF.
TWENTY NINETEEN ONE WORK OUT
HERE AND- YOU KNOW THERE'S- ALL
THESE PRESENTATIONS ON THE HOME
ONCE AND BOUGHT OUT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED ON IT. END. AND
LEAVE YOUR COMMENTS AND- I. AT
THE OF IT. NOT NOT EVEN THE
TIME DISPROPORTIONATE. EVEN IF
THERE LOCAL. BETWEEN THE
IDENTITY OF INDIVIDUAL THAT
WILL NOT THE THERE IS A
CREDIBLE RACIAL ON YOUTH MIND
POPULATION AND WE ARE. OF
POLLUTION. WITH A AND EXCITED
YOU KNOW WHAT THESE ARE. APPLE
AND THEN AND WE NEED TO GATHER
WITH MAKE IT THAT BUT IF YOU
IGNORE. YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
SUPPORT OF MICHAEL WE'RE HERE
WE WANT TO PART OF THE- AND ONE
WAY TO DO THAT IF. YOU FONG
COOPER CRONK DONOVAN THAT I.
CLOSELY THANK FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER. NINE
ONE NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE NINETY SEVEN LINES OPEN
YEAH HI HI MY NAME IS GOAL OF
BRIAN- BIG RECORD DIRECTOR OF
MY THOUGHTS- THAT IS THE MOST
FROM AMERICAN SOCIETY SOCIAL
SERVICES FOUNDATION. WE ARE
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT- AS YOU'VE
BEEN HEARING. HE IS- A HISTORIC
CROP OPERATIONS SOLUTION BASED.
VALUATION INITIATIVE- AND IT'S
CRIMINAL CURRENTLY FINDING
THIRTY FIVE CULTURALLY.
RESPONSIVE- IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- THAT CERTIFIED
POPULATION WHAT ARE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN- LOT NEXT EAST ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND NATIVE
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE IF YOU
COMMUNITY. AND AS A PILOT
PROJECT HINGED NONSENSE IS
ACTUALLY THE ONLY NON PROFIT
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA AS PART
OF THIS CHARITY P. THAT HAVE
BEEN FUNDED AND ONLY NONPROFIT
THAT HAS DEVELOPED A PEER
SPECIALIST PROGRAM- TO THE C.
R. D. P. AND TO PROVIDE. IT
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES FROM
THE MIDDLE EASTERN SOUTH ASIAN
AND NORTH AFRICAN COMMUNITIES.
BASICALLY A PLACE TO FIX
SERVICES- ONLY PLACE THAT CAN
BE UNDERSTOOD- UNDERSTAND ALL
THE VAST LINGUISTIC- ALL THE
LANGUAGES THAT EXIST WITHIN
THESE COMMUNITIES. AND ALL THE
CULTURAL NEEDS THAT IT HAS- AS
WELL AS- THEIR DEBT DIRE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE TRAUMA THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED- FROM COMING FROM
ALL THE WAR TORN COUNTRY THEN
NOW- HAVING IN YOUR LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES- AND AS YOU MIGHT
KNOW SACRAMENTO. IS HOME TO
OVER SEVEN PROUD IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES FROM THE MIDDLE
EASTERN SOUTH ASIAN AND NORTH
AFRICAN COMMUNITIES. AND THE
POPULATION OF IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES. HOW FURTHER
INCREASED- FROM 200-012-2000
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
HAS RECEIVED A HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND REFUGEES
APPROXIMATELY 15217% OF THESE
REFUGEES- ARE. THAT HAVE
ARRIVED COUNTRYWIDE AND-
ACCORDING TO THE- TO OUR
WEBSITE- THE FISCAL YEAR IN
MILLIONS OF CLEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
53% OF ITS REFUGEES. FROM ONE
OF THESE MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES WHICH OF PAKISTAN. SO
I'M HERE TO JUST EXPRESS THAT
THERE'S FUNCTIONS OF THE
COUNCIL SERVICES HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED IN. THE DEMOCRATS ARE
COULD YOU. DO THAT THEY ARE
DEEPLY AT THE STATE LEVEL- AND
TO THE IMAGES THEY ACT- WITH
UNLESS IT'S THE ACTIONS TAKEN
IT PROCEEDS IN APRIL OF. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU SO
CONSIDERING I'M GOING TO
CONCLUDE WITH THINGS AS THE
CONCERNED APPEARED IF HE'S
AFFECTED SPEAKER- OF EACH
OPERATION BUT HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO DO KALRA. ENDEMIC IN
THE RACIAL RECKONING AFTER THE
VERY YOU KNOW VERY PUBLIC
KILLINGS OF BLACK PEOPLE THE
VALUE IN ARGENTINA OF
SUSTAINING THIS PROJECT IS
OBVIOUS- SO IT'S IMPERATIVE. TO
FORWARD YOUR DEEPLY CONSISTING-
AND WE- AND EXTENDING THE
CURRENT PROGRAM INCLUDING
TECHNICAL SYSTEM RALLY WAS
CREATING MECHANISM FOR SCALING
THE PROGRAM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING ARMS FOR
PHASE THREE AND EXPANDED
SERVICES TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL OPERATIONS AND SYSTEM
CHANGE AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL- WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
FIFTY MILLION ONE CURRENT
FUNDING FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE
GENERAL FUND OR IN. ANY OTHER
STATE BUDGET SOURCE THIS YEAR
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH ALL OF
THESE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IT'S NOT CLEAR TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE A CO
SPONSORED THE C. R. D. P.
FUNDING REQUEST THAT WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
SUSTAINING AND EXTENDING FULL
FUNDING FOR THE C. R. D. T. FOR
THREE YEARS AND THE CHRISTIE
ARGUED HE FUNDS AT THIRTY FIVE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
INNOVATIVE IMPLEMENTATION PILOT
PROJECTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SERVING FIVE POPULATION GROUPS
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATIN ACT
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER NATIVE
AMERICANS AND LGBTQ CLASS. THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM THAT IS TACKLED A
PARTICULARLY INSIDIOUS PROBLEM
IN OUR STATE WHICH IS MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES- I PLEASE
ASK YOU TO CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM. FOR THREE YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
SIR. GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
NAME IS STILL BOUND- AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AT GENDER SPECTRUM
I'M I HEAR HIM CRY AND THEN
COMING TO YOU FROM SAN LEANDRO
ON WHAT IS UNSEEN IT CHOI CHANG
YEOW ALONI LAND- MY
ORGANIZATION GENDER SPECTRUM IS
ONE OF THE- ORGANIZATION THAT
HAS BEEN BLESSED TO BE PART OF
THE C. R. D. P. PROGRAM. OUR
PROJECT IS CALLED CREATING
GENDER INCLUSIVE SCHOOL AND I
GUESS HEY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR- HAVING TODAY
SESSION I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN HERE
PRETTY MUCH SINCE ABOUT TWO
THIRTY I MEAN IT'S BEEN
FASCINATING QUITE HONESTLY HERE
THE FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH. AND
IN A NUMBER OF INSTANCES I
HEARD SCHOOLS BEING TALKED
ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION I WORK
FOR GENDER SPECTRUM WORKS TO
HELP TRANSGENDER AND OTHER
GENDER DIVERSEYOUNG PEOPLE
NAVIGATE WHAT IS OFTEN A CLOCK
STYLE WORKOUT WORLD GIVE ME-
THIS WILL BECOME A SPECIALLY-
TRUE FOR MANY OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH THE COVETED
PANDEMIC. IN PARTICULAR FOR
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE LIVING IN
HOMES THAT ARE NOT AFFIRMING OF
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY IN MANY
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO IT TO
HELP SCHOOLS CREATE MORE GENDER
INCLUSIVE CONDITION CALLED A
MORE WELCOMING FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND IN MANY CASES
THEY'VE BEEN QUITE SUCCESSFUL-
I WANNA SAY HOWEVER FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE- BEEN
STUCK AT HOME IN NOT BURNING
HOUSEHOLD. IN SOME CASES GOLD
BUT UNDERSTAND GENDER HAVE BEEN
THEIR ONLY STATE HARBOR THEY
HAVE LITERALLY BEEN A SANCTUARY
AND I'VE HAD INCREDIBLE STORIES
FROM THE ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS
THIS GREAT STATE THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WORK MORE- AND
WORK WITH ELECTION STATE I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THEIR LEVELS OF GENDER
LITERACY. I WANT TO STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENDORSE THE R. P. D. THE
STATEMENT RECOMMENDING THE
CURRENT PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION. PROGRAM I'M TO ALL.
CREATING BURKE. THE PRO. AND
FINALLY DEVELOP PLAN FOR. THREE
SO I SPAM SERVER THE- DIGITAL
SPY POP- BLACK THING OFF THERE
THAT THIS. HAS BEEN SUCH AN AND-
OP. TO PARTNER ACROSS MULTIPLE
FORMS OF IDENTITY THE DEGREE TO
WHICH ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO
SUPPORT AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
ACT API NATIVE AMERICAN LGBTQ
POPULATION. HAVE BEEN JUST
EXTRAORDINARY AND QUITE
HONESTLY ONE OF A CRIME- THE
STATE HAD SOMETHING REALLY
REALLY COLD AND IT AND MY HOPE
DON'T HANG ON TO IT- THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE PROJECT AND SO WE-
WE SUPPORT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ONE TIME FUNDING-
TO KEEP THIS AMAZING PROGRAM
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES SIR THANK YOU- NO
YOUNG YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MINING
STOPPED AGAIN JOHN I'M FROM THE
FRESNO CENTER CAMP RIGHT NOW I
AM VERY HAPPY TO SAY THAT I'M
FROM EL DORADO IS DISTRICT. AND
ALSO ALL PROJECT- HAPPENS TO
TAKE PLACE IN IMPACT A MINUTE
BECAUSE COACHES AND THAT AS
WELL HAS ASSEMBLY MENTIONED
PATTERSON IN THE FRESNO AND
CLOVIS AREA. WE ARE ONE OF. THE
IDPS THIRTY FIVE I. P. P. I. P.
P. IS CALLED THE MALL HELPING
HANDS IN A PROJECT WAS
CONDUCTED IN FRESNO MERCED AND
STANISLAUS STOCKTON SERVING THE
LARGEST CONCENTRATION OF
COLUMBIA MALL REFUGEE COMMUNITY
IN THE STATE. IN FACT IN ACROSS
THE COUNTRY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE HERE TODAY
TO URGE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THE CIDP WORK. BECAUSE ONE MANY
OF THESE PROJECTS HAVE SHOWN TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN THAT RESPECT TO
COMMUNITY AND HAVE DEVELOPED
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL PROJECT MOVING
FORWARD. SECOND IN SOME AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE THESE PROJECT
MAY BE THE ONLY CULTURE
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES NOT AVAILABLE FOR EACH
OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITY TO
TRULY ACCESS. SUCH PROJECTS ARE
CRITICAL TO BUILDING TUST DO
YOU STIGMATIZING MENTAL HEALTH
AND ALSO INCREASE MANY HELP
UTILIZATION RATE HE COMMUNITY
UNDER CERVANTES AND NEED A LOT
OF WE HAVE SHOWN- TO HAVE
HAPPENED AND I'M MORE HELPING
HANDS AND THIRD MOVING FORWARD.
LIKE SPECIALLY DONE THE COPING
NINETEEN CONDEMNED MAKE SUCH
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES LIKE BLOODY P.
ISN'T MUCH NEEDED A VERY.
IMPORTANT TO KEEPING AND
EDUCATING THE DIVERSE
UNDERSERVED AND UNSERVED
COMMUNITY TO BE MENTALLY
HEALTHY AND LASTLY I JUST WANT
TO ECHO ONE OF BALK OPERATIVES
PENSION- MALL AGAINST QUEST
NEVER RECEIVE ANY HELP SHOWS
THIS BEFORE BUT ALSO HAS PTSD
YEAH WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE R. D.
P. SHE BETTER. GET JUST SAYS
BECAUSE YEAH HELPS SAVE MONEY.
THANKS FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY THIS IS NEAR IN
CALIFORNIA CHILD POP THIRTY AND
WANTED TO CALL THE SUPPORT OF.
AND THE FUNDING FOR THE- TOPIC
THAT SUICIDE PREVENTION ISSUE
THREE I ALSO WANTED TO CALL
RELATED TO SEVERAL ITEMS AN
ISSUE CHU JUST BROADLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INCREASED
FOCUS ON PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND INVESTMENT
BECAUSE THEY FOUND OUT HOW. WE
WOULD LIKE THE FLAG PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS IS ANOTHER
POPULATION OF VALUABLE
FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO HELP IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS MANY EARLY MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. EPHA IMPORTING
ABOT YOUR REQUEST BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY TO PILOT
AND MODEL TO INCREASE THE
SKILLSOF THESE PROVIDERS AND
SCHOOL BASED PROFESSIONALS TO
BETTER ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSING OF THE WHAT
LAWMAKERS IN THE COMING WEEK.
WE ALSO SUPPORT INCREASING THE
L. A. C. PROPOSAL TO EIGHTY
POINT FIVE MILLION TO FULLY
FUND THE REMAINING KOKANEE
PARTNERSHIP AND LASTLY- FOR
ISSUE FIVE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE AGENCIES PROVIDE TELLING
PROPOSAL TO SIMPLIFY AND
STREAMLINE MENTAL HEALTH
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ALIGN WITH MEDICAL PROVIDER
REQUIREMENTS IMPROVE EFFICIENCY
AND INCREASE PROVIDER BURNOUT.
ALIGNS WITH LEGISLATION WE ARE
RUNNING AT THE TWO NINETY THREE
ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA LINE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY OF
COUNTY COUNCIL COMMUNITY THERE
ARE AGENCIES WHICH WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WITH YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME. AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTNERSHIP TODAY. THANK YOU
MA'AM MEXICO PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT EVENING I THINK I
HEARD VICE PRESIDENT PUBLIC
POLICY AND UP WITH FAMILY
SERVICES IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
BUDGET ITEM NUMBER THREE. I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THOMAS WERE BRINGING FOR THE
TWO MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
TO FUND THE OFFICE WITH THE
FACT CONVENTION AND TO USE
SOMETHING I'M GLAD I'M GLAD FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR UP LISTING
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS WE
GO TO LINE TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GETTING YOUR ARAMBULA MY
NAME IS STACY HERE A MODEL ON
THE DIRECTOR OF BRAMCOTE IT'S A
REAL PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
REMCO- THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION IS A CO SPONSOR. OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL ALONG WITH
ANY OF W. CALIFORNIA TO EXTEND
THE FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECTS
THE RDP. OF FOR THREE YEARS.
ONE CALL AND BEEN VERY PROUD TO
BE PART OF PHASE ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT AND ALSO PLAY A SMALL
PART IN PHASE TWO. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVED BY MANY
OF THESE INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS
MAY BE UNLIKELY TO SEEK OR
RECEIVE SERVICES ELSEWHERE. I
KNOW THAT MOST IF NOT ALL OF
THESE PROJECTS COULD TELL YOU
THAT NUMEROUS YEARS FAMILY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD NOT HAVE
GONE TO PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY
TRADITIONAL COUNTY PROGRAMS OR
MAINSTREAM MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS. WE WITH THE
TRAUMA EXPERIENCED BY PEOPLE IN
THESE PROGRAMS THAT COVERED
THAT THE CULPRIT PANDEMIC AND
THE KILLINGS OF BLACK PEOPLE BY
POLICE LAST YEAR- THESE
PROJECTS MUST BE EXTENDED.
HOWEVER THE PROJECT GOES WELL
BEYOND JUST THE THIRTY FIVE
INDIVIDUAL PILOT PROJECTS.
CURRENTLY FUNDED THE OVERALL
PROJECT IS TO SUPPORT THE
EFFICACY AND USAGE OF COMMUNITY
DEFINED EVIDENCE PRACTICES OR
STATE DEPT. RACIAL ETHNIC AND
LGBT COMMUNITIES ARE OFTEN
BETTER SERVED BY THESE
PRACTICES WELL OTHER THAN THE
MAINSTREAM EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT BY THE WAY ARE
NOT USUALLY TESTED ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR THE
LGBT COMMUNITY. WE CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL THE FINAL EVALUATION IS
COMPLETE. AND THE FINAL REPORT
PUBLISHED BEFORE EXTENDING
THESE PROJECTS THESE PROJECTS
THESE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WILL
NOT BE RECEIVING FUNDING MONTHS
BEFORE THIS TAKES PLACE. TO PUT
HELLO MERRY FINDINGS ARE VERY
PROMISING AND THE ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES WOULD
NOT HAVE PUT THEM FOURTH IN THE
FIRST PLACE HAD THEY NOT BEEN
CONFIDENT THAT THEY MAKE A VERY
POSITIVE DIFFERENCE FOR THE
PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE
ARE HAPPY TO MEET WITH ANYONE
TO PRESENT INITIAL FINDINGS
PLEASE FROM THE C. R. D. P. FOR
THREE MORE YEARS NOT SMALLER
BRIDGE FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THERESA COMSTOCK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS QALBI H. B. C.
SUPPORTS THE WORK OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY NINE MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS- WERE BROADLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING. AND ANY
FUNDING TOWARD WORK FORCE
INCLUDING THE PEER SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION AND SPECIFICALLY
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE FOR SEAT THE COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL FOR.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT
TO THE TO LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- I
HOPE EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME YES
MA'AM- MY NAME IS THANK YOU OUT
MY NAME IS DR CATCHER LITTLE
BOBBY AND I'M THE LOCAL
EVALUATOR FOR TWO THOUSAND
NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILY SERVICES
CALIFORNIA REDUCE THE DISPARITY
PROJECT. OF ACORN WALLET
PROGRAM OUR TRAVEL PROGRAM IS
LOCATED IN THE WILL BE TO THE
HUMBOLDT AND DEL MAR COUNTY THE
ECONOMIC PROGRAM PRIMARILY
SERVES NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH
AGES EIGHTEEN. HEART OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCES THE VERY
PRODUCT OF THE POWER IN OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND ARTICULATE THE
VALUATION PROGRAM HAS GATHERED
DATA WHICH SHOWS HOW CULTURAL
PRACTICES INCREASE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS. BYE YOU PRETTY FAMILY
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING
COMMUNITIES AND STRENGTHENING
INTER TRIBAL CONNECTIONS AND
PARTNERSHIPS. WE KNOW THAT OUR
CULTURAL PRACTICES FOR TARGETED
THROUGH THE ATTEMPTED GENOCIDE
THAT BUILT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YEAH WE HAVE
PERSEVERED AND CONTINUED TO
RECONNECT TO OUR CULTURE THE
FAMILY. MADE A COMMUNITY
CONTINUE TO FACE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SUICIDE AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IN THE NATION
AND OUR RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
THAT CULTURAL PRACTICES ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE FOR IMPROVING
MENTAL HEALTH. ONE OF OUR YOUTH
EVEN WROTE IN THEIR JOURNALS
WHICH WE COLLECTED COLD I
NEEDED TO PROGRAM THIS WEEKEND
BUT I WOULD LOVE IT EVERY
WEEKEND I AM PROUD TO BE
INDIAN. AND QUOTE ARE YOU TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT. MENTAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. MANY HAVE THERE'S
SOME THE MOST OF. BY COVERED
TEN. AND IT WILL BE A PANDEMIC
PRO THAT ARE COMMUNITY. A
CULTURALLY. WHICH WILL PROVIDE
THE PRACTICES BERNIE PEOPLE.
STOPPING PROGRAM NOW WOULD
BETTER TO OUR COMMUNITY TO BE
CULTURE APPROACH SERVICE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE- OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE FACE. THE THAT
WE IN OUR- AND I GOING THE
JUDGE. THAT A HALF THROUGHOUT
THIS NATION. THE CALIFORNIA A
THIRTY. EVEN ON PRESIDENT
INITIATIVE. WE ARE HERE TO NOT
ONLY HOW THE F. OF OUR PRO BUT
THE HOUSE WILL HAVE A BIG-
URGENCY IT CONTINUED TO FUNDED.
PROGRAM PLEASE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED FIFTY NINE ONE FUNDING
THIS YEAR. AND HIS NAME
APPEARED TO BE THREE EDITION
YEARS. SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
GOOD WORK. IN OUR COMMUNITY. AT
YEAH. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO NINE ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL FIRST OF
ALL I WANTED THANK YOU DR
GRAHAM DEALER AND GET.
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO YOU
VANCE. YOU LISTENING TO
EVERYONE THAT YOU GIVE EVERYONE
BEHIND BARS. DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU CARE
ABOUT ALL OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M ABLE I GAVE THE
PRESIDENT CALLED NINE. AFRICAN
AMERICAN HUB OF THIS IDPS AND
WE HAVE THE TRIED PROGRAMS.
WE'VE BILLION TO BILLION THANK
CONNECTING. I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT VALUATION EVIDENCE BASED
OUTCOMES BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS
BEEN GREATLY MISUNDERSTOOD.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT HAVING A
STATE ONE VALUATION. TAKES IT
KIND OF THE TOP LEVEL DEAL- AS
A GROUP- WHAT IT IS BUT-
OUTCOME THE BIGGEST THAT
LEGISLATION IS AFFECTED THIRTY
FIVE FLOOD MITIGATION DOWN
READING. OF PROGRAMS FOR FOUR
YEARS. AND THE EASY WHEN CARE I
HAVE- INDICATED THAT. ARE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
ARE SUCCESSFUL NOW IT'S NOT
SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE
DEMONSTRATED IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO. TWENTY THREE AT SOME POINT
IT'S BEEN DEMONSTRATED IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
WILL BE DOING BLACK IT DON'T
MATTER AND EVEN IN THOUGH BLACK
MEN THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY AND-
OF ALL AGES THAT THE TICKET
LIKE SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE. SIX
ONE NINE YEAR OLD AFRICAN
AMERICAN. YEAH MAN WITHOUT
MONEY DOWN ASSEMBLY ON HEALTH
BUSINESSES HERE THE TRAUMA AND
DEPRESSION INTERCEPTED BY COOK
THE MAJORITY OF THESE YOUNG
MEN. AND ALL RIGHT AWAY SHE
SAID HUNDREDS OF YOUNG MEN FIND
IT MORE THAN ONE STATED THAT
THE CONTENT OF COMMENT AND
ALMOST A HALF. OF DEPRESSION
GET OUT OF FOUR HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS THAT I HAVE
PERSONALLY INTERVIEWED ONLY WE
HAVE RECEIVED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND TWO OF THESE. WERE
ORDERED BY THEIR COLOGNE AND- I.
COMBINES. NEVER GOING TO GO TO
BOTH OF ARE. WE DON'T WHERE
THERE NO COMPETENT CARE THE
WEEDS THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE WITH THE DISORDERS BETTER
BEEN THROWN AWAY THEY DON'T OF
GANGS WELL WE NEVER THOUGHT OF
BASIS FOR THEM SO WHAT WE HAVE
TO DEMOCRAT POPIEL ATOMIC IN
CLINICAL GROUP WE HAVE NO BANKS
OUT WITH A DEVELOP NEW CONCEPTS
OF SELF IDENTITY AND POSITIVE
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT NEW MENTAL
MODELS AND WILL USE. EVERY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ONLY OF
JUVENILES WHICH FOCUSES ON THE
PAVEMENT IF SUPPORTERS. THE
DALLAS ST THOMAS IT WOULD COME
ALIVE BECAUSE HE NEEDED AN
EXECUTED ON THE SPEECH BY THE
POLICE. WELL THERE IN A MOMENT
OF DRAMA. IN A COMMUNITY THAT
HAS SIXTY. OF THE ONLY A YOUNG
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE ON IS
LESS THAN TWO THIRDS. APPLE
PALCA THAT EVERYTHING THEY
OUTCOME. OF PROGRAM IS TO WHERE
IS AS WE- YOU ARE. THEY PUT
THEIR DOWN THEY SEE HOPE THING
MOVED FROM THE STATE TO BE. HE
EVIDENCE BASED OUT. I DON'T
THAT OUT OF GAME. CHANGING IN
MY AND WE BE. THAT INCOME AND
JUST TRANCE. FROM HEALTH
WORKERS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
DID YOU PAINT. THEY'RE GOING TO
COME. GETTING THE AGENT NEEDS.
SAID THEIR OWN BUSINESS BUT.
HELLO MY SO BOB THOUGHT OF.
PHONE THAT. I EIGHT OUTCOME
OCTOBER HAS BEEN IS DOWN. AND
THE VALUE HAVE BEEN AT THE
EVERY TO GO THEY STATEWIDE THIS
EVENT YEAH ON THE EIGHT MINUTES
ON GRANT BECAUSE STATES HAVE IN.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILL.
INCLUDING STATE IN ADDITION TO
THE PHYSICAL OUTCOMES THAT I
JUST WELL EACH ONE OF THE
THIRTY FIVE PROJECT. DOESN'T
VALUATION. YEAH BOB HUNT THAT
DEMONSTRATED THAT BASS ALKA
JUST LIKE ON THEM WE NEED A
BRIDGE WE NEED TO COME TO. A
STATE STATE. DON'T CARE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE MOST
UNDERSTOOD THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS 63% OF THE
POPULATION OF THIS STATE THERE
ARE DIFFERENT THEN WHAT THAN
WHAT THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ARE DESIGNED FOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU O VERY
MUCH AND I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. IT IS A
PRIVILEGE AND ESPECIALLY AT
THIS LATE HOUR TO I HAVE YOUR
EAR AND TO HEAR FROM SO MANY OF
MY- COLLEAGUES OUT- FOR ON THE
LINE AS WELL. MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES DISPARITIES FOR THE
STATE BOTH LOCAL RACIAL AND
ETNIC POPULATION.
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT OF
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS DISPARITIES PRODUCTION.
THE OTHER THREE RD T. IT IS A
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE TO ELIMINATE
STIGMA. AND CONTRIBUTE TO
REDUCTIONS IN THE SEVERITY OF
MENTAL ILLNESS FOR FIVE
PRIORITY POPULATIONS. THIS
INVESTMENT PUT CALIFORNIA AHEAD
OF THE NATION IN RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO INTENTIONALLY
ADDRESS DISPARITIES. CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT IS
AN UNPRECEDENTED HISTORIC CROSS
POPULATION SOLUTION THAT HAS
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE AND A
STATE NATIONAL OR INTERNATIONAL
LEVEL. RAJINIKANTH'S VALUE
VALUE TO THE PRIORITY GENERALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS THAT
IT IS DESIGNED TO SERVE AFTER
MANY YEARS OF FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL APPROACHES
AT THE STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL.
THAT REALLY CONTRIBUTED TO
ONGOING AND- HISTORIC TRAUMA BY
REINFORCING IN ENFORCING RACIST
AND DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
BUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
OPEN THE DOOR FOR A GENERATION.
OF PRACTICES AND POLICIES TO
BEGIN TRANSFORMING OUR
ASSUMPTIONS AND APPROACHES.
THIS IS THE CRT P. IT IS
ESTABLISHING A PLATFORM FOR
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES SO THAT YOU HEARD
MUCH ABOUT FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
TO ORIENT AND GROUND THE NEXT
GENERATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. ROGIC MOST CERTAINLY
WARRANTS EXTENDED FUNDING AS
WAS ASKED EARLIER IN THE DAY.
INTENTIONAL FUNDING. AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH I BELIEVE
SHOULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY LARGER
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THREE ADDITIONAL YEARS. IS THE
VERY LEAST THAT THE STATE
SHOULD INVEST ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ALL THAT WE KNOW IS COMING UPON
US WITH THIS WAVE OF POST CODE
STRUCT THIS ORDER. C. R. D. T.
IS CRITICALLY NECESSARY FOR
COMMUNITY INTERVENTION AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH. IT IS WORTHY OF
FURTHER INVESTMENT I CANNOT
REPEAT THAT MORE EARLIER ON THE
CALL WHEN I HEARD A DIRECTOR
TOBY EWING REFER TO THE
DEVASTATING HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
STRESSES FACED BY COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR BECAUSE OF KOBE
NINETEEN. I THOUGHT WHILE JUST
BE DEVASTATING HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC STRESSES WHILE THOSE
EXISTED PRIOR TO COVERT
NINETEEN BECAUSE IT NINETEEN.
HAVE BEHAVE LIKE A BLOWTORCH ON
THE ALREADY UNDER RESTORED ILL
SERVED CULTURALLY NEGLECTED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY THE BLACK
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BLACK
WOMEN'S HEALTH PROJECT WE ARE
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD STATE MY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO IMPROVE. THE HEALTH
AND WELLNESS FOR THE STATE'S
ONE POINT TWO MILLION BLACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. MY NAME
IS SONYA YOUNG THE DON AND I'M
THE CEO OF THE ORGANIZATION WE
ARE ASKING THAT THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED A MINIMUM OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FROM
THE SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL FUND
OR ANY OTHER. SOURCES THIS YEAR
TO SUSTAIN THE CRT P. FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL YEARS BLACK WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE THE- HEALTH OF
OUR HEALTH THE- HAS A HELPFUL.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE HEAD OF OUR
HOUSEHOLD AND ALL THE HEADS OF
OUR HOUSE WE- THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE WORK THAT
THE CALIFORNIA BLACHOWICZ HELP
PROJECT HAS DONE THROUGH THE
SISTERS NOT ONLY MOBILIZED
IMPLEMENTATION PILOT PROJECT.
HAS SHOWN VERY STRONG EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT BLACK WOMEN WHO DO
NOT FIND A STATE SPACE IN A
SAFE PLACE TO SEEK MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IN THE TRADITIONAL
SYSTEM I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I REALLY DO HOPE THAT WE
WILL SEE A POSITIVE OUTCOME.
FROM TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS YOLANDA RANDALL'S I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE WEST HAS NO
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER AND R.
I. P. B. PROJECT IS CALLED THIS
WEEK TO CREATE A PROJECT. HELLO
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING MYSELF TO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT OUR
PROGRAMS HERE THIS WE WOULD
HAVE A PROGRAM- LIKE MANY OF
OUR USE THAT OUR PARENTS- SAY
IT BRINGS HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY
FOR FAMILIES AND I JUST WANT TO
READ SOMETHING REAL QUICKLY-
PART OF OUR PROGRAM- THE USE
HAPPEN IN THE RISE DISCREET AND
IT SAYS I AM TODAY'S HARVEST.
CHANGING TOMORROW'S FUTURE I
WILL FIGHT AGAINST ALL ODDS
THEIR STAND AGAINST ME MY
CIRCUMSTANCES SHALL NOT DEFINED
ME I WILL NOT BE SHACKLED BY
FEAR INSECURITIES ARE DOUBT MY
PASTOR IT IS MY PRESENT WHICH
COMPLEMENTS MY FUTURE I WILL
NEVER GIVE UP EVER I CHAU
SIXTY. YES RIGHT THE MANY
THIRTY FIVE FIVE TWO THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I KNOW BE CONTINUALLY
CONTINUOUSLY FIGHT YOU KNOW FOR
A FAMILY REQUIRED FOR UC'S
SENIOR SENIORS TO PROVIDE THE
GREAT PROGRAMS SO TODAY I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER ONE TO FULLY- IT'S FUN
THIS IS FANTA BILITY OF THE C.
R. D. PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
CRITICAL. THAT THESE PROGRAMS
CONTINUE OUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
AGAIN AND PLEASE CONSIDER
ASCERTAINING ARE WORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM AND THANKS
FOR INVITING ME TO THE HARVEST
WITH THE STUDENTS. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE WHAT. WE GO TO LINE TWO
OH EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHIU RAM COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND STAFF MY NAME IS
MARIE COULD CALL A MEMBER OF
BECAUSE PACIFICA CENTERS
CHILDREN AND FAMILY. FAMILIES
IN THE INTENT OF OUR COUNTY
WEAKENED WORKING WITH AT RISK
YOUTH AND FAMILY FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AT THIS POINT
I'M CALLING IN REGARDS TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE THE FUNDING FOR
THE OPPOSITE SIDE PREVENTION-
FIRST BILL IT IF I CAN'T THE
REQUIREMENTS THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS FOR CHAMPIONING.
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE FOR US I
WANT TO BOYS ART AGENCY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE. A HIGH
LEVEL COORDINATION NEEDED.
STOCKS NOW MORE EVER- AS THE NO
HAVE BEEN NO. BY PRE SPEAKERS
THE CURRENT DATA THAT WILL
READING ABOUT IN THE PAPERS
EVERY DAY. THE SOCIAL SOCIAL
ISOLATION THE DISTANCE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING B. AS DOOM
STARING AT A SCREEN FOR HOURS
EVERY DAY OVER THE PAST ELEVEN
AND A HALF MONTHS. THE LACK OF
CONNECTION AND FRIENDSHIP AND
PLAYING ON THE SCHOOLYARD
DEPARTED FROM UNDER THREE.
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR ADOLESCENT MENTAL
HEALTH AS YOU ARE ALL WELL
AWARE- AND I WONDER JUST
REMINDED THE THEY- NEED FOR OUR
PRECIOUS RESOURCES ARE OUR
COUNTRY'S FUTURE LEADERS. AND
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THEM WE NEED
THIS OFFICE TO PROVIDE THOSE OF
US IN THE FIELD WITH THE MOST
CURRENT DATA AND THE BEST
PRACTICES AVAILABLE. SO WE CAN
SUPPORT THESE PRECIOUS
CHILDREN- IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
COMPETITION CAN SURELY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME CONVENING
THIS HEARING DROPPING ALL OF
THE CRITICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES IMPACTING THE LIVES OF
OUR CHILDREN. ADOLESCENTS AND
YOUNG ADULTS. SO FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE. THE CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE TO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR THE THIRD CARD BUT SPEND
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AN
INDEPENDENT NON PROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE WE FOCUS IS TO
ADVANCE SOUND PUBLIC POLICY ON
THE ISSUE THE BRAIN HOW.
GRATEFUL THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
HOLDING A HEARING AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING ISSUES OF BRAIN HOW.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS OUR EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT WITHIN FOR ANTI
ISSUES ON TODAY'S AGENDA ISSUE
TO INSURING CHILDREN RECEIVE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO YOU
INCLUDING THE PROPOSED FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. ISSUE FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FOCUS ON IDENTIFYING GAPS AND
TARGETING FUNDS WHERE THEY'RE
MOST NEEDED. ISSUES FIVE-
SUPPORT MAKING TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITY PERMANENT ALSO A CO
FOUNDER AND CTO THREE LAST YEAR
ESTABLISHING THE KERR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WHICH
REALLY APPRECIATE TO BE MARKED
ON THE ITEM OPEN AND WITH THE
POOREST- NOT FUNDED TO SUPPORT
EACH OFFICE WORK. WE ALSO
APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION'S
WORK ON CAL EIGHTEEN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT MOVE
FORWARD AND FINALLY ISSUE SEVEN
FROM THE MEDICAL INFORMATION ON
A- TO SERVICE ACROSS THE STATE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU OUR PROFESSION
DOT COM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NIXEUS LINE TO EIGHTEEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU ALLOWING
US TO HAVE THIS TIME GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS MOLLY WILSON
AND I'M WITH THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMPANIES SERVICES WHICH IS A
PROGRAM OF HEALTH RIGHT THREE
SIXTY I AM REPRESENTING THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT THE PROGRAM
WHICH IS SPECIFIC ON THE
FOCUSED PROGRAM WHICH EVERYONE
UP THIRTY FIVE IP PIECE FOR
CALIFORNIA. REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR SUSTAINING RDP
CALIFORNIA REDUCE UNNECESSARY
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN SO
VALUABLE TO OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES BY SUPPORTING OUR
ON THE GROUND LEADERS TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH OUR PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IN ADDRESSING TABOO.
TOPICS SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH.
HE R. T. P. HAS SUPPORT. I'M
HAS ALREADY OUR COLD PROGRAM
EACH SO WE CAN. THE BRIDGE YOU
DON'T HELP BRIDGE THOSE GAPS
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH AND
PROMISES. TO SEE RDP WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD TRUST WITH
THOSE WHO DID NOT TRUST THE
SYSTEM. AND THAT'S BASICALLY
OUR COMMUNITY. CIDP HAS HELPED
US LEARN HOW TO TEACH OUR
COMMITTEES ABOUT DATA. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT TO TELL OUR
STORIES. AND IF WE- ALL OF A
SUDDEN DISAPPEAR OUR COMMUNITY
IS NOT GOING TO TRUST ANYMORE.
AN EXAMPLE IS IN OUR PACIFIC ON
A COMMUNITY THERE IS LITTLE TO
NO DOUBT. ABOUT IT HIMSELF THAT
IS BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF TRUST
SO BY HAVING CULTURAL SPECIFIC
PROGRAM. ALLOWS US TO BREAK
DOWN THESE BARRIERS. IN ORDER
FOR COMPANIES TO THRIVE. WE
NEED TO HAVE THESE CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. OF LONGITUDE
I PUBLIC DRIVE BECAUSE I'M
GETTING SO EMOTIONAL. ABUSE
PUBLIC PROGRAMS ARE ONLY A
BANDAID WILL HELP TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT. AND FUND PROGRAMS
LIKE DON'T. OFFERED TO CRT P.
HOPE INVEST IN US SO WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO SUPPORT
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR C. R. T.
P. SO WE CAN CONTINUE. TO BREAK
DOWN THE WALLS THE STIGMA AND
BUILD OUR COMMUNITIES UP
WELLNESS. SO IN MY CULTURAL
LANGUAGE AND ONE SHAPE. PUBLIC
HIGH LEVEL. WHICH IS THANK YOU
SOMEONE. MAILLOL PEOPLE WHICH
IS THANK YOU AND TANIA AND
MODEL WHICH IS THANK YOU
IMPOSITION. BLESS YOU ALL THANK
YOU HAVE A GOOD NIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PASS AND THAT.
NEXT PLEASE. GO TO LINE TWO OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GETTING OLD- MY NAME JESSICA
THE SENIOR RESEARCH ANALYST
SERVICE FOR GROUPS ANGELES WE
CERVANTES ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
WITHIN THAT ADDITIONAL PARK FOR
THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
POPULATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK TONIGHT I
SUPPORT EXTENDED FUNDING FOR
THE SECURITY KEY BY THREE YEARS
AFTER KILLING DOLLARS- HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM ANY OF MY-
COLLEAGUES AND I THIS
UNPRECEDENTED INITIATIVE IS
HELPING IN ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY BY UP
LOOKING AND EVALUATING THESE
COMMUNITY DRIVEN SOLUTIONS
ABOUT THE EXPERTISE.
REPRESENTED BY THE PANELISTS
AND LYFT IS EXTRAORDINARY BUT-
TO REALIZE WHAT SOME OF THE
FOLKS CALLING IN THE FOLKS WHO
ARE LEADING THIS ORGANIZATIONS
WHO BRING TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
TO LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY AND
WISDOM- THE SECURITY PIECE
SERVES VERY COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY I'M
DEFINITELY IMPACTED BY CO THE
NINETEEN. AND WE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER THIS EVENING ABOUT
THE WAVE OF POST PANDEMIC
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WILL FACE AND THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES BY TONY THIS. OF
BARBERTON BUT AFTER- BUT I
STILL WANTED TO UNDERSCORE THAT
A BIG PART OF THE VALUE IS
ALLOWING A COLLECTIVELY TO
APPLY THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THIS INITIATIVE AND INTEGRATE
THESE MODELS AND TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM AND THE LEFT IS
REALLY WILL BE EXPENSIVE IN
PART BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY
OF STRATEGIES AND PROGRAMS
REPRESENTED BY THESE GRANTEES.
I BELIEVE THE PRELIMINARY DATA
BIRTH STRONG INDICATION OF THE
POWER OF COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE PROGRAMS WE CANNOT LET
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THESE
PROGRAMS. TO SCALE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. CAN YOU.
NICE COLOR PLEASE. GO TO LINE
TWO SIXTEEN GO AHEAD. WELL GOOD
EVENING- AND- I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK- VERY MUCH- AND- GOING
AND- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF SERVICE HAVING THIS- MEETING
THIS EVENING AT ALLOWING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
ARE MELMASON AND I AM THE-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CLINICAL
DIRECTOR WELL AS CO FOUNDER. OF
AN AGENCY CALLED THE VILLAGE
PROJECT INCORPORATED IN SEASIDE.
FROM I AM HERE TO. IN STRONG
SUPPORT STRONG SUPPORT. OF THE
EXTENSION YOU KNOW OF OUR I. P.
PLEASE- I R. I. P. P. THIS CALL
AND IN THE OPERA. WHICH IS A
MAASAI WORD FOR WARRIORS CAMP
AND WE HAVE. WE STARTED OUR
PROGRAM FOUR YEARS AGO. HELLO
WITH CHILDREN. OF AFRICAN
ANCESTRY- GRADES K. THROUGH
FOUR AND SO FOR THE FOUR YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WATCH. TV ON
PEOPLE. ARE REALLY BE WARRIORS
WARRIORS ABOUT THEIR OWN HEALTH
WORRIES ABOUT THEIR WELL BEING.
AND WARRIORS IN TERMS OF THEIR
LOVE AND AFFECTION FOR EACH
OTHER AND FOR THEIR COMMUNITY-
IT WAS. OUR PROMISE THAT- GOING
TO. OF AB ANSWERS. LEARNED
THEIR CHIU AND THAT IDENTITY.
BUT THE STRENGTH IN THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF WHO THEY ARE. WILL
SERVE TO PREVENT THEM FROM
HAVING- EVER DEVELOPING A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT WOULD
BECOME SEVERE AND DISABLING AND
WE HAVE SEEN THAT INDUCED FOUR
YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM- COMMITTEE OPERATIONS
ABOUT RITUAL. IT'S ABOUT HABITS
IT'S ABOUT- TRANSFERRING THE
MEMORY AND THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
EXISTENCE OF THEIR ANCESTORS
AND WHAT THEIR ANCESTORS HAD
PROVIDED FOR THEM IN TERMS F
LEGACY- WE'VE HAD INSTANCES
WHERE CHILDREN HAVE GONE FROM
BEING ON THE GRADE LEVEL- TO
BEING- BEYOND GREAT LOVE- AND
ONE OF THOSE THOSE YOUNGSTERS-
HAD MENTIONED. THAT THE REASON
WHY HE WAS ABLE TO DO HAT WAS
BECAUSE HE SOLD IT TO A
FANTASTIC. WE HAVE HOW ARE ALL
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE INCLUDING
THEIR PARENTS HAD NEVER BEEN.
COOPED THERE ARE PRETTY ARE YOU
NEVER SAW ANY KIND OF CLINICAL
SERVICES BEFORE BUT NOW THEY
ARE THERE THEY TALK ABOUT. TO
HELP TO RAISE STAKE MY- I'VE
BEEN TRYING ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT GOTTEN OUR YOUNG. ARE
YOUNG WARRIORS THROUGH OF THE
PANDEMIC AND NOT ALL OF THIS
THAT WILL HAPPENING CALLS BLACK
MATTER- TO COME TO THE FORE.
THE THING THAT HAS GOTTEN
CURRENT DOWN THROUGH ALL OF
THIS WITH THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE SATURDAYS WHERE THEY ALL
COME TOGETHER. AS WARRIORS OF
STUFF SYSTEMS AND BROTHERS
BEING ABLE TO SHOW UP FOR EACH
OTHER. AND THAT STRENGTH THAT
COMES FROM THAT HAVE GOTTEN
GOING THROUGH THESE REALLY
TOUGH TIMES. I THINK IT WOULD
BE- BUT SHANE IF- THESE- FIVE
PP IS WERE NOT EXTENDED. AND-
SO I AM MAKING. THE STRONGEST
CASE POP CAN. FOR THE EXTENT OF
ALL OF OUR I. T. TO USE. THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. I THINK
IS NORMAL ENOUGH TO GIVE UP I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS THAT
OBVIOUSLY WAY MORE. BUT I'M
JUST HERE TO AGAIN- PUSH FOR
AND SUPPORT YOU KNOW THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE EXTEND. THESE
IDPS BECAUSE COULD NOT DO SO I
THANK BUT KEEP YET ANOTHER AND
JUSTICE. ON THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT C. R. D. P.
WAS DESIGNED TO OUTLAST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREETINGS HOW
TAP THE GARDEN NAY GREETS THE
GOD IN YOU THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS REGINA MASON
AND I AM WITH THE VILLAGE
PROJECT IN SEASIDE CALIFORNIA
IN MONTEREY COUNTY AND I'D TO
M. ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF
THE VILLAGE PROJECT- THE
VILLAGE PROJECT CAME TO
FRUITION AS A RESULT. OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE
BEING UNDERSERVED WHEN YOU LOOK
AT ALL OF OUR I. P. P. ACROSS
THE THIRTY FIVE OF THEM WE'RE
DOING WORK IN R. I. P. P. THAT
COUNTIES AND SYSTEMS CANNOT DO
BY SPENT A CAREER IN THE FIELD
OF CHILD WELFARE AND THAT
STIMULATED A NEED TO PROVIDE
AFRICAN AMERICANS WITH. A
PROGRAM AND WITH CLINICAL
SUPPORT THAT COULD MEET THEIR
THEIR NEEDS FROM A CULTURAL
PERSPECTIVE THE PEOPLE THAT
COME TO OUR CLINIC AND R. I. P.
P. HAVE NEVER HAD THERAPY IN
THEIR LIVES AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE HAVE SEEN YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO UNDERSTAND THEIR
CULTURAL IDENTITY AND HERITAGE
UPLIFTING THEIR SELF THAT
HAVING HIGH EAGLE FUNCTIONING
GOING FROM BEING EXPELLED FROM
SCHOOL TO. BEING SCHOLARS AND
SO I AM URGING YOU WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT MAKES DECISIONS
ABOUT THE BLACK LIVES IN THE
OTHER LAWS OF UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE THAT REALLY DO MATTER IN
THE SOCIETY TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND TO. SUSTAIN THIS-
THREE YEAR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- PROJECTS WERE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA AND I
REALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING AND- BY- APPRECIATE
YOU CONSIDERING THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- WE GO TO TWO TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M TO TWENTY
FOUR LINES OPEN. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS I WANT TO ECHO THAT IT
IS TRULY AN HONOR TO BE HERE
THIS EVENING. ALONG WITH MY
SIBLING PROJECTS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT MY NAME IS
DR NINA MORE AND ALL AND I AM
THE RESEARCH AND STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS DIRECTOR WITH SAFE
PASSAGES ONE OF THIRTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION PROJECTS. PART
OF THE C. R. D. P. THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT AND ONE OF SEVEN
PROJECT OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
HUB OF THE C. R. D. P. I AM
ALSO ONE OF THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
EVALUATORS THAT ARE YOU VALUE
WAITING- THE- ONE OF THIRTY
FIVE IMPLEMENTATION PROJECT
SAFE PASSAGES IS. COMMUNITY TO
FIND EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
CALLED THE LAW AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE LIFE COACHING PROGRAM
AND I'M EVALUATING THE PROGRAM
BOTH AT THE LOCAL AND AS PART
OF THE STATEWIDE EVALUATION.
AND IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
SAFE PASSAGES TEAM I HAVE BEEN
INTRICATELY INVOLVED WITH THE
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
ITS LOCAL AND STATEWIDE
EVALUATION AND I CAN ATTEST
FIRSTHAND THAT SAFE PASSAGES OF
LIFE COACHING PROGRAM HAS HAD A
MULTITUDE OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUTH. AND
FAMILIES THAT HAVE SERVED IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY C. R. D. T. IS
ON PRESIDENTE IT IS HISTORIC IT
IS CROP POPULATION IT IS
SOLUTION BASED AND IT ENTAILS A
RIGOROUS EVALUATION FOR EVAN-
INITIATIVE. OUR C. R. D. P. HAS
BEEN FUNDED AT THE STATE CREWS
MENTAL SERVICE ACT BUT UNLESS
ACTION IS TAKEN. IT WILL CEASE
IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
CONSIDERING THE C. R. D. P.
ATTRACTIVELY SERVES THE VERY
POPULATIONS THAT SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN TWENTY
TWENTY. TO THE CODED NINETEEN
HANDS THAT MAKE AND THE RACIAL
RECKONING AFTER THE VERY PUBLIC
KILLINGS OF BLACK PEOPLE WE
HAVE HEARD ABOUT MANY OF THESE
ISSUES DURING TODAY'S HEARING
NOT ONLY IS THE VALUE. AND
WORTHINESS OF ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT OBVIOUS BUT IT IS
URGENT. FOR MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IT IS A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE C. R. D. T.
B. SUSTAIN THE BUY ONE.
EXTENDING THE CURRENT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND EVALUATION NUMBER TWO
CREATING A MECHANISM FOR
SCALING THE PROGRAMS AT THE
LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL AND NUMBER
THREE DEVELOPING PLANS FOR A
PHASE THREE THAT EXPAND THIRD
INSTANCE TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL POPULATIONS. AND
SYSTEMS CHANGE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONE TIME FUNDING
EITHER FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE
GENERAL FUND OR ANY OTHER
SOURCE. THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THESE THREE
GOALS THIS ONE TIME FUNDING
WOULD SUSTAIN THE C. R. D. P.
FOR THREE ADDITIONAL YEARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE TWO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NAMI CALIFORNIA AB
YOU'LL HAVE OUR LETTER SHORTLY
AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR YOU AND
ALL THE CALLERS WAITING SO
PATIENTLY WITH REALLY IMPORTANT
STORIES TO SHARE- THAT WILL BE
THE LONGEST PART OF MY TEST
MONEY WHAT I JUST SAID NOW-
ONE. MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACTS PROPOSAL. WORK
COUNTY THE SCHOOLS ARE READY
LET'S GET THIS TREATMENT A KIDS
NUMBER TWO TWO MILLION TWO
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
SUPPORT NUMBER THREE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS MONEY
GOING TO THE PEOPLE WE LOVE
SUPPORT YOUR MY TIME TO THE
NEXT CALLER THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS
TO THE TIMELINE TWO OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS. HERE THIS
EVENING TO SUPPORT TWO OF THE
MANY- WERE THE ITEMS THAT YOU
HAVE ON THE AGENDA TONIGHT- THE
FIRST THING ISSUE EIGHT WHICH
WORLD GIVES- IMPLEMENTATION
STAFF. AT BEFORE- SIX OF THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES CAN REFER OUT CASES
WHERE THEY FIND ENTITIES OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE HORRIBLE
PRACTICE. OF BY BROKERING AND
THE ADDICTION TREATMENT
INDUSTRY TO AN APPROPRIATE
JURISDICTION FOR THE
PROSECUTION I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION THIS
EVENING TO A STATE THAT WAS
JUST PUBLISHED LAST WEEK AND
HELPED VERY- JOURNAL IN WHICH
RESEARCHERS- ACTING AS MYSTERY
SHOPPERS IN THE ADDICTION
TREATMENT INDUSTRY CALLED FROM
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. TO BUY THEIR RECORDING
TECHNIQUES THEY FOUND THAT 43%
OF THE PROGRAM HAD SURPRISING
AND TROUBLING HARD SELL TACTICS
THAT HAPPENED EVEN BEFORE
COLORS WERE GREEN TO ASSESS
THEIR NEED FOR TREATMENT OR
EVEN TO DETERMINE IF THE
PROGRAM MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR
THEIR NEEDS. I THOUGHT THE
THIRD OF THE COLORS WERE OFTEN
OFFERED A SPOT IN AN ELECTION
TREATMENT PROGRAM BEFORE THEY
HAD EVEN HAD ANY CLINICAL
EVALUATION CURRENTLY CONGRESS
IS DEBATING THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN WHICH WILL SUPPLY
FORTUNATELY AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE SAM
SHOULD GO BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
PROGRAM. UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH
DISTRIBUTION OF MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM WE KNOW FROM PAST
EXPERIENCE WILL ALSO BRING MORE
BODY BROKERS SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT THING ITEM THE SECOND
ISSUE IS ISSUE FOR- DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES CONTINUUM
OF CARE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIRTY DAYS OF INPATIENT
TREATMENT OR FORTY SIX WEEKS OF
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION. DOES
NOT CARE OF THIS CHRONIC
RELAPSING DISEASE THE OPTIONS
FOR STEP DOWN THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED UNDER THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT WILL
REDUCE RELAPSE IMPROVE. PROGRAM
AFTER CARRIED HERE AND IMPROVE
THE CONTINUE OF. MEDICAID AND
TO TREAT. FOR PEOPLE WITH
ADDICTION HAS TIME TO STOP.
PEOPLE AND OUT OF. IT'S TIME TO
PEOPLE IN EARLY. WITH THE FUNDS
THAT WE PROVIDED. BY
DISINVESTMENT THANK YOU AND
GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT NEXT
WE GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOLLOW FORGET
EVENING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
LORI MCKENNA AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF B. S. AND SOMEONE
OF PROGRAM JUST ONE OF THE
THIRTY FIVE IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECTS THAT SERVES THE
PACIFIC ISLANDER POPULATION.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE AND
THERE. ANDTHE EXTENSION OF THE
C. R. D. P. SHARED MAYBE HAD TO
CLOSE TO HOME AS IT SERVES THE
VERY COMMUNITY THAT HAS RAISED
ME. I COMMUNITIES HAVE GONE
LONG ENOUGH BEING UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED. SUSTAINING THE C.
RDP PROJECT GIVES HOPE TO OUR
PEOPLE THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO GET SERVICE FOR ANOTHER
THREE YEARS. ANOTHER THREE
YEARS OF ACCESS TO CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND SPECIFIC
PROGRAMMING. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT LOOK LIKE ME
LOOK LIKE OUR ELDERS LIKE ARE
YOU. AND LASTLY THREE MORE
YEARS OF KNOWING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY WILL BE TAKING CARE
OF. THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE TO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS BOB LANE
ON BEHALF OF THE VHA
REPRESENTING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE
SERVING OVER HALF A MILLION
CLIENTS WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITEMS TO THREE AND A LOT OF
AND AS THEY WILL HELP BOLSTER
THE CRITICAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS IN NEED
OF OUR FINANCIAL SUPPORT. IN
GENERAL WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES CRITICAL
HELP OUR PROVIDERS TO ON THE
FRONT LINES OF BEHAVIORAL
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES THAT
ALSO INCLUDES THE LINE THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
THAT SPONSORED PROPELLED WALTER%
FROM THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
AND THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COMMUNITY CONTINUUM OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IN
GENERAL WE ALSO ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER BOB IT'S GOT
THE NEED ISSUES TO FURTHER WE
ALIGN DOT- DOLLARS TO LOCAL
AGENCIES AND PROVIDERS THAT ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THROUGH
REMOVING ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
SUCH AS THE INVESTMENT SCHOOL
THROUGH MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS THE STATE WILL BE A
STRONGER ALIGNMENT OF THESE
DOLLARS CLOSER TO THE POINT OF
CARE AND WE'LL LIFESAVING
DISSIPATED WHEN UNNECESSARY.
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLAY.
WE GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
SHARE HAT THE FAIR TO CAT
REPRESENTING RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA I
WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY COMMENT
ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ARE HERE
HE STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
TRAINER RESOURCES INVESTMENT IS
CRITICAL TO EXPAND CAPACITY AT
THE BEAVER HEALTH SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MA'AM THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. TO GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD H.
YES THIS IS KAREN REFLECT MYERS
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COSTA PARO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE PROVIDE
INTENSIVE TREATMENT SERVICES TO
TEENAGERS. AND I AM CALLING IN
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ITEM NUMBER THREE ON THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR REALLY
PRIORITIZING THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE- WE HAVE A FRONT LINE SEE
THE EFFECTS OF. OF DEATH BY
SUICIDE- ALL THE TIME AND WE
ARE SO PLEASED TO SEE THE
PRIORITIZATION. OF THESE
CHILDREN IN NEED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
FOCUSING ON ANOTHER MEANT NOT
AN UNDERSEA OKAY PASSAGES AND
WE ARE PART OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN HUB OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION- IN A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS YEAR EIGHTY
HE AND THE PASSION AND
COMMITMENT TO THIS INITIATIVE
AND THE POPULATIONS THAT WE
SERVE HAS COME THROUGH- VERY
CLEARLY OUT WE ARE ALL VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
AND GIVE THIS PUBLIC COMMENT-
I'D LIKE TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
ON THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
CULTURE AND SCIENCE THAT THIS
YEAR TO KEEP UP PERCENT- I
THINK. OFTEN IT'S MISSED THAT
THIS IS AN INITIATIVE THAT IS
SIMULTANEOUSLY IMPLEMENTING
THIRTY SIX EVALUATIONS ALL
DESIGNED TO BUILD THE EVIDENCE
BASE TO SUPPORT CONTINUING TO
FIND EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE
SERVING. DEVALUATION HAVE ALL
THE SEEDS STATE IRB APPROVAL IT
IS EVALUATIONS ALSO- HAVE
EMPLOYED CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
ACCOMPLISH THE SEARCHERS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITIES AND
SOME OF THE MOST RESPECTED
EVALUATION FIRMS IN THE
COUNTRY. WE ARE PRODUCING
ANOTHER IN SPACE THAT MAKES THE
CASE FOR CLEANING TO FIND
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES AND
THERE ARE A LONG LIST OF
POWERFUL MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
THAT WE ARE PRODUCING WITH JUST
A SMALL FRACTION OF THE TOTAL
MENTAL. HEALTH FUNDING
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE. WE ARE
HERE TO A THE STATE OF. SO TO
SUSPEND THE RACISM AT ITS CORE
MORE IN. OR NOT ONLY ARE WE
TRYING TO ADDRESS
INTERGENERATIONAL DISPARITIES
AND INEQUITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES. BUT ALSO WE ARE AND AT
THE FRONT LINE IN THE CURRENT
MINE IN TERMS OF DEALING WITH
APCO THAT NINETEEN IN TRYING TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT. OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE POPULATIONS
THAT WERE SERVING. WE'RE HERE
REPRESENTING AN UNPRECEDENTED
COALITION OF THIRTY FIVE
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ARE HERE
REPRESENTING A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO SELF DETERMINATION IN
EQUITY. TOWARDS THAT END WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
REQUEST FOR A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR EXTENSION OF THE C. R.
D. P. AND THE SCALABILITY
ACTUALLY THE FIND EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE. PRACTICES TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM THAT HAS
IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITIES. SENSE
BARELY BEFORE IT EVEN THE
FOUNDING OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE ARE HOPING FOR A
POSITIVE RESULT. GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU MA'AM THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. AT THE TIME ENOUGH
OTHER ARE CLOSING Q. OPERATOR
WE DO ONE MORE SWEEP PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT YOU IMPRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AS OF
NOW WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WITH THAT I WILL
TAKE THAT AS THE CLOSE OF
PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD LIKE TO-
IN THIS HEARING WITH AN
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THE- WORK
THAT TO EVERYONE HAS DONE FROM
THE SERGEANTS TO OUR STAFF AND
IN PARTICULAR TO ANDREA MERKEL
LIST. JUST WANTED TO APPRECIATE
ALL OUR WORK ON THE AGENDA WITH
THAT WILL CLOSE TODAY'S HEARING
AND ADJOURNED.